foreign
you might have heard of several Cyber
attack cases where companies have lost
their crucial data money reputation and
customer trust these attacks are carried
out by hackers who exploit weaknesses in
a computer network to gain unauthorized
access to Vital Information however
hacking is not always bad as there are
hackers who work with different motives
white hat hackers also known as ethical
hackers hack with permission to defend
an organization this form of hacking is
legal it is known as ethical hacking
ethical hacking is distributed into six
different phases the first phase is
reconnaissance where you collect all the
required information next is the
scanning phase where you try to spot any
system vulnerability
following this is the gaining access
phase where the spotted vulnerabilities
are exploited in the next stage known as
maintaining access you try to maintain
your access for future attacks by
installing back doors
the fifth phase is clearing tracks where
you clear all the evidence of the hack
and finally in the reporting phase you
document the summary of the entire
attack
there is and there will always be high
demand for ethical hackers who can
Safeguard organizations from cyber
attacks so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become
an ethical hacker and put an end to the
cyber attacks in the world this was
ethical hacking in short when most
people hear the expression hacking they
see someone attacking their computer
with a virus crashing a network and
stealing money or enslaving a firm with
ransomware most people are unaware that
ethical hackers are paid to think like a
hacker or Bad actors they methodically
explore a company's system for Flaws and
bring them to the notice of the
management before the Bad actors use
them
ethical hacking is an investment that
modern businesses cannot afford to
ignore
hackers will spend countless hours
understanding every bit and bite to
circumvent and breach systems they
become specialist in the business
systems Gathering all the information
they can discover and utilizing all they
learn to construct a complex assault
based on a series of activities
these activities then inflict
significant harm to the company's
systems and overall organizations all of
these acts cannot be replicated by
automated Technologies on their own in
contrast to humans who can watch
recognize learn and adjust an automated
forensics tool cannot discover a
scenario that it has not been designed
to locate this makes the ethical hacking
industry an absolute necessity
today we're going to take you through
the field of ethical hacking teaching
the Inside Out mechanism of this
profession we start by learning about
the basics of ethical hacking and the
multiple applications of penetration
testing in the ID sector we take a look
at the most infamous hacks and hackers
that made headlines on a global scale
due to their criminal activities in the
cyber world
next we learn about the best tools and
programming languages being used by
professional ethical hackers on a daily
basis these are the same tools being
used by the malicious actors when trying
to breach confidential barriers and
firewalls
moving on read about a couple of
operating systems that are catered
specifically to ethical hackers or
penetration testers
relax based distributions by Nature
these operating systems come with all
major ethical hacking tools and scripts
pre-installed making everyday work
easier for the professionals
in the next section we learn about the
most well-known cyber attacks like
ransomware and DDOS attack being
employed on a daily basis by Mauritius
hackers these attacks affect the general
consumer in order to steal private
information to battle these threats we
are going to have a look at some tools
which can do the same for users like
vpns and the tord network finally we go
over the multiple roles in a cyber
security team and it's a popular
certifications along with the relevant
study materials with regards to
beginners and ethical hacking we humans
are highly tech savvy in today's times
with the extensive use of the internet
and modern Technologies there is a
massive challenge in protecting all our
Digital Data such as net banking
information account credentials and
medical reports to name a few have you
heard about the deadly what a cry
ransomware attack the attack happened in
May 2017 in Asia and then it spread
across the world within a day more than
230 000 computers were infected across
150 countries the wannacry cry crypto
worm encrypted the data and locked the
users out of their systems for
decryption of the data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 in
Bitcoin the users who use the
unsupported version of Microsoft Windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of April 2017 were
targeted in this attack the one a cry
attack took a toll on every sector
top-tier organizations like Hitachi sun
and FedEx had to put their businesses on
hold as their systems were affected too
now this is what you call a Cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented we can Define cyber
security as the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital attacks these illegal attacks
are often referred to as hacking
hacking refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network to obtain
unauthorized access to information a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
into computer systems this is a
misconception that hacking is always
wrong there are hackers who work with
different motives let's have a look at
three different types of hackers black
hat hackers are individuals who
illegally hack into a system for a
monetary gain on the contrary we have
white hat hackers who exploit the
vulnerabilities in a system by hacking
into it with permission in order to
defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers in addition to these
hackers we also have the gray hat
hackers as the name suggests the color
gray is a blend of both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in a system and report it to the
system's owner which is a good act but
they do this without seeking the owner's
approval sometimes gray hat hackers also
ask for money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand more
about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking through an
interesting story Dan runs a Trading
Company he does online training with the
money his customers invest everything
was going well and Dan's business was
booming until a hacker decided to hack
the company's servers the hackers stole
the credentials of various trading
accounts he asked for a lump sum Ransom
in exchange for the stolen credentials
Dan took the Hacker's words lightly and
didn't pay the hacker as a result the
hacker withdrew money from various
customers accounts and Dan was liable to
pay back the customers
Dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers after this
incident Dan gave a lot of thought as to
what could have gone wrong with the
security infrastructure in his company
he wished there was someone from his
company who could have run a test attack
to see how vulnerable systems were
before the hacker penetrated into the
network
he realized he needed an employee who
thinks like a hacker and identifies the
vulnerabilities in his Network before an
outsider does
to do this job he hired an ethical
hacker John
John was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in Dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation
so now you know hacking is not always
bad John in this scenario exposed the
vulnerabilities in the existing Network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases let us look at
these faces step by step with respect to
how John our ethical hacker will act
before launching an attack the first
step Jon takes is to gather all the
necessary information about the
organization's system that he intends to
attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like nmap
and hping for this purpose
John then tries to spot the
vulnerabilities if any in the Target
system using tools like nmap and Expos
this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access after John makes his way through
the organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the Target
system the Metasploit tool helps him
with this this phase is called
maintaining access John is a brilliant
hacker hence he tries his best not to
leave any evidence of his attack this is
the fifth phase clearing tracks we now
have the last phase that is reported in
this phase John documents a summary of
his entire attack the vulnerabilities he
spotted the tools he used and the
success rate of the attack
looking into the report Dan is now able
to take a call and see how to protect
his organization from any external cyber
attacks don't you all think Jon is an
asset to any organization if you want to
become an ethical hacker like John then
there are a few skills that you need to
acquire first and foremost you need to
have a good knowledge of operating
environments such as Windows Linux Unix
and Macintosh
you must have reasonably good knowledge
of programming languages such as HTML
PHP python SQL and JavaScript networking
is the base of ethical hacking hence you
should be good at it ethical hackers
should be well aware of security laws so
that they don't misuse their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker like John few examples of
ethical hacking certification are
certified ethical hacker certification
ceh CompTIA pin Test Plus and license
penetration tester certification to name
a few
simply learn provides a cyber security
expert master's program that will equip
you with all the skills required by a
cyber security expert you could have a
look at it by clicking the link in the
description so here's a question for you
in which phase of ethical hacking will
you install back doors in the Target
system a scanning B maintaining access C
clearing tracks D reconnaissance
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below the
endless growth of Technologies in this
area is directly proportional to the
number of cyber crimes cyber crimes are
estimated to cost 6 trillion dollars in
2021. hence to tackle these cyber crimes
organizations are continuously on the
lookout for cyber Security Professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is ninety one thousand
dollars in the U.S and approximately
rupees 7 lakhs in India
so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an ethical hacker
like John and put an end to the cyber
attacks in the world computers have made
our lives more effortless than ever
however computer viruses have been
trouble since day one on that note hey
guys welcome to yet another exciting
video by simply learn this video brings
you the top six most dangerous computer
viruses of all time
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting Tech videos every
day so moving on here's a list of the
most dangerous computer virus let's see
what we have at number one at number one
we have my do my Doom is one of the
worst computer virus outbreaks at
history in 2004. this malware is
technically a worm spread by mass
emailing it broke previous marks set by
the soapic worm and I love you to become
the fastest spreading email worm ever
email spammers appear to have hired my
Doom to spread spam via compromised PCS
users will open an attachment named mail
transaction fails that will be sent to
the victim its objective was to take
down popular websites like Google and
lycos my Doom cost estimated damage of
38 billion dollars in 2004 but its
inflation and gested cost is 52.2
billion US dollars
by that figure my Dome has taken on a
life of its own infecting enough poorly
protected machines to send 1.2 billion
copies of itself per year 16 years after
its creation my Doom one of the most
widely distributed viruses infected one
out of every 12 emails at its height my
Dome hit companies like Google SEO group
and Microsoft with the distributed
denial of service attack in 2004 16 to
25 percent of all emails had been
infected by mindu on that note here's a
question for you which is the latest
deadly computer virus you have heard of
do let us know in the comment section
below
[Music]
number two we have I love you the I love
you virus of 2000s spread by delivering
a fake love letter that appeared to be a
harmless text file this attacker like my
Doom sends copies of itself to all of
the email addresses on the infected
machines contact list it had spread to
over 10 million PCS within a few days
after its May 4 release
[Music]
a college student from the Philippines
invented the virus he created the virus
to collect credentials to log into
internet sites he wanted to utilize for
free since he was shot on cash according
to reports he had no clue how far his
work would travel love letter is another
name for this virus
at number 3 on the list of dangerous
computer viruses we have code read code
red was a computer worm that emerged in
July 2001 and infected computers running
Microsoft's IIs web server the code red
worm had been released on July 13th but
on July 19 2001 another variant of the
worms spread rapidly and was reported to
infect over 250 000 computers in just
nine hours on that day the total number
of infected hosts reached 359
000.
the worm defaced the affected websites
to display the hacked by Chinese text
stream it was the first large scale
thread that could successfully Target
Enterprise networks in August 2001 the
guardian reported that the FBI had
issued serious warnings to organizations
asking them to safeguard themselves
against this worm at number 4 we have
crypto Locker
the crypto virus popularly known as
crypto Locker is a ransomware virus that
encrypts files on a computer and Demands
a ransom in return for a decryption code
the crypto Locker malware spread between
early September 2013 and late May 2014.
the primary means of infection was via
phishing emails with malicious
attachments it was identified as a
trojan virus that targeted computers
running different versions of the
Windows operating system once the crypto
Locker is launched it encrypts many
files on a user's computer or hard
drives servers and other storage devices
throughout the organization crypto virus
attacks are rising with over 4000
attacks each day as per the US
government estimates more than one
billion dollars is paid in Ransom each
year
at number 5 we have Melissa the Melissa
virus was one of the biggest and
earliest cyber threats in history
released in March 1999 Melissa started
spreading via email infecting thousands
of computers within ours the virus was
sent in a file called list.talk which
contained passwords to censored websites
so when users downloaded the file and
opened it in Microsoft Word a macro
inside the document was executed and
emailed the list talk file to 50 people
listed in the user's email Alias file
email servers at more than 300 companies
and government agencies worldwide became
overloaded and some had to be shut down
entirely as per the usfpi report the
estimated cost for cleaning and
repairing affected computer systems was
18 million dollars and finally at number
six on the list of most dangerous
computer viruses we have Slammer on
Saturday January 25th 2003 the internet
was hit by a wish's computer worm known
as SQL slam
it brought down most of the world's SQL
servers and slowed down internet traffic
Bank ATMs were down Slammer was 376
bytes of malicious code that attempted
to connect to every computer it could
find over Ms SQL UDP Port 1434 causing
heavy Network traffic it is believed to
have infected over 75 000 systems within
10 minutes SQL Slammer was the fastest
spreading computer worm in history The
New York Times reported that Microsoft
admitted that some of its machines had
gone unpatched and that its MSN internet
service also had significant slowdowns
due to the slammer work according to
cyber security Ventures the global
cybercrime cost is expected to grow and
reach 10.5 trillion US Dollars by 2025.
that's the cost we have to pay for cyber
crimes in this video we bring you the
top 10 dangerous computer hackers of all
the time at number 10 we have Johnson
James Ancira in the year 2006 Johnson
James Angela of Downey California was
charged for controlling huge number of
Partners In other words hijacked
computers this was the first time that a
hacker who was sent to prison for the
use of botnet technology and should I
use botnets to compromise more than 400
000 computers advertising companies paid
him to install adware or bots on
specified systems it is also noted that
and cheetah advertised the sale of his
podcasts to those interested in sending
spam or launching D Rose attacks without
being identified he was also pleaded
guilty for infecting machines at two U.S
military sites which earned him more
than sixty one thousand dollars Joss and
James Angela was captured in a
well-planned and elaborate stink
operation when FBI agents coaxed him in
their office on the pretext of
collecting computer equipment he was
sentenced to nearly 60 months of
imprisonment and was ordered to pay 15
000 US dollars to the US federal
government for hacking their military
computers at number nine we have andren
lamo lamo began his hacking journey by
hacking games he was more likely a gray
head hacker who wanted people to
understand the importance of Internet
Security
however it went far ahead when he hacked
the New York Times intranet in 2002. he
was called the homeless hacker for his
transient lifestyle and he often had no
fixed address he used to hack top-notch
accounts by sitting in cafeterias
libraries and so on he was convicted for
compromising security at the New York
Times Microsoft and Yahoo to name a few
he later gained the batch of an American
threat analyst he also appeared on Good
Morning America Fox News democracy Now
Etc as an expert on netcentric crime and
incidents lamo died in the year 2018 at
the age of 37. at number 8 we have Kevin
Paulson a former American black hat
hacker in the hacker Community he is
better known as dark Dante at the age of
17 he hacked the U.S Department of
Defense but he was left with a warning
as he was a minor later in 1990 he
propelled the stardom for infiltrating a
radio show calling contest and
guaranteeing that he will be the 102nd
caller to win the brand new Porsche 944s
team the FBI stated pursuing Paulson and
was soon arrested and sentenced to a
five years of imprisonment he was also
barred from using a computer or Internet
for three years post his release later
he took into white hat hacking and
journalism in the Year 2005 he became a
senior editor of wired news at number 7
we have the famous American hacker
Jonathan James bernones comrade he was
the first juvenile in the United States
to be sent to prison for hacking this
famous hack was his intrusion into the
defense threat reduction agency or the
tra computers a division of the United
States Department of Defense he
installed a back door on its servers
this enabled him to access over 3 000
messages from government employees
various usernames passwords and other
confidential data
this helped change seal a piece of NASA
software and this forced NASA to shut
down computers for three weeks to fix
the issue at an estimated cost of 41 000
American dollars he was sentenced to six
months arrest in 2000. he carried out
his hacking using the Alias comrade he
specialized in hacking high profile
continent systems however he had a
better ending in 2008. moving on to our
hacker at number six at number six we
have anonymous
the anonymous group is an international
decentralized hacktivist movement that
is widely known for its cyber attacks
against several governments its agencies
and the Church of Scientology this group
is focused on the concept of social
justice the members of this group known
as anons are recognized in public by
wearing guy Fox masks however some
members cover their face without using
the well-known masks as well they are
known as being the digital Robin Hood
amongst its supporters one of the noted
incidents was in the year 2008 when the
group took up issue with the Church of
Scientology and began to disable their
websites they are also known for hacking
Vatican the FBI PayPal Sony the CIA
MasterCard Visa the Israeli Chinese
tunison and Ugandan garments while the
law enforcement agencies and FBI have
tracked down a few of the group's
members the lack of any proper hierarchy
makes it all almost impossible to
distinguish or eliminate the anonymous
groups as a whole at number 5 we have
the British deal Martha Raven and
Richard Price in 1994 the do hacked into
multiple U.S military systems including
the defense information system agency
Griffis Air Force Base and the Korean
automatic Research Institute they
infiltrated into foreign systems by
transferring critical data of Korean
automatic Research Institute into the
United States Air Force system in 1996
Babin was arrested for hacking incidents
related to U.S Air Force defense
manufacturer Lockheed NASA and NATO
the Pentagon described beaven as the
number one threat to U.S security and
possibly the single biggest threat to
World Peace since Adolf Hitler however
we even claims he was looking to prove a
UFO conspiracy theory in 1997 price was
fined 1200 pounds after pleading guilty
to 12 offenses of gaining unauthorized
access to computer assistance in March
and April 1994. having malicious
purposes or not even in price displayed
that even military networks are
vulnerable now moving on to a hacker at
number four at number 4 we have Astra
this hacker is a tad bit different from
the others on this list as he has never
been publicly identified the pen name of
this hacker Astra is a Sanskrit word for
a weapon in 2008 it was reported that
the authorities apprehended him at that
time he was known as a 58 year old Greek
mathematician he hacked into France's
distort group systems and got his hands
on vulnerable weapons technology data
and then sold it to different countries
for a long period Astra was reported to
have sold the data to nearly 250 people
from across the world this in turn
caused the salt 360 million US dollars
of damage while the astra's real
identity was never discovered officials
have said that he had been wanted since
the year 2002. at number three we have
the famous American computer hacker
Albert Gonzalez he was responsible for
carrying out multiple hacks he is
accused of masterminding the biggest
fraud in history that is the combined
credit card theft and reselling of
nearly
170 million car and ATM numbers from the
Year 2005 to 2007. this shows how unsafe
internet banking can be at times this
was recorded to be one of the biggest
credit card thefts in history he carried
out this by installing a sniffer Albert
Gonzalez has also said to have been The
Mastermind of the TJX companies hack
wherein 45.6 million debit and Credit
numbers were stolen later in 2010 he was
sentenced to 20 year in federal prison
moving on to a hacker at number two at
number 2 we have Gary mckinson he is a
Scottish systems administrator and
hacker accused of carrying out the
biggest military computer hack of all
time in 2002 he identified himself as
solo through a note message on a U.S
army computer it was later found to be
Gary mckinson he was accused of
infiltrating 97 United States military
and NASA computers by installing virus
and deleting a few files over 13 months
between February 2001 and March 2002.
this was the biggest military commuter
attack of all time this shutdown the U.S
military's Washington Network for 24
hours what is fascinating is his reason
that much of his hacking was in search
of information on UFOs that he believed
the US government was hiding in its
military computers and finally let's see
who we have at number one at number one
we have Kevin metnik the now affluent
American entrepreneur was one of the
most Wanted cyber criminal of us Once
Upon a Time Kevin who is currently a
security consultant was once convicted
of hacking controller Nokia and Pentagon
Kevin mastered computer hacking and
social engineering early and got his
start as a team in 1982 he had the North
American Defense command this
achievement inspired the 1983 film war
games in 1989 he hacked digital
equipment corporations Network and made
copies of their software it's largely
believed that he once obtained full
control of Pacific Bells Network to
merely prove that it could be done he
never exploited the data he obtained
according to reports mitnik gained
unauthorized access to a dozens of
computer networks while he was a
fugitive after five years of
imprisonment midnik started afresh and
became a security consultant his neck
with computers is still remembered all
of these hackers were unbelievably
skilled in cyber Court few of them faced
Trail in time a few of others ever since
put their cyber skills to better use by
becoming security advisors and helping
humankind hacking skills aren't a form
of criminal Behavior if it is put to
good use so with that we have come to an
end of this video on top 10 dangerous
hackers of all time in this video we
bring you the top 10 computer hacks of
all time let's see what we have at
number 10. from April 27 2007 Estonia
the European country faced a series of
cyber attacks that lasted for weeks this
happened when the Estonian government
decided to move the bronze soldier from
Thailand Center to a less prominent
military cemetery located on the city's
outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down Estonian Banks online services
media Outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnitz sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated Online
requests according to researchers the
public faced DDOS attacks there were
conflicts to edit the English language
version of The Bronze soldiers Wikipedia
page as well although there is no
confirmation Russia is believed to be
behind these cyber attacks that largely
crippled the Estonian Society let's now
move on to the next attack on December
23 2015 several parts of Ukraine
witnessed a power outage and this was
not a typical blackout it was indeed the
result of a Cyber attack
Information Systems of three energy
distribution companies in Ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
Victorious Cyber attack on a par grid it
is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were Switched Off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours U.S
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a Cyber attack cost a
21-day shutdown of NASA computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
Jonathan James he first penetrated U.S
Department of Defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails including
the ones containing usernames and
passwords this helped James steal a
piece of NASA software and crack the
NASA computers that support the
International Space Station which caused
a space exploration agency's 41 000
assistance were shut down for three
weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the American space
agency let's now move on to the next
attack in late November 2014 there was a
leak of confidential data from the film
studio of Sony Pictures
information about Sony Pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased Sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked this Cyber attack was carried out
by a hacker grouped named Guardians Of
Peace so what did the hackers want well
they demanded that Sony withdraw its
then upcoming movie the interview this
movie was a comedy storyline to
assassinate the North Korean leader Kim
Jong-un Sony then decided to cancel the
film's theatrical release due to their
threats at Cinema screening the movie it
is indeed hard to trace the roots of a
Cyber attack in this case after
evaluation the U.S intelligence
officials arrived at the theory that the
attack was in a way related to the
government of North Korea
however North Korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six in December
2006 TJX the U.S retailer company
identified that 45.6 million debit and
credit card details were stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data as a result banks
in the affected regions had to reissue
and block thousands of payment cards a
group of hackers did this Albert
Gonzalez being The Mastermind the group
was from Miami the place where the TJX
Heist was believed to have originated
reports said that the TJX data breach
occurred because of weak web encryption
at two of its martial stores in Miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet this
malware's motive was unlike any other
usual cyber attacks it aimed at
distracting the equipment the computers
controlled
stuxnet came a deadly purpose of
damaging Iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 Industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in Iran
stuxnet initially spread via Microsoft
Windows and targeted Siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
It is believed to have been silently
sabotaging Iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuges of the Iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the US and the Israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same moving on to number four in
the year 2014 Home Depot was the victim
of one of the deadliest cyber attacks 56
million payment cards were compromised
along with 53 million customer email
addresses stolen
the security breach happened from April
to September 2014. criminals were
believed to have used a third party
vendors username and password to enter
the perimeter of Home Depot's Network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom-built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the U.S and
Canada moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the PlayStation
gaming system is one of Sony's most
popular products unfortunately in April
2011 Sony Executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the PlayStation Network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million PlayStation
users accounts and prevented users of
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation Portable
consoles from accessing the service
this forced Sony to turn off the
PlayStation Network on April 20th on May
4th Sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days Sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
Sony is believed to have invested
approximately 170 million dollars to
improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in May
2017 one of the most dangerous cyber
attacks took place
it was known as the wannacry ransomware
attack caused by the wannacry crypto
worm the victims were the users that
used the unsupported version of
Microsoft Windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update
this did not take place through phishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable SMB port
the attack originated in Asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than 200 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cry crypto worm locked the
users out of their targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via Bitcoin in
exchange for their data this attack took
a toll on both private and government
organizations it resulted in Damages
from hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars
in a matter of few days the emergency
patches released by Microsoft halted the
attack also the discovery of a kill
switch prevented the infected computers
from spreading the crypto worm Security
Experts in a few countries believed that
North Korea was behind this attack and
finally let's see what we have at number
one more than two decades ago in March
1999 the Melissa virus a mass mailing
macro virus was released it targeted
Microsoft Word and outlook-based systems
and created considerable Network traffic
Melissa virus infected computers via
emails the email would look like an
important message well yes it was fake
if the recipient opens the attachments
in the mail and downwards the document
and then opens it with Microsoft Word a
virus was released on their computers
this would then Mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victim's contact
list and then disable multiple Safeguard
features on Microsoft Word and Microsoft
Outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet David L
Smith released the virus the virus cost
nearly 80 million worth of Damages it
did not steal data or money however it
cost a Havoc almost 1 million email
accounts were disrupted worldwide
agencies were overloaded and some had to
be shut down entirely and internet
traffic in some locations were slowed
down so with that we come to the end of
this video on the top 10 computer hacks
of all time do you agree with our list
if you're aware of any other great
interesting computer hacks in history do
let us know in the comment section below
hey everyone welcome to this video where
we look into the rampant spyware program
that is the Pegasus service before we
learn about the Pegasus platform let us
understand what spyware is and it's
working spyware is a category of male
web that can gather information
regarding a user or a device straight
from the host machine it is mostly
spread by malicious links via email or
chat applications when a link with the
malware is received clicking on this
link will activate the spyware which
allows the hacker to spy on all our user
information
but some spyware systems even clicking
on the link isn't necessary to trigger
the malicious payload
this can ultimately cause security
complications and further loss of
privacy
one such spyware system that is making
the rounds in the tech industry today is
Pegasus the Pegasus is a spyware system
developed by an Israeli company known as
the NSO group it runs on mainly mobile
devices spanning across the major
operating systems like the Apple's IOS
on iPhone and the standard Android
versions this is not a newly developed
platform since Pegasus has existed since
as early as 2016. a highly intricate
spyware program that can track user
location read text messages scan through
mobile files access device camera and
microphone to record voice and video
Pegasus has all the tools necessary to
enforce surveillance for any clan that
wishes to buy its services initially the
NSO group had designed the software to
be used against terrorist factions of
the world with more and more encrypted
communication channels coming to the
Forefront Pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
National Security unfortunately the
people who bought the software had
complete control over who how and up to
what level they can put surveillance
limits on
eventually the primary clients became
Sovereign Nations spying on Public
Information that is supposed to stay
private became really easy with this
service
multiple devices can be affected with
the same spyware system to create a
network information this network keeps
feeding data to the host to understand
how a network can be created let's know
how a mobile device can be affected by
Pegasus
we all communicate with friends and
family over instant messaging
applications and email in some instances
if you check your inbox on a regular
basis you must have noticed that we
received some spam emails that the mail
providers like Gmail and Yahoo can just
filter into the spam folder some of
these messages bypass this filter and
make their way into a person's inbox
they look like generic emails which are
supposed to be safe the Pegasus spyware
targets such occurrences bypassing
malicious messages and links which
install the necessary Spy software on
the user's mobile device be it Android
or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS Stacks WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threema once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the spyware is successfully
installed the perpetrator who sent the
payload to the victim can monitor
everything the user does
Pegasus can collect private emails
passwords images videos and every other
piece of information that passes through
the device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
by the primary spying organization can
monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex spyware software like
Pegasus can access the roots files on
our mobiles these root files hold
information that is crucial to the
working of the Android and iOS operating
systems
taking such private information is a
massive blow to the security and the
privacy of an individual the information
that may seem trivial like the name of
your Wi-Fi connection or the last time
you ordered an item from Amazon that
indeed all valuable information this
exploitation is primarily possible due
to the zero day vulnerabilities known as
bugs in the software development process
the zero day bugs are the ones that have
just been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do
however many such critical bugs make
their way onto the dark web where
hackers can use them to create exploits
these exploits are then sent to innocent
users with a link or a message like we
had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers others cannot
be fixed without breaking some core
functionality these become the Gateway
for spyware to enter into the system
you can never be 100 safe but you sure
can give it all in protecting yourself
the one thing where Pegasus stands out
is that zero click action feature
usually in spam emails the malicious
code is activated when the user clicks
the malware link a user doesn't need to
click the link in the new version of the
Pegasus and a few other spyware programs
once the message arrives in the inbox of
WhatsApp Gmail or any other chat
applications the spyware gets activated
and everything can be recorded and sent
back to the central server the primary
issue with being affected by spyware as
a victim is detection
unlike crypto Miners and Trojans spying
Services usually do not demand many
system resources which makes them tough
to detect after they have been activated
since many devices slow down after a
couple of years any kind of Performance
Set due to such spyware is often
attributed to poor software longevity by
the users they do not check meticulously
for any other causes that is causing the
Slowdown
when left unchecked these devices can
capture voice and video from the mobile
sensors while keeping the owner in the
dark let's take a moment to check if you
are well aware of the causes of such
attacks how do users fall prey to such
spyware programs a by installing
untested software B by clicking on the
third party links from email and
messages
see by not keeping their apps and phones
updated or D all of the above let us
know your answers in the comment section
below and we will revive the correct
answer next week but what about the
unaffected devices the vulnerable ones
while we cannot be certain of our
security there are a few things we can
do to boost our device be it against
Pegasus or the next big spyware on the
market
let's say we are safe now and we have
the time to take the necessary steps to
prevent a spyware attack what are the
things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated with the latest security patches
the vulnerabilities that the exploits
Target are often discovered by
developers from Google and apple which
send the security patches quickly
this can be done for individual apps as
well so keeping them updated is of
utmost importance
while the most secure devices have
fallen prey to Pegasus as well a
security patch from developers may help
in minimizing the damage at a later
stage or maybe negate the entire spiral
platform altogether another big factor
is the spread of malware is the trend of
side loading Android applications using
dot APK files downloading such apps from
a third party website have no security
checks involved and are mostly
responsible for adware and spyware
invasions on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into a
device you should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains
spyware is a controversial segment in
governance while the ramifications are
pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes
sufficient resources and a contingent
plan can alter the false will of
democracy altogether
even if our daily life is rather
simplistic we must understand that
privacy is not about what we have to
hide in instead it portrays the things
we have to protect it stands for
everything we have to share with the
outside world both rhetorically and
literally if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
in this video we are going to discuss
what is ethical hacking now take this as
an example there is an organization that
keeps on getting compromised or keeps on
getting attacked repeatedly every month
and they're at a loss of why exactly
this is happening so an employee comes
up with a brilliant idea of hiring an
ethical hacking or a hiring an ethical
hacker to test the security systems the
bosses agree and the company ends up
hiring ethical hacker now what this
hacker does is they try to test all the
security controls that the organization
has implemented all the applications
maybe even the databases and then they
start giving a report so here you can
see that they are trying to test the
firewall maybe fire viruses malices
queries towards the firewall hack the
company's website test the company's
websites any applications that the
company is utilizing and try to analyze
the responses that they're going to get
so they're trying to emulate a hacker
scenario where a hacker is trying to
attack and trying to figure out the
vulnerabilities and the areas for
compromise to the organization's
infrastructure so once the report is
ready they would be submitting the
report to the organization and they
would then give recommendations of how
to enhance the security posture of the
organization once the security posture
is enhanced the likelihood of the
organization getting compromised reduces
drastically thus the organization
becomes a lot more secure than it was
before and this is what we are going to
discuss in this video so first and
foremost we are going to discuss what is
ethical hacking we are going to talk
about the types of hackers we are
looking at phases of ethical hacking
common types of attacks that are
possible on networks and other systems
and then we are talking about
certification and job rules in the cyber
security space as well so what exactly
is ethical hacking ethical hacking is
locating weaknesses or vulnerabilities
of computers and information system
using the intent and actions of a
malicious hacker now the difference here
is the intent a malicious hacker will
try to gain something for their own
personal gains or try to cause damage to
the other organization here the intent
of the ethical hacker is to identify
possible flaws and vulnerabilities
weaknesses and then try to enhance the
security on those weaknesses by
mitigating those weaknesses thus
preventing malicious Hackers from
getting access so the intent is the
complete other way around where a
malicious hiker may be looking at
gaining personally from these attacks
where ethical hacker would prevent the
vulnerability thus prevent the hack from
happening in the first place an ethical
hacker is an expert who penetrates a
computer system or network on behalf of
its owners to find security
availabilities that the hacker can
exploit so the difference between the
hacker and ethical hacker here is that
the hacker is not authorized by the
organization whereas in case of ethical
hacker it's the organization themselves
who have hired the services of the
ethical hacker to test the security
controls to test the network to test
applications and find out flaws within
them so that they can be fixed ethical
lacker is also known as a penetration
tester so the job rule here is to find
vulnerabilities and to fix them so that
malicious hikers may not be able to
misuse them what are the advantages of
hiring an ethical hacker in an
organization first and foremost ethical
hackers can emulate or simulate the
scenarios that a hacker would they have
the same knowledge might use the same
tools except for the intent so they will
be able to identify the security threats
for the organization once the security
threats have been mitigated the
organization can actually focus on their
business and increase productivity once
the attacks have been mitigated and the
compromises have been minimized the
organization can full flesh walk towards
their goals their objectives of the
business and be more productive the
reputation of the company can be
safeguarded we obviously don't want to
deal with organizations that keep on
repeatedly getting hacked and compromise
our data we wouldn't trust those
organizations with our private and
personal data in the first place which
means that this is going to inspire
customer confidence the customer would
feel that if the organization is secure
and is able to protect themselves they
would be able to protect the customers
data and customers private information
as well which is the protection for your
customers or clients so this can be
advertised as by the organization saying
we have ethical hackers we do proactive
approach towards our security measures
we have Integrated Security mechanisms
in place we are safe we have been tested
and we can prove that we are security
compliant once the customers come to
know about this customers would feel a
lot more safer to deal with such
organizations after discussing the
advantages of hiring an ethical hacker
let's discuss the types of hackers the
first classification is of a black hat
hacker these people are individuals with
extraordinary Computing skills which
means they are very intelligent they can
program quite a bit they know everything
about hacking and these guys are experts
however the intent is malicious or
destructive in nature they would want to
harm the victim and gain possibly
monetarily from these kind of activities
some of these people would do it for fun
and ego boost if you will the second
classification is of a gray hat hacker
these are individuals who work
offensively as well as defensively so at
times they can for an agenda become a
black hat hacker gain out of it hack
without authorization and at times they
can actually accept a contract from an
organization to help them enhance the
security of that organization and then
there are white hat hackers these are
individuals professing the same skills
that offer black hat or a gray hat they
might use the same tools persist the
same knowledge except for the intent
their intent Is Not to cause harm but to
protect the organization and enhance the
security skills These Are People Like Us
these are ethical hackers who
essentially try to emulate or simulate
the attacks from a blackhead hikers
perspective to find out the flaws and
then try to mitigate them try to enhance
the security posture of the organization
to prevent that organization from
getting hacked and then there are
suicide hackers these are individual
visuals who bring down critical
infrastructure for a cause the main
difference between the black hat hikers
and suicide hikers is that black hat
hikers will try to hide their identity
suicide hikers do not in fact they will
claim responsibility for the attacks
that they have done then we have script
kiddies these are unskilled hackers they
have no idea what they're doing they may
not be technically very Adept but they
rely on tools already created by black
hat hackers and then try to use those
tools and leverage them to try to hack
an organization a cyber terrorist would
be any organization or individual who
are motivated by religious or political
beliefs and they try to create fear by
large-scale disruption of computer
networks so they might attack countries
they might attack organizations to
promote their political or religious
causes and might create harm to the
population at large state sponsored
hackers are individuals who are employed
by the government to spy on neighboring
countries or their enemies the attempt
is to gain top secret information that
would be damaging to other governments
which would enhance the security posture
of one one's own country now this is not
an official job profile but it's a known
fact that most of the governments have
hired uh hackers to spy on other
countries and other organizations then
there are activists individuals who want
to promote a political agenda by hacking
and defacing websites these guys do not
infrastructure they just hack
websites deface them put their own
propaganda on the face of the website to
promote whatever political messages that
they want to promote now let's talk
about the phases of ethical hacking
ethical hacking is distributed in five
different phases they are the
reconnaissance phase scanning gaining
access maintaining access and covering
tracks the first phase the requirements
phase is all about information gathering
here you're trying to identify the
target trying to get to know the target
gathering information about the target
could be digital in nature could be any
personal information or organizational
information that you can leverage later
on for social engineering attacks as
well here you might try to find out from
a technical perspective the IP addresses
domain names subdomains email addresses
phone numbers of people working in the
organization once you have all this
information you would then proceed to
the scanning phase we are going to
actively scan for devices that are live
and can you can interact with then
you're going to scan those live devices
to identify ports protocols and services
running on those systems now these ports
are protocols these would be your entry
points to try to gain access to that
system it is here where those flaws
would exist so in this phase you're
basically identifying which ports are
open which services are running on top
of them what protocols are being
utilized by the machine once you have
identified this you might want to
enumerate them by gathering more
information from a specific protocol and
then you might want to go into the
vulnerability scanning phase where
you're going to scan these Services
protocols for vulnerabilities and to
create a list of all the possible
vulnerabilities in that system once you
have the list of possible
vulnerabilities you are going to move on
to the gaining access phase where you're
going to attack those vulnerabilities
try to exploit them and try to gain
access or embed a trojan virus key
logger or any software that can spy on
the victim once you have hacked into
this machine you are going to try to
maintain access maintaining an access is
you're trying to retain those access for
a longer period of time so you can spy
on the device spy on the user try to
collect more information as time goes on
you're not going to rely on the hack
forever because the hack May no longer
work after a period of time especially
if the system gets patched up or
somebody runs an antivirus scan or
figures out something is wrong
maintaining access is where you're going
to install a back door and unauthorized
back door obviously without the
knowledge of the victim which will allow
you to interact with the machine or
gather information from the machine
without any hindrance once you have
installed these kind of soft to as you
don't want them to be discovered that's
where the covering tracks come into the
picture when you have installed a root
cater Trojan a spyware it will create
directories it will create files in this
phase the covering tracks you're going
to try to erase the trace of the
creation of these files when you're
accessing something while maintaining
access or gaining access there would be
logs that would be created by the
applications which would announce what
you've been doing in the coverage
covering tracks phase you will be trying
to delete those logs and try to erase
the traces of your activity as well so
in these five phases the entire Gambit
of ethical hacking is covered let's move
on to discuss the common types of
attacks the first and foremost and the
most common attack in today's world is
that the denial of service attack or a
distributed denial of service attack
this attack is launched by attacker not
to not for personal gain but to harm the
other organization by crashing those
services or making the services
unavailable for legitimate users thus
causing monetary harm and reputational
harm to the organization they actually
try to restrict the access to these
resources for legitimate users by
consuming all the bandwidth or the
resources made available then there are
password attacks these attacks are
essentially where you're trying to crack
the password of a user so that you can
get access to their account and through
their access you can then leverage those
access and capture data that you
wouldn't have otherwise gotten access to
when man in the middle attack is where
you are trying to capture data packets
over the network that are flying between
the victim and the target server so
essentially placing yourself between the
communication channel that has been
opened between the victim and the
targeted server and you're trying to
capture the data package you're trying
to analyze those data packets and
capture any secret information like
usernames passwords any other
transactions that the user might be
doing then you have email attacks the
attacker sends bait often in the form of
an email so these would be your phishing
attacks that would come under the Gambit
of social engineering phishing attacks
are nothing but fake males that look
very genuine to the end user and thus
persuade to click on links that lead to
malicious servers thus compromising the
device of the victim SQL injection
attacks are normally targeted to
websites or web applications that have a
database connected to them the database
and the application interactive with
each other using SQL language or
structured query language if not
configured properly and if there are no
firewalls watching a user can craft
malicious SQL queries which can then
dump data or give out unwanted
information to the hacker that should
have been protected in the first place
and then if you have the eavesdropping
attack where the attacker observes the
traffic on the system and works and the
work you are doing on your computer
eavesdropping could be where your truck
you're tracking VoIP calls or you have
installed a Trojan on somebody's mobile
phones and you're trying looking at all
that information let's look at the
certifications that are available in
this field the foundational knowledge
that you would require is a graduate in
computerized science or any ID security
related field most of the universe
universities nowadays provide this kind
of certifications you should have solid
grounds in ID fundamentals that means
you should be technically very Adept you
should understand how protocols work how
networking works you should be somewhat
convergent with some scripting languages
and should be able to understand
programming knowing networking and
mastering networking is a very
fundamental requirement even if you
later on decide to go into application
security and you're looking at
programming languages applications still
work over the network and you need to
know how these networks are going to be
configured and how data is going to be
transmitted over this network coding
skills like I said programming not from
a developer's perspective but at least
good enough to understand how the
program functions what the flaws may be
in the programming code that has been
given and how you can break that
particular code that is what is required
a few scripting languages like PHP pull
python Ruby they would be a lot helpful
at this point in time maybe bash
scripting or Powershell scripting as
well and then our understanding of the
architecture of an operating system we
just don't want to know how the
operating system works and how it
functions we should be able to
troubleshoot the operating system to
recover from errors flaws and we should
know how the operating system works
stores data and interacts with the
hardware at the first place with
everything there is now cloud and cloud
is gaining traction a lot we got public
clouds like Amazon Microsoft and Google
we got private clouds like VMware
Microsoft again Citrix and so on so
forth most of the organizations in
today's world have a hybrid environment
where they've got a part physical ID
infra and part Cloud infrastructure so
learning what cloud is the nuances of
cloud the services that a cloud can
provide software as a service
infrastructure as a service and platform
as a service understanding them and then
knowing how you can secure these or what
the vulnerabilities are in the first
place and then trying to secure them is
of very much a sense in today's world
over a period of time you will have to
learn Cloud security to be relevant in
in today's world especially with iot
artificial intelligence and machine
learning picking up pace and then
malware analysis and reversal
engineering so let's say there's a new
virus that has been released and there's
an antivirus company who's working to
figure out how the virus Works what are
the signatures that are created by the
virus and this is where those malware
analysis skills come into the picture
even in real terms or in normal terms if
you're working in an organization and if
a machine has been infected or is
suspected of an infection you need to
investigate the machine to identify
whether it was a worm virus or a Trojan
and need to take effective action to
prevent further compromise from
happening and that is why malware
analysis is of importance as well the
certifications that you have certified
ethical hacker it will train you in
reverse engineering so this is where you
basically look at offensive security
this is where you're looking at hacking
and you're looking at how the
methodologies the five steps that we
have talked about and this course deals
with each and every one of those five
steps and helps you analyze and
understand the tool sets and the skills
that are required for each of that
particular step salaries May range
between 71 000 US Dollars and above in
the US market and around around five
lakh rupees and more in the Indian
market after ceh we have got the ecsa
slash lpt course ecsa is the easy
Council certified security analyst
Course once you get certified on that
you can then apply for the lpt which is
the license penetration tester so it's
for CH then ecsa EC console certified
security analyst and then lpt license
penetration tester this gives certified
penetration testers the opportunity to
practice their skills and gives you a
license where you have a certificate
that proves that you have understood the
methodology and are very Adept at the
skills of hacking when we hear the term
hacker we may picture a dangerous cyber
criminal however not all hackers are
inherently bad they are powerful
individuals who use their technical
skills to break into to computer
networks and bypass security measures
hacking is not always bad and it is to
be noted that the world of computers is
actually safer to an extent because of a
particular type of hacker
a hacker is deemed to be good or bad
depending on their motive and whether or
not they are breaking the law
in this video we will acquaint you with
the differences between a white hat
hacker black hat hacker and a gray
attacker through a short story hackers
are basically categorized by the type of
metaphorical hat they don't white hat
gray hat and black hat hackers can
either be a black hat or a white hat or
a gray hat hackers can be good or bad
depending on which color hat they decide
to wear and by this we mean that hacking
motives and obviously not in the sense
of creating a fashion statement here
let's have a look at our story
our story here revolves around Dan who
is the owner of a company that provides
a platform for video conferencing
his platform enables online
communication for video meetings audio
meetings and webinars
just like other video conferencing
platforms his platform 2 has built-in
features like chat recording screen
sharing and so on
everything went well and his business
increased tremendously with the onset of
the covid-19 pandemic
covid-19 accelerated the rise of the
worldwide digital economy and it made
people rapidly adopt video conferencing
tools and apps in a contactless world
starting from employee interactions to
family get-togethers to Virtual workout
classes everything happened virtually
dance video conferencing platform
enabled long-distance communication and
enhanced collaboration
so now you might be wondering what could
have gone wrong well there are many
risks involved when it comes to the
safety of these online platforms
online meeting rooms are susceptible to
a number of digital threats Dan received
complaints from his customers that his
platform was insecure and safe anymore
little did Dan know that the popularity
of his video conferencing platform made
hackers eager to disrupt the virtual
meetings and hijack the conferences
his platform witness complaints like the
addition of an unknown participant in
every meeting room someone covering up
information that is being presented and
also unknown screen recording of a
meeting to name a few these Intruders
were sneaky hackers who tried to gain
access to sensitive information and who
try to disrupt meetings
and how do these hackers manage to do
all this well this was done by
exploiting weaknesses in Dance computer
network in order to obtain unauthorized
access to crucial data and sensitive
information
this is known as hacking and the
individuals who carry this out are known
as hackers
in this form of hacking that Dan
witnessed hackers exploited Dance
Company security posture by identifying
weaknesses in it in order to intrude
into the meetings and gain access to
business data or personal data and this
form of hacking is definitely bad and
unethical the hackers who carried this
against Dance Company are known as black
hat hackers these hackers are cyber
criminals who carry out cyber attacks
with a negative intention these attacks
can be in the form of trojan virus
malware attacks phishing attacks DDOS
attacks man-in-the-middle attacks SQL
injection attacks and so on
so who exactly is a black hat hacker
like in the case of dance organizations
Cyber attack
ERS are highly skilled cyber criminals
who break into computer systems and
networks with malicious intent they
illegally hack into a system and this is
obviously without the system owner's
approval
such hackers do not abide by the laws
they violate loss and disrupt Networks
the motive Behind these attacks vary
from One Tree gains to personal profit
usually they are for monetary gains
black hat hackers May violate the
confidentiality Integrity or
availability of a company systems and
data they may also use malware to
destroy files or steal passwords credit
card numbers and other confidential
information
black hat hackers are also sometimes
called crackers
but this is who a black hat hacker is
going back to Dan's story black hat
hackers disrupted his business and he
lost his customers as nobody wished to
communicate on an unsecure platform it
is but true right would you be okay to
use a platform that is unsafe none of us
want to have unknown people in our
meetings right this is how dance
customers felt too and this new spread
and his company's reputation took a bad
hit
that is when Ted approached Dan so who
is dead let's have a look at that snow
Dead who was unknown to Dan explained to
him that he found Dance Network to be
weak Ted told Dan that he has identified
vulnerabilities in dance systems and
networks and he will fix them provided
Dan pays him well Dan had nothing to
lose and without any further delay he
paid Ted a good amount of money to fix
the vulnerabilities in dance networks on
receiving the money Ted began his work
and he fixed all the issues and
vulnerabilities in Dance Network he made
sure that nobody can exploit Dance
Network vulnerabilities again and this
way he safeguarded Dance Network for the
time being so who is dead well he's
called a gray hat hacker as they say not
all things are black and white so is the
concept of gray hat hackers as
fascinating as the name sounds let us
dive deep into understanding the role of
a gray hat hacker a gray hat is a
security expert who may at times violate
the loss or the ethical standards
however they do not carry a malicious
intent unlike a black hat hacker
hence they are known to work both
defensively and offensively they land
between the good and the bad gray hat
hackers look for vulnerabilities and
assistant without permission but with
good intentions
just like how Ted informed Dan about how
he could exploit dance system
vulnerabilities gray hat hackers inform
an organization the same and in return
ask for a fee to fix it in some cases
when the organization doesn't comply
gray hat hackers may become black hat
hackers although a gray hat Hacker's
intention might not be bad what they do
is still illegal since they do not have
permission to break into another system
back to our story all the dance issue
was sorted by Ted for the time being he
had a few concerns
his first concern was history repeating
itself yes he was worried about what if
black hat hackers hack into his systems
again although his system
vulnerabilities are fixed at the moment
it was a matter of time before they
could be exploited again with new
hacking techniques
his next thought was to have a
professional who could constantly keep a
tab on his networks and protect it from
hackers don't you think his concerns
were Justified yes it was as this was
the only way he could provide a safe and
secure video conferencing platform in
the long run
that is when Dan's friend came to his
rescue and introduced Anne the ethical
hacker to him and being an ethical
hacker a short Dan that she would scan
and identify his Network for system
vulnerabilities before an outsider
exploits it and she would fix those
vulnerabilities on a regular basis such
ethical hackers like Anne are called
white attack hackers now that we saw who
black hat hackers and gray hat hackers
were it is time we learn about our third
type of hacker who is a white attack
hacker a Wi-Fi hacker gains access to
networks with an intention to fix the
identified weaknesses
they also perform penetration testing
and vulnerability assessments and break
into systems with permission
they search for loopholes or
vulnerabilities in any given piece of
technology just like how a black hat
hacker would do however white attackers
Harden their organization system before
the bad guy can get in
their goal is to spot system and network
vulnerabilities in order to improve
system security
white attackers are also known as
ethical hackers since they obey the law
of the land and follow a code of ethics
many companies and government
organizations employ white hat hackers
to help them secure their systems
these hackers are typically hired by
organizations to look for
vulnerabilities in a system like other
hackers the only difference being they
are given permission to break in
one Stan spots the vulnerabilities she
documents her findings and gives Dan
advice on how to fix them or she'll even
take it up to fix them so that an
outsider cannot spot it in the future
Anne does this on a regular basis as
system updates happen regularly and it
is imperative to be on track with it and
fix new vulnerabilities
this made sure dance network is now safe
and secure gradually he regained his
customers trust and his platform got
back to being one of the best and safest
platforms for video conferencing
resulted in a huge business growth and
Dan is very happy
just like how Ann put an end to dance
business problems there are many white
hat hackers out there who are in great
Demand by organizations to safeguard
their networks from cyber attacks and if
you are interested in a career in
ethical hacking then simply learn can
help you fulfill your dreams simply
learn CH version 11 certification
provides you the Hands-On training
required to master the techniques
hackers use to penetrate Network systems
and fortify your system against it
this ethical hacking course is aligned
with the latest CH version 11 by EC
Council and will adequately prepare you
to increase your blue team skills so
what are you waiting for get certified
with simply learn and become a certified
ethical hacker and put an end to the
Cyber crimes in the world
remember the more active white attack
hackers are the fewer opportunities
black hat hackers have for system
exploitation cyber security has become a
struggle for organizations in 2021
recent Trends the side effects of a
global pandemic and cyber security
statistics reveal a huge increase in
hacked and breach data for increasingly
common sources in the workplace like
mobiles and iot devices
on top of this the covid-19 has ramped
up remote workforces making inroads for
cyber attacks this kind of growth would
not have been possible if not for
several Reliable Tools and services from
scripts that find intricate details of
companies to software that can Brute
Force servers with a single command
today's lesson is all about such tools
that make an ethical hacker effective
let's learn about what is ethical
hacking ethical hacking involves an
authorized attempt to gain unauthorized
access to a computer system application
or data carrying out an ethical hack
involves duplicating strategies and
actions of malicious attackers
often carried out in the form of
security audits ethical hacking is
extremely beneficial to organizations
who are looking to secure the data from
falling in the wrong hands
there are three variants of hackers
while a black hat hacker is notorious
for criminal activities white hat is an
ethical hacker or computer security
expert who specializes in penetration
testing and other testing methodologies
that ensure the security of an
organization system
there are a few that fall under the gray
hat hacker umbrella where the hacker
occasionally have not authenticated
themselves before attempting to hack an
organization while sometimes requiring a
small fee to report the vulnerability to
the developers directly
the purpose of ethical hacking is to
improve the security of the network or
the systems by fixing the
vulnerabilities found during testing
ethical hackers may use the same methods
and tools used by the malicious hackers
but with the permission of the
authorized person for the purpose of
improving the security and defending the
systems from attacks ethical hackers are
expected to report all the
vulnerabilities and weaknesses found
during the process to the management
directly
ethical hacking has proven itself to be
quite a productive career option for
many ambitious individuals the demand
for its courses today is at an all-time
high and rightfully so it provides you
with an engaging job that never gets
tedious some certifications like the
CompTIA plus ceh and Cisco CCNA are
highly acclaimed and will teach a
learner all there is to know before
dipping their toes in the industry
when it comes to web app hacking It
generally refers to the exploitation of
applications by HTTP which can be done
by manipulating the applications via its
graphical user interface this is done by
tampering with the uniform resource
identifier also known as a URI or
tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be compromised
anyone who uses a computer connected to
the internet is susceptible to the
threats that computer hackers and online
Predators post these online variants
typically use phishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise the computer
security
hackers can also try to access your
computer and private information
directly if you are not protected by a
firewall they can monitor your
conversations or produce the back end of
your personal website usually disguised
with a bogus identity Predators can lure
you into revealing sensitive personal
and financial information
a web server which can be referred to as
the hardware the computer or the
software which helps to deliver content
that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertext transfer protocol or http
so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like DDOS
attacks syn flooding pink flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other end
although wireless networks offer great
flexibility they have their own security
problems a hacker can sniff the network
packets without having to be in the same
building where the network is located as
wireless networks communicate through
radio waves a hacker can easily sniff
the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack a network
from a distance and therefore it is
sometimes difficult to collect evidence
against the main hacker
social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer systems
coming to our main focus for today let
us have a look at the top 5 most
essential ethical hacking tools to be
used in 2021
at the top of the chain lies and map
nmap which stands for network mapper is
a free and open source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service uptime
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and thus
Bridge the device
nmap uses raw IB packets in novel ways
to determine what hosts are available on
the network what service they are
running what operating systems are
installed what type of packet filters
and firewalls are in use and dozens
other characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
finest against single host as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or a server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked device
next on our list we have Metasploit
the betasploit framework is a very
powerful tool that can be used by cyber
criminals as well as ethical hackers to
probe systematic vulnerabilities on both
networks and servers
because it's an open source framework it
can be easily customized and used with
most operating systems
with Metasploit the ethical hacking team
can use ready-made or custom code and
introduce it into a network to probe for
weak spots as another flavor of threat
hunting once the flaws are identified
and documented the information can be
used to address systemic weaknesses and
prioritize Solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the necessary exploit is
value to the system there are a host of
options for the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all the
personal data stored on the device
a big advantage of Metasploit is the
ability to run full-fledged scans on the
target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
softwares having a single solution to
gather almost all the necessary points
of attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the list
moving on we have the acunetics
framework
iconetix is an end-to-end web security
scanner which offers a 360 degree view
of an organization security
it is an application security testing
tool that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web assets
the need to be able to test application
in depth and further than traditional
vulnerability management tools has
created a market with several players in
the application security space
accuratics can detect over 7000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross-site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other out-of-band vulnerabilities
it can scan all pages web apps and
complex web applications running HTML5
and JavaScript as well it also lets you
scan complex multi-level forms and even
password protected areas of the site
iconetix is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as sasd scanners
sast tools only work during development
and only for specific languages and have
a history of reporting lot of false
positives whereas Dynamic testing tools
also known as dest have the ability to
streamline testing from development to
deployment with minimal issues
next on our list we have air Garden
this is a multi-use bash script used for
Linux systems to hack and audit wireless
networks like our everyday Wi-Fi router
and its counterparts along with being
able to launch denial of service attacks
on compromise networks this multipurpose
wi-fi hacking tool has very rich
features which support multiple methods
for wi-fi hacking including WPS hacking
modes WP attacks handshake captures evil
twin and so much more
it usually needs an external network
adapter that supports monitor mode which
is necessary to be able to capture
Wireless traffic that reverse the air
channels
thanks to its open source nature air
Garden can be used with multiple
Community plugins and add-ons thereby
increasing its Effectiveness against a
wide variety of routers both in the 2.4
gigahertz and the 5 gigahertz band
finally at number 5 we have John the
Ripper
John the Ripper is an open source
password security auditing and the
password recovery tool which is
available for many operating systems
John the Ripper jumbo supports hundreds
of hash and Cipher types including for
user passwords of operating systems web
apps database servers encrypted keys and
document files some of the key features
of the tool include offering multiple
modes to speed up the password cracking
automatically deselecting the hashing
algorithm used by the passwords and the
ease of running and configuring the tool
to make it password cracking easier
it can use dictionary attacks along with
regular brute forcing to speed up the
process of cracking the correct password
without wasting additional resources
the word is being used in these
dictionary attacks can be used by the
users and allowing for a completely
customizable process
we also have a few honorary mentions in
our list that just missed the cut
let's Parker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any fuss so you can focus on
fixing the reported vulnerabilities
the bobsled professional is one of the
most popular penetration testing and
vulnerability finder tools and is used
for checking web application security
the term burp as it is commonly known is
a proxy based tool which is used to
evaluate the security of web-based
application and to do Hands-On testing
moving away from websites and
applications Wireshark is a free and
open source packet analyzer which was
launched in 2006. it is used for Network
troubleshooting analysis software and
Communications protocol development and
education
it captures Network traffic on the local
network and stores data for offline
analysis
vaisha captures Network traffic from
ethernet Bluetooth wireless networks and
frame relay connections
now that we learn about the different
types of tools that can be used when
conducting an ethical hacking audit
let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits
being able to identify defects from an
attacker's perspective is game changing
since it displays all the potential
Avenues of a possible hack one can only
prepare for the known vulnerabilities as
a defensive specialist but proactively
trying to breach a network or device can
make hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for
this kind of unpredictability goes a
long way in securing a network against
malicious actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
Network infrastructure as seen on many
occasions a real breach will cause loss
of data and irreparable damage to the
foundation of an organization
being able to gauge such shortcomings
before they become public and can be
used exploited is a benefit most
organizations make use of
this is not to imply that such security
audits are only beneficial to the
organization paying for it when coming
across companies that provide certain
Services a reliable third-party security
audit goes a long way in instilling
trust and confidence over their craft if
the ethical hackers cannot find any
major vulnerabilities that can be
leveraged by hackers it just accentuates
the technical Brilliance of the
organization and its Engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount with the rise in
censorship and general fear over privacy
loss consumer security is at an all-time
high risk technology has made our life
so much easier while putting up a decent
Target on our personal information it is
necessary to understand how to
simultaneously Safeguard our data and be
up to date with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography meet Anne Anne wanted to
look for a decent discount on the latest
iPhone she started searching on the
internet and found a rather Shady
website that offered a 50 discount on
the first purchase once and submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was
their HTTP webpage instead of an https
one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers Hatcher used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iPhone enthusiasts could have
avoided this particular incident this is
why it's never recommended to visit
unknown websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics we covered today
we take a look into what cryptography is
and how it works we learn where
cryptography is being used in our daily
lives and how we are benefiting from it
then we will understand the different
types of cryptography and their
respective users
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action
let's Now understand what cryptography
is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is a primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply run is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text the only
ones who can are the people who know how
to decrypt the coded word thereby
reversing the process of encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text to encrypt the
message we use certain algorithms that
serve a single purpose of scrambling the
data to make them unreadable without the
necessary tools these algorithms are
called ciphers they are a set of
detailed steps to be carried out one
after the other to make sure the data
becomes as unreadable as possible until
it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it through
the cipher algorithm and get the
encrypted data this encrypted text is
called the ciphertext and this is the
message that is transferred between the
two parties the key that is being used
to scramble the data is known as the
encryption key these steps that is the
cipher and the encryption key are made
known to the receiver who can then
reverse the encryption on receiving the
message unless any third party manages
to find out both the algorithm and the
secret key that is being used they
cannot decrypt the messages since both
of them are necessary to unlock the
hidden content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit more than 65 billion
messages are sent on WhatsApp every day
all of which are secured thanks to
end-to-end encryption
there is a huge Market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption
asymmetric encryption
and hashing let's find out how much you
have understood until now do you
remember the difference between a cipher
and ciphertext leave your answers in the
comments and before we proceed if you
find this video interesting make sure to
give it a thumbs up before moving ahead
let's look at symmetric encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times
Caesar Cipher Enigma machine are both
symmetric encryption examples that we
will look into further
for example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob she can apply a
substitution Cipher or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into ciphertext stream
ciphers convert the plain text into
ciphertext one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks
in today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is AES
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128 bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available other primitive
algorithms like the data encryption
standard that is the Des the triple data
encryption standard 3des and Blowfish
have all fallen out of favor due to the
rise of AES AES chops UPS the data into
blocks and performs 10 plus rounds of
obscuring and substituting the message
to make it unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key the
public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiving
the message Bob uses his own private key
to decrypt the data this way nobody can
intercept the message in between
transmissions and there is no need for
any secure key exchange for this to work
since the encryption is done with the
public key and the decryption is another
private key that no one except Bob has
access to both the keys are necessary to
read the full message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message
this mechanism also proves that the
sender is authenticated and there is no
problem with the origin of the
information
RSA encryption is the most widely used
asymmetric encryption standard it is
named after its Founders revised Shamir
and Edelman and it uses block ciphers
that separate the data into blocks and
obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than AES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time since asymmetric
encryption takes longer to decrypt large
amounts of data the full information is
encrypted using a single key that is
symmetric encryption that single key is
then transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the diffie-hellman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into
the third variant of cryptography is
termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general the
calculations that do the job of messing
up the data collection form the hash
function they are generally not
reversible without resilient Brute Force
mechanisms and are very helpful when
storing data on website servers that
need not be stored in plain text for
example many websites store your account
passwords in a hashed format so that not
even the administrator can read your
credentials when a user tries to log in
they can compare the entered passwords
hash value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
authentication since the function will
always return the same value for the
same input
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
Julius Caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table a spy can't decipher the
original message at first glance for
example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use the substitution
shift of plus 2 a becomes c b becomes D
and so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus 3
becomes d w w d f n this Cipher has been
appropriately named the Caesar Cipher
which is one of the most widely used
algorithms
the Enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic Cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the Nazi German armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political military and
administrative information and it
consisted of three or more rotors that
scramble the original message depending
on the machine's State at that time the
decryption is similar but it needs both
machines to stay in the same state
before passing the cipher text so that
we received the same plain text message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of RSA encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the ciphertext in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know RSA encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetrically cryptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well
in RSA we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from our 512 bit to
1024-bit all the way up to a 4096 bit
key the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the ciphertext
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024 bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on pass freezes the tool we are
using right now generates this
pseudorandom keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the
ciphertext this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself
in this scenario let's try an encrypt
the word simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over here
the cipher we are using right now is
plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well
once you click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plain text will
trigger a completely different
ciphertext this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from Brute Force
methods now that we are done with the
encryption process let's take a look at
the decryption part
the receiver gets this ciphertext from
the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once you click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of RSA encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
around we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner here we just have to take
the private key and use that to encrypt
the plain text and select the same in
this checkbox as well you can see we
have generated a completely new
ciphertext
this ciphertext will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites let's take a
look at Wikipedia here pretty standard
https website where the edge stands for
secured let's take a look at how it
secures the data
Wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use this software to see the traffic
that is leaving a machine and to
understand how vulnerable it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to Wikipedia
[Music]
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a HTTP web page
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks there is a login form here which
needs legitimate user credentials in
order to Grant access
let's enter a random pair of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data's transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform instead we can see the
data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
HTTP login form to the internet if we
check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the Wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find the correct credentials if any
website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it have been really easy to get a hold
of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid HTTP
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online due to the increase in the
network transactions in the modern era
there are often cases when we Face some
problems regarding network issues but
are they exactly network issues or is
somebody spying on us
will such cases are regarded as Network
sniffing cases
but how exactly a hacker hack into a
network system
well for today's topic we'll understand
the same
let's take a look at Network sniffing
to access the network related
information between devices to gain
profit or use the Hacked data for
illegal purpose is known as Network
sniffing this is a process where a
hacker automations programmer spy into
the network devices of our system
they can access different websites that
we visit often or see our Network habits
let's take a look at different tools
that are suitable for sniffing purpose
Network sniffing tools are softwares
that are available on the internet that
can be used to sniff into the network
let's take a look at some of the famous
Network Tools first one is Avic this is
a networking sniffing tool which has a
specialization in intelligent analysis
for Network packets
next is Wireshark this software tool is
best to look into protocol related data
packets that are often transmitted over
the network
and lastly we have solar wind Network
packet sniffer
where the performance of this sniffing
tool is best where the Performance
Management is to be looked into
let's take a look at the Wireshark
sniffing tool this is an open source
Network sniffing software which is
specifically designed to attack data
packets during a transmission over the
network this type of software uses
different color combinations to
represent different packets and
protocols let's take a look at some of
the uses for the sniffing software
the first uses it is used to analyze
Network packets
whereas it can also be used to
troubleshoot different network issues
which are often used by different
Engineers to test whether the software
or a network device is susceptible to an
attack
and lastly it is also used to check
malicious and hacking possibilities on
the network now that we are completed
with the briefing for the software that
is known as Wireshark let's take a look
at the actual demo how exactly Network
sniffing is done you can directly access
the Wireshark software website
where you can find the download option
and download the most suitable
version for your laptop or computer
device
after downloading the software when you
install it
you will get something like this
as we can see these connections are the
connections that are connected to my
laptop right now
and the difference in the graph that we
can see over here represent the traffic
on the network that is present
too much to understand what exactly is
going on the network we can access one
of them let's access the Wi-Fi network
on my laptop
after accessing the network we can see
some packet settings like this
these represents the packet transaction
that has been made on my network through
the internet
and this is how a hacker or a cyber
criminal knows how exactly we use a
network services
this part of the Wireshark represents
different detail information about the
transaction that has been made
and the last section represents some raw
data or Garbage data
but how exactly a hacker use all this
jumble data and hack into a system
well to clarify this is an option that
can be used that is known as diff
display filter on the Wireshark software
if you want to search for a specific
protocol for example TCP we can write
TCP in the search filter and search
and now as we can see
we only get the protocols that are
related to TCP
this is how we can differentiate
different protocols and access some of
them to gain knowledge about what
exactly is going on in the network
let's try accessing some other protocol
now
for example
DNS
and as we can see
only the protocol and the data packet
that is related to DNS protocol is
visible to us
to further enhance the display filter
let's try accessing a
different page on the web browser for
example
simplylearn.com
when we access a simply learn website we
can see the professional courses that
are available but let's take a look at
the changes that has been made on the
Wireshark
to know this let's write
TCP and a keyword included contains
and one more thing to include over Eis
during the display filter if you write
something that is related to the
software it will represent in a green
color like this but if you write some
error related keywords like this it will
represent in the red
let's continue with the search setting
including the contains keyword and
writing
simply learn
and entering now as we can see these two
related data packets represent the
simply learn website that we access just
now where the source destination IP
address represent
my system address whereas the
destination that is
13.224.21.74 represent the simply learns
IP address let's take a look
and in the garbage area or the raw data
we can take a look simply learn website
to see some more details regarding the
same
you can access the transport layer
security
and the transmission control protocol
where we can see the source Port the
destination Port which is always 443
as well as
the flag
and the timestamp for the same
this is how hackers get the data about a
network settings
but if we want to search for more data
related to Simply learn website that we
visited just now
they send another filter that we can use
for example
using IP Dot addr
space equal equal and writing the IP
address for the website simply learn
that is
30.224
.21.74 and when we press enter we get
all the related data for the simply
learn website
and this is how we can see the related
data
to much further enhance our display
settings let's try in another example
access your internet browser
and access some other website for
example
dot for example the State University
and access the alawat State University
and some other are in it for example the
university State PDF
let's see the changes in our Wireshark
settings
and try using http
when we write this we get the data that
is related to the HTTP but what is the
use for the same
when you access this and right click on
the same and choose the option follow
an HTTP stream
and over here we can take a look at the
host that is the website that we just
visited
now imagine if we were a hacker and we
knew all this we can access any website
that a user visited
and we can hack into his system through
the website
guys but the point that has to be noted
over ERS if we use the Network's nothing
tool why shark or some other tool that
is available on the internet for
research purpose or experimental use
that's fine but we shouldn't use all
these softwares for any malicious
activity because that is illegal
now
some of the options that we can see are
the Red Box
this action is used if we want to stop
the traffic connection that means if we
press this option
and clear this and press enter
this shows
that the network settings has stopped
receiving any traffic that is available
on the network but if we want to access
them again
you can choose this Bluefin option
continue without saving and the software
against
start recording the websites or the data
packets that are available on the
network
now let's take a look at an example as
we all know we often visit different
websites and there are some cases we
often see when the Chrome represent a
non-secure option
that represents that the website is
unprotected against network attack
for example we can access a experimental
website
this is a website that allows us to
access the non-secure part of a website
if we write for username as
admin1213 and for password as
simply learn
and login
as this is an experimental website it
says it's sorry and the login has failed
let's see the changes in a Wireshark
software
now as we already did earlier if we want
to access a specific website we should
write TCP
contains and the keyword of the website
that was
admin
through this we can see this was the
website that we visited just now
but if we want to access the actual
important data that was the password
that we typed
we can use this option
and over here we can see the simply
learn
which was encrypted earlier in the
website
this is how our hacker or a cyber
criminal use different sniffing
softwares and gain data about different
users in this video we bring you the
best programming languages for hacking
here we will give you the top 5
programming languages that will help you
enhance your hacking skills
first let's understand the importance of
knowing programming for hacking you
might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker as you
might be aware hacking involves breaking
the protocols and exploiting a network
thus being a hacker requires you to
understand the languages of the software
that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies it takes plenty of
practice and programming knowledge to
become an ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages it is a known fact
that some of the world's best hackers
started off as programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim yes there
are several ready-made scripts available
today however you might need to apply
your skills in case the available
scripts don't work well for you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that in such a scenario zero
knowledge of the respective programming
language will definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack it will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking techniques
and make your cyber security career
worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit
now that we have an idea as to why
programming is important for hackers let
us understand which programming
languages should a hacker learn there
are several programming languages for
hacking and it might be overwhelming to
choose from the endless list
here we are to help you with that do
keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top 5 programming languages for
hackers let us go through them one by
one number one on our list is one of the
most popular programming languages today
that is python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing it is
referred to as the de facto hacking
programming language it plays a crucial
role in writing hacking scripts exploits
and malicious programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules
for example OS modules are available if
the target is a native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security Integrity of
systems and it can also be used to
exploit them python has a massive
community that helps with third-party
plugins every day it is also an easy to
read language with a simple syntax this
will be helpful for beginners you can
easily write automation scripts using
Python and it also makes prototyping
much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have JavaScript
currently JavaScript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of JavaScript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitations since most of their web
apps use JavaScript or one of its
libraries
knowing JavaScript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
JavaScript can be used to read saved
cookies and Security Experts also use
JavaScript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
JavaScript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
JavaScript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses easily
initially JavaScript was a client-side
scripting language however with the
release of node.js it now supports
back-end development this implies a
larger field for exploitation
a hacker can now use JavaScript to Snoop
the typed words inject malicious code
and track browsing history to name a few
number three on our list is PHP
hypertext preprocessor or PHP is a
dynamic server-side programming language
that is used to build websites
hackers should understand PHP as it will
help them understand web hacking
techniques better
especially if you're into web hacking
then getting your hands on PHP would be
an asset
PHP is used in server-side scripting
using PHP you could write a custom
application that modifies settings on a
web server and makes a Target server
susceptible to attacks
with the help of PHP you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code
PHP is one of the most powerful
server-side languages used in most of
the web domains this shows how learning
PHP can help you with web hacking and
also help you fight against malicious
attackers
popular content Management Systems run
on a foundation of PHP hence having a
strong knowledge of PHP can help you
protect or compromise such websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is SQL SQL is the
acronym for structured query language
although SQL is not a traditional
programming language it is a language
used for only communicating with
databases
several systems like MySQL postgresql
stored their data in databases
SQL is used to interact with such
databases in order to organize add
retrieve delete or edit data from a
database
having an in-depth knowledge of SQL lets
you comprehend the structure of a
database thereby helping you decide
which scripts or tools to deploy
SQL is used for the purpose of web
hacking SQL is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into a large databases
it would be impossible to counteract
database attacks without a good
understanding of SQL
using SQL hackers can perform an attack
known as SQL injection attack such an
attack enables hackers to access
confidential information from databases
SQL is used by hackers to develop
various hacking programs based on SQL
injection
SQL injection is used to bypass web
application login algorithms that are
weak
such an attack can also help a hacker
View and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number 5 we have the C
programming language
it is no surprise that we have C the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field it helps with exploit writing and
development the low-level nature of C
provides an edge over other programming
languages used for hacking
a hacker can use the C programming
language to his or her Advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level Hardware
components such as the ram
Security Professionals mostly you see
when they are required to manipulate
system resources and Hardware
C also helps penetration testers write
programming Scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in C language hence
learning C you will help hackers get an
overview of the structure of operating
systems
C is also used to create shell codes
root kits exploits built undetectable
malware keyloggers and much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both C and C plus as they both come in
handy for hackers
so those were our top 5 programming
languages for hackers do keep in mind
that the most important step of becoming
a hacker is to learn various programming
languages it will be great if you can
Master a variety of programming
languages as your target will not be the
same always on that note in addition to
previously mentioned programming
languages we have an additional list of
languages that are also well recognized
for hacking let's have a look at our
honorary mention
first we have Ruby the Ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now there can be a
close comparison drawn between Ruby and
python based on its syntax however Ruby
is more web focused
Ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits Ruby has been used by several
hackers to exploit corporate systems it
is not that easy to master Ruby and that
is one reason why mncs look for
professionals who know Ruby
second we have Pearl although Pearl has
lost its old Fame it still holds value
in the hacker Community for exploit
writing
there are systems that still run on Perl
as it was the go-to solution once it is
a great language that can help you
manipulate Linux text files and help you
create tools and exploits
pull code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is HTML many of you
might have wondered why we didn't
mention HTML yet yes no programming list
is complete without mentioning HTML
the hypertext markup language HTML is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glues the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web this shows
the importance HTML has
an understanding of HTML is vital to
play with web applications
HTML also Finds Its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
HTML is a must if you want to master
this field having said that HTML is not
that tough a language to learn hence it
is advised to master HTML if you want to
compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have assembly level
language it is undoubtedly one of the
most powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn it is a complicated
low-level programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine Hardware or
software using it
Assembly Language helps a hacker menu
plate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and Trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse Engineers use Assembly Language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled assembly
is the go-to choice
as complicated as a language sounds the
results it produces are highly fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and successful hacker we should
keep in mind that a strong understanding
of programming languages help cyber
Security Professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals Kali Linux is an
operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution that is
made specifically for penetration
testers let's start by learning about
Karl Linux in general
Kali Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools that
are targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering
Kali Linux is a multiple platform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and hobbyists
among all the Linux distributions Kali
Linux takes its roots from the Debian
operating system Debian has been a
highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop
while the operating system is capable of
practically modifying every single part
of our installation the networking
components of Kali become disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk and critical environments apart
from boosting security it allows a
deeper element of control to the most
enthusiastic of users
we did not get Kali Linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its history
Linux is based on years of knowledge and
experience in building penetration
testing and operating systems during all
these project lifelines there have been
only a few different developers as the
team has always been small the first
project was called wapix which stands
for white hat knopex as can be inferred
from the name it was based on the nopics
operating system as its underlying OS
Optics head releases ranging from
version 2.0 to 2.7
this made way for the next project which
was known as wax or the long hand being
white hat slacks the name change was
because the base OS was changed from
nopics to slacks wax started at version
3 as a Nord at carrying on from warp X
there was a similar OS being produced at
the same time auditor security
collection often being shorted to just
auditor which was once again using
nopics
its efforts were combined with wax to
produce backtrack backtrack was based on
slackware from version 1 to version 3
but switched to Ubuntu later on with
version 4 to version 5. using the
experience gained from all of this Kal
Linux came after backtrack in 2013. Kali
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when Kali Linux became a
rolling operating system
now that we understand the history and
the purpose of Kali Linux let us learn a
little more about its distinct features
the latest version of Kali comes with
more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
that was included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either similar did
not work which duplicated other tools
that provided the same or similar
functionality
the Kali Linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code basis to external asset greatly
reduces the risk of source contamination
which can cause Kali Linux users
worldwide a great deal of damage as a
direct victim of cybercrime
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in their native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in general
since rmbs single board systems like the
Raspberry Pi are becoming more and more
prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Kali Linux is available on a wide range
of arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with the mainland
distributions so the tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution
all this information is necessary for
users to determine if Kali Linux is the
correct choice for them if it is what
are the ways that they can go forward
with this installation and start their
penetration testing Journey
the first way to use Kali Linux is by
launching the distribution in the live
USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the Kali Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB
some people don't need to save their
data permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the caviar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USPS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations
but what if the user wants to store data
permanently in the installed OS the best
and the most reliable way to ensure this
is the full-fledged hardness
installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to overwrite any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of Linux
the next alternative route for
installing Kali Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtualbox the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and Kali Linux
can be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window
the hardware requirements will be
completely customizable starting with
the allotted Ram to the virtual hard
disk capacity
the usage of both a host and guest
operating system like carlinux allows
users a safe environment to learn while
not putting the systems at risk if you
want to learn more about how one can go
forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where Kali Linux is
being installed on VMware while running
on a Windows 10 operating system you can
find the link in the description box to
get started with your very own virtual
machine
the final way to install Kali Linux is
by using a dual boot system to put it in
simple words the Kali Linux OS will not
be overrating any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and Kali Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system there are multiple ways
to install color Linux we can either
install it on a normal hard drive in a
virtual machine software such as VMware
or virtualbox or we can do that in hard
bare metal machines now for the
convenience of explanation we're going
to install Kali Linux today on a virtual
machine software known as VMware
VMware is able to run multiple operating
systems on a single host machine which
in our case is a Windows 10 system
to get started with Kali Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image file
you go to get Kali
and as you can see there are multiple
platforms on which this operating system
can be inverted as per our requirement
we're going to go with the virtual
machine section as you can see it is
already recommended by the Developers
this is the download button which to
download a 64-bit ISO file we can
download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet
after clicking on the download button
we can see we have a window archive
which will have the ISO files
for now we have downloaded the ISO file
and it is already present with me so we
can start working on the VMware side of
things
once the ISO file is downloaded we open
up VMware Workstation
go to file
and we create a new virtual machine
in these two options it is highly
recommended to go with the typical setup
rather than the customer the custom is
much more advanced and requires much
more information from the user which is
beneficial for developers and people who
are well versed with virtualization
software but from 90 of the cases
typical setup will be enough
here we can select the third option
which will be I will install the
operating system later and some
operating systems we can use the ISO
file here directly and VMware will
install it for us but for right now in
the case of Kali Linux the third option
is always the safest
color Linux is a Linux distribution so
we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here I have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels
every distribution has of a parent
distribution for example Kali Linux as
Debian and there are other distributions
which are based or forked from some
parent distribution kaliness is based
off Debian so we can go with the highest
version of Debian which is the Debian
10.x 64-bit
go on next we can write any such name we
can write Kali Linux so that it will be
easier to recognize the virtual machine
among this list of virtual machine
instances the location can be any
location you decide to put by default
this should be the documents folder but
anywhere you put it will hold up all the
information of the operating system all
the files you download all the
configurations you store everything will
be stored in this particular location
that you provide
when we go next
we are asked about the disk capacity
this disk capacity will be all the
storage that will be provided to your
virtual machine of Cal Linux think of
your Windows device if you have a one
terabyte of hard drive you have the
entirety of the hard disk to store data
on how much data you give here you can
only store up to that amount of data not
to mention some amount of capacity will
be taken up by the operating system
itself to store its programs and
applications
for now we can give around let's say 15
GB of information or if a recommended
size for Type n is 20 we can just go
ahead at 20. it depends on the user case
if you are going to use it extensively
you can even go as high as 50 or 60 GB
if you have plans to download many more
applications and perform multiple
different tests
another option we get over here is
storing virtual disk as a single file or
storing them into multiple files
as we already know this virtual machine
run entirely on VMware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
you're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over here
instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible
for all scenarios except it is much
easier if the split the virtual disk
into multiple files now even if this
makes what importing virtual machines
easier from either system to system or
software to software let's say if you
want to switch from VMware to virtualbox
or vice versa the performance takes a
small hit it's not huge but it's
recommended to go with storing the
virtualized as a single file if you have
no purposes of ever moving the virtual
machine even if you do it's not a
complete stop that it cannot be ported
it's just easier when using multiple
files but in order to get the best
performance out of the virtual machine
we can store it as a single file over
here
this is a summary of all the changes
that we made and all the configurations
that have been settled until now now at
this point of time we have not provided
the dot ISO file yet which is the
installation file for the Kali Linux
that we downloaded from this website
as of right now we have only configured
the settings of the virtual machine so
we can press on finish
and we have Kali Linux in the list now
to make the changes further we press on
edit virtual machine settings
the memory is supposed to give the ram
of the virtual machine
the devices with ram of 8GB odds below
that giving high amount of ram will
cause performance issues and the host
system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my Windows machine takes about 2GB so I
have 6 GB of memory to provide although
if you provide all of the 6gb it will be
much more difficult for the host system
to run everything properly so for this
instance we can keep it as 2GB of memory
for the virtual machine instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if you
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as well
hard disk is pre-set up as the SCSI hard
disk and it does not need to be changed
for the installation of this operating
system at all
cdid DVD this is where the installation
file comes
you can think of the ISO file that we
downloaded as a pen drive or a USB thumb
drive which is necessary to install an
operating system to provide this
we're going to select use ISO image file
we're going to click on browse
go on go to downloads and select the Im
so file over here
select open
and we can see it is already loaded up
next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use Nat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or Lan segments but those are
not necessary for installation
rest of them are pretty standard which
do not need any extra configuration and
can be left as it is
press OK and now we can power on this
virtual machine
in this screen we can choose how we want
to proceed with the installation
we have a start installer option over
here
so we're going to press enter on that
we're going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO file
the first step in the installation is
choosing the language of the operating
system
for this we can go with English as
standard
this is a location this will be used for
setting up the time and some of the
internal settings which depend entirely
on the location of the user so for this
we're going to go with India
configuring the keyboard it's always
recommended to go with the American
English first many people make a mistake
of going with the Indian keyboard if it
is possible and it provides a lot of
issues later on so it's always prefer to
go with the American English and if
later we see some necessity of another
keyboard dialect adaptiveness required
we can install it later but for now we
should always stick with American
English as a basic
at this point it's going to load the
installation components from the dot ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a hostname for the system
this hostname can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a lan cable let's say if we
use the name Kali
domain name you we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation
the full name for the user
let's say we can provide the name as
simply learn as a full name
next we're going to set up a username
this username is going to be necessary
to identify the user from its use root
accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one two three
now we have to choose a password for the
user now remember since this is the
first user that is being added onto this
newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator
we can use whichever password we like
over here
and use the same password below and
press on continue
at this point it's going to detect on
the components on which the operating
system can be installed
like here there are multiple options
like the use entire disk use entire disk
and setup lvm this entire disk and setup
encrypted lvm for newcomers it is
recommended to just use the first one
since lvm encryption is something that
we can learn afterwards when you are
much more Hands-On with the Linux
operating system for now we're going to
use the use entire disk guided
installation and press on continue
when we set up the virtual machine on
VMware we had set up a disk capacity
that we gave a preposition 20 GB that is
the hardest which is being discovered
here even though it is a virtual disk on
VMware it acts as a normal hard disk on
which an operating system can be
installed
so we select this one and press on
continue
here there is a multiple partition
system
all the operating systems that are
installed have different components one
is used for the keeping of the
applications one for the files other for
the RAM management and other things for
newcomers it is always recommended to
keep it in one partition
and we're going to select that and press
on continue
this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1GB used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with Linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine
we can press on finish partitioning and
write changes to disk and continue
it's just a confirmation page as you can
see it showed that SCSI 3 is our virtual
hard disk of 20 GB disk capacity
write the changes to the disk we press
yes and click on continue
at this point the installation has
started now this installation will take
a while depending on the num amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quick assistance this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a while
since this is going to take some time to
install as it is being run on a virtual
machine with only 2GB of RAM we're going
to speed up this part of the video so we
don't have to waste any more time just
watching the progress bar
foreign
is completed it's asking us to configure
a package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating system is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple devices
it's an interface to install external
applications which are not installed by
default let's say for Google Chrome or
any other browser which can be used to
browse the internet
at this point of time is ask us to
select our Network mirror we're going to
select as yes and move forward with this
next
is going to ask us for a HTTP proxy
which we can leave it as blank and press
it as continue forward
at this point of time it's looking for
updates to the Kali Linux installation
this will fetch the new builds from the
Kali server so the installation is
always updated to the latest version
now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it has installed the grub
bootloader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press continue
remember the installation was conducted
on dev SDA
so we're going to select installation of
the Guard loader on the same hard disk
that we have configured
we press this one and press continue
so now the grub bootloader is being
installed
the grub is highly essential because it
is it shows the motherboard where to
start the operating system from even if
the operating system is installed
correctly and all the files are in
correct order the absence of a
bootloader will not be able to launch
the OS properly
as you can see the installation is
finally complete so now we can press on
continue
and it's going to finalize the changes
foreign
Linux being booted up straight away it
doesn't check for the ISO file anymore
since the operating system is now
installed onto the virtual hard disk
storage that we had configured before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up before
and we have the calendar system booted
up
and this is your home page
we can see the installed applications
over here which are being used for
penetration testing by multiple security
analysts worldwide
all of these come pre-installed with
Carl Linux and others can be installed
using the APT package manager that we
had configured
we can see a full name over here
and with this our installation of the
Kali Linux is complete
in today's world an organization's most
valuable asset is its information or
data
this is true for all kinds of businesses
be it public or private on a daily basis
they all deal with enormous amounts of
sensitive information
as a consequence terrorist groups
hacking teams and cyber thieves often
attack them to ensure the safety and
protection businesses use a variety of
security measures and regularly upgrade
their index
organizations must be proactive in this
age of digitalization by regularly
assessing and updating their security
hackers discover new methods to breach
firewalls ethical hackers or white hat
hackers provide a fresh perspective on
security the conduct penetration test to
validate security measures generally
they will penetrate your networks and
give you relevant information about your
security posture once an organization
has this knowledge it may upgrade its
security procedures accordingly
the latest version of Kali Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed
after reviewing every tool that was
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a great number of tools that
either simply did not work
or which duplicated other tools that
provided the same or similar
functionality
occasionally when conducting penetration
testing or hacking we must automate our
activities since there may be hundreds
of conditions and payloads to test and
manually examining everything is time
consuming
to improve our productivity we utilize
tools that come pre-packaged with Kali
Linux these tools not only save us time
but also accurately capture and process
the data
the Kylie Linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols
restricting access of critical code
bases to external assets greatly reduces
the risk of source contamination
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need to do for the
job
since arm plays single board systems
like the Raspberry Pi are becoming more
and more prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Kali Linux is available on a wide range
of arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with the mainline
distribution so tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution tools let's begin with
some terminal Basics on Kali Linux
when most people hear the thumb Linux
they Envision a complex operating system
used only by programmers however the
experience is not as frightening as it
appears Linux is an umbrella term for a
collection of free and open source Unix
operating systems there are many
variants like Ubuntu Fedora Debian these
are distributions which will be a more
precise term when using a Linux
operating system you will most likely
utilize a shell which is a command line
interface that provides access to the
operating system Services the majority
of Linux distributions shipped with a
graphical user interface also known as
GUI as their primary shell this is done
to facilitate user interaction in the
first place having said that a command
line interface is suggested due to its
increased power and Effectiveness by
entering the commands into the CLI tasks
that require a multi-step GUI procedure
may be completed in a matter of seconds
we can start the terminal by clicking on
the prompt icon here on top
once the terminal is open
we can put up a command use another
command known as mkdir which is supposed
to stand for make directory and I write
nf2 shortage for new folder 2.
if I open up the NF you can see the new
folder is created
this is how the PWD command works
another important command
to change directories it's called the CD
command let's say right now if I am in
NF I want to create a new file in an F2
folder or something else in the nf2
folder I have to shift to CD and F2
now if I write PWD
it will show the present working
directory of Home simply learn desktop
NF and inside that I am in nf2 right now
it is done to navigate through the Linux
files and disk directories it requires
either the full path or just the name of
the directory if we have to move a
completely different folder on a
completely different file then we can
use the entire path like this
for now CD Works another few commands is
we can write CD dot dot and it will come
back one folder now the PWD will be just
NF and not nf2
let's say we are in this folder and we
want to go a different file let's say if
we just go for CD
home
simpler
that's it
right now these are the folders in our
current present working directory
we have the desktop the documents
downloads Etc
from here we can again go to the desktop
using the same CD command
cross check the changing of directories
and check the files again and yes there
we go NF how do we know this what are
the command that we are used to show the
files and folders that folder is known
as the ls command LS can be used to view
the contents of a directory by default
this command will display the contents
of your current working directory if we
add some other parameters we can find
the contents of other directories as
well
there are some hidden files as well in
Linux which cannot be showed just with
ls for example if we just go to cdetc
which is a configuration folder for
Linux if we write LS now these are the
files that can be seen
if you want to see the hidden files
we'll have to add one more parameter
here like LS minus a and as you can see
the number of files have increased this
time around
there are other things as well that we
can see with Linux
LS minus a l will show the hidden files
along with some of the parameters and
some of the permissions that has been
provided for each file
as you can see many of these files have
root access some of them can write some
of them can read
it differs file to file and the ls minus
Al command is used to check each of
these files permission and change them
accordingly if needed
the next command that we can look for is
the cat command or concatenate
it is one of the most frequently used
commands and it is used to list the
contents of a file on the output
for example let's say if I have a file
at the desktop
in this nf2 folder I will create a
document
create an empty file
e file
I'll open up the document and I'll write
it as
hello Kali
I will save this up
now to change the directories from Etc
to nf2 we have already discussed how to
use the CD command using just the folder
name now if you want to go through the
entire directory we can write Siri
home
as you can see it is already prompting
us to complete the name of the directory
at this point we just have to press tab
and it completes it for ourselves next
we already know we have to enter the
desktop
NF and nf2
and this brings us to the current
working directory here if we press LS we
can find a file over here now as
discussed for the concatenate it is used
to show the contents of a file so right
now if we press cat which stands for
concatenate
if I
as you can see we have written hello
Kali in the text file and we can see the
output right now
we can also use it to create new files
for example if we write cat
any file name such as e-file 2.
here we can write anything
hello Kali again
once you press Ctrl C here we can check
e File 2 and we have hello Kali again
printed over here we can see the same
using the concatenate command as well if
I press LS you can see we have two files
here and I can go with cat e file to
and I have Hello Kali again this is how
the concatenate command works
apart from this it can be used to copy
there is a different command like called
CP which is used to copy the files from
one place to another mindful this is not
moving this is only going to copy the
command for example currently our PWD
which is the present directory
is in the nf2 folder as you can see over
here
let's copy the E file to to the NF
folder
we can write CP
e file to
and give the path of the NF folder which
will be home
simply learn
Tech stock
and an F
now if I press LS I'll find both the
files and nf2 since I copied
to go back to the NF folder again we can
again use the same command of
none or we can again use the home
simply learn
desktop
and just an F no nf2 this time just
enough
as you can see this will change back our
present working directory now when we
press LS we will find the e-file to file
and the nf2 folder and we can confirm
this using the GUI as well
this is the NF folder and you can see
the nf2 folder and the e-file to
document if I write cat e file to
cat e file to
we can see the contents of the file now
this can be done using moving as well
for example if I go to CD nf2 which is
the inside folder it has both the
document files like e file and e-file 2.
let's say I want to move the e-file
completely from nf2 to NF1 instead of
writing CP the command I'm going to use
is MV
MV e file and again give the path of the
folder into which I have to copy which
will be again home
simply learn
desktop
and NF
as you can see the contents of the nf2
have appeared here and E file has been
moved
from nf2 to
NF
this is this nf2 and we do don't find e
file here anymore if we press CD dot dot
and we go back to NF LS right now and we
can file both the files e file that we
moved and E file to that we copied from
the nf2 folder so this is how copying
and moving will work using the terminal
now this is just a simple one line
statement that might take a couple of
clicks when using GUI this is why the
command line interface is considered to
be much more streamlined for Linux
operating systems
another very important con command for
Linux operating system is the sudo
command Sudo is short for super user do
the command enables you to perform tasks
that require administrative or root
permissions you can think of it as how
we run programs administrator on Windows
systems it is not advisable to use this
cupboard for daily use because it might
be easy for an error to occur and the
permissions of root are very intricate
so new beginners are advised to use the
sudo command only when absolutely
necessary for example
sudo SU
with this command I am giving this
terminal a root permission this Su
stands for this user
at this point it's going to ask for my
admin password
once I enter my password
and I now have root access note how the
password that I entered did not show up
here this is a security measure to
prevent people from snooping on your
root password which is the end game of
all this operating system
as you also can see the symbol changed
if the dollar symbol is showing it shows
as a standard user when you switch to
root you can easily see a hash symbol
this opens up a separate shell inside
this terminal command for example we can
exit out of the root user to the
standard user using the command exit and
once again we have the dollar sign and
the root has vanished over here there
are some commands that will only work
with administrative access for example
when updating the Kali Linux system we
have to use apt update
as you can see it says problem unlinking
the file because permission denied now
let's try this using sudo
sudo APD update
as you can see it is updating the
package repositories which work as the
software installed on the system
this can be done using either writing
the pseudo command every time we want to
perform a root access or we can just
write sudo Su once and write apt update
alone
the fetching is complete over here
for the second example let's say I just
write sudo Su and this time is not going
to ask me the password because at this
current terminal process I've already
provided the root password once and it
is in memory right now now when we used
to update the system we had to write
sudo apt update that was because we were
running it as a standard user now we are
running it as a root user so all we have
to write is if it update and it's going
to continue its work
there you go
another command that can be useful is
the Ping command
it's self-explanatory it's going to be
checking the internet connectivity you
can be used to check internet
connectivity or you can see if there is
a local server on your system which
needs to be ping then you can check that
for example if you have to write ping
and we can use either IP address or
domain let's say if you want to check
that if we can access google.com using
this Kali Linux installation or not we
can write ping google.com
and you can see it shows the bytes being
sent and received and how much time it
took to take up the request
this can be done for local systems as
well for example this installation of
Kali Linux is being run on a virtual
machine
once this machine is running I still
have my host machine running over here
the IP address of which is
192.168.29 179.
if I try to Ping this from here
as you can see the time to complete the
request is drastically low compared to a
website on the internet considering this
is on the local network
this is how the pink command is worked
and it can show you what kind of
packages are transmitted how many are
received if there was any kind of packet
loss between the connection window and
other details
a very important command when working
with the terminal for long duration is a
history command
pretty self-explanatory there are so
many commands that are being run
sometimes people forget what was the
change they did oh what was the
directory name they put a history
command helps to recover some of the
commands that you have written it
doesn't go all the way back but it takes
up many commands that were inputted in
the last few processes
this is how the history command works
these are some of the most commonly used
terminal commands if you want to learn
more about this terminal and every other
feature of this please let us know in
the comment section and we'll try to
make an in-depth tutorial special
figures
repeat if you want to learn more about
the terminal please let us know in the
comment section and we will try to make
an in-depth tutorial specifically for
terminal commands on Linux
moving on we learn how to configure
proxy chains on a system
proxying refers to the technique of
bouncing your internet traffic through
multiple machines to hide the identity
of the original machine it is a good
tool that hackers use to accomplish this
goal is proxy chains
essentially you can use proxy chains to
run any program through proxy server
this will allow you to access internet
from behind a restrictive firewall which
hides your IP address
even allows you to use multiple proxies
At Once by chaining them together
one of the most important reasons that
proxy chains is used in a security
context is that it's easy to evade
detection attackers often use proxies to
hide their true identities while
executing an attack
and when multiple proxies are chained
together it becomes harder and harder
for forensic professional to trace the
traffic back to the original machine
when these proxies are located across
countries investigators would have to
obtain warranties in the local
jurisdictions where every proxy is
located
to see how proxygen works let's open
Firefox first and check our current IP
address
write Firefox
and there we go
as we can see Firefox is now open
let's check our current IP address right
now
if we go to an address called my ip.com
and you can see it easily detects our
country is in India and this is a public
IP address
now
if we move to the terminal again
here we can now write
proxy chains
minus h
what is minus H does is it finds a help
it it stands for the help file this is
for help file
what we found out using this is proxy
chains has a config file here
Etc
proxychains4.conf this is the config
file found using this config file we can
customize how our proxy change should
work
if we want to open that we have to use
it in a text editor on Windows we have
notepad and other things like that
Microsoft Word to edit documents on
Linux we have a tool called Nano to
access the Nano we use the command Nano
and give the path of the file that we
want to check as of right now the proxy
chains config file is located over here
so we're going to follow the path there
chains 4 Dot comf
and here we go we see the config file
there are three basic types of proxy
chaining here
we have a strict chain where all the
proxy in the list
will be used and they will be changed in
order
we have a random chain where each
connection made through proxy genes will
be done via random combo of proxies in
the proxy list so in your Dynamic chain
it's the same as strict chain but dead
proxies are excluded from the chain
and here we can set up whichever type we
want
to enable or disable a particular type
we use the hash symbol here as you can
see right now all the lines have a
hashtag symbol at the front except this
one a dynamic chain this is the current
one being used let's say if I want to
use a strict chain method so I can add a
hash value here
and remove the hash here at one point of
time any one of these three four types
should be enabled
let's go for the denim Dynamic chain
we can disable this strict Chain by
putting the hashtag in front
and removing the dynamic chain
as you can see below we have few
commands to how to handle the Nano text
editor this symbol is known as the
control button on your keyboard now if
we want to write out which is synonymous
to saving the file
supposed to go with Ctrl O So if I press
Ctrl o on my keyboard it says file name
to write and we have to press enter here
since we want to overwrite the proxy
chains 4.0 NF file we don't want to
create a new file over here so just
press enter
and we get a permission to write this
permission denied we're getting is
because we have opened this using a
standard user Etc is a system folder to
be able to use make some changes we have
to use it using a sudo command
to exit this Nano we have to use the
control X command we use Ctrl X
we're going to clear
and this time we're going to use the
sudo command
sudo Nano
Etc
proxy chains
4.0
and we have the same file open up again
now this time if you want to make a
change let's say we're going to add a
strict chain instead of a dynamic chain
which remove the hashtag from strict
we're going to use Ctrl o for the save
file option we're going to press enter
and it says root 160 lines
again if you want to reverse this change
we put the hashtag over here
enable Dynamic chain
we press Ctrl o
press enter and it says root 160 lines
now we can exit straight away using the
control X format
right now we have not provided any file
or a proxy chain we can have proxy IP
addresses from the internet but we have
to make sure that they are safe and they
don't Snoop on our data
when there is no proxy change being
provided personally
it going it's going to use the Tor
Network but for that we have to start
door
Tor is a service in Linux to know more
about the store we can write sudo
systemctl which is used to know the
status of services on the Linux
operating system
and status of torque
a system CTL sorry uh as instead of STL
it should be system CTL status Tor as
you can see it is a toss service
anonymizing overlay Network for TCP
connections and it's currently inactive
now to start this up we have to write
sudo system CTL start
Dot now if we repeat the same sudo
system CTL status Star as you can see
it's active now
you can see the green logo over here
okay
to integrate the Firefox and the browser
we can use the proxy chains command
directly over here we can write proxy
chains we can use Firefox to launch our
web browser and let's say if we want to
visit google.com
we press enter
and the Firefox window is launched
and it should open a google.com next
and there we go
if we go to my ip.com once again
as you can see we have a different IP
address and the country is a known as
well
so this is how we can use proxy chains
to anonymize our internet usage when
using Kali Linux
next on our agenda is the ability to
scan networks using nmap
at its core nmap is a network scanning
tool that uses IP packets to identify
all the devices connected to a network
can learn more about nmap using their
help file
as you can see these are some of the
parameters that can be used when
scanning ports of a system you can see
the version and the URL of the webs of
the service
over here the primary uses of nmap can
be broken into three group processors
first the program gives you detailed
information on every IP active on your
network and then each IPA can then be
scanned
secondly it can also be used to
providing a lot of live hosts and open
ports as well as identifying the OS of
every connected device
thirdly
and map has also become a valuable tool
for users looking to protect personal
and business websites
using nmap to scan your own web server
particularly if you are hosting your
website from home is essentially
simulating the process that a hacker
would use to attack your site attacking
your own site in this way is a powerful
way of identifying security
vulnerabilities
as we already discussed The Host Windows
10 machine on the system has an IP
address a 192 168 29.179
if you want to test the OS scan of the
system we're going to first get the root
permission over here
we use the sudo command and now we are a
root user we're going to launch the
command and map
minus o which is supposed to be an OS
detection scan the IP address we can use
of the host system
192.168.29.179
in a legitimate penetration testing
scenario we can use the IP address of
the vulnerable disk device over here
we are going to let it scan for a while
and it's going to give us some guesses
on what can the OS be
as you can see the scan is done and it
has shown some of the ports that are
open
you can see the msrpc port open at the
https 443 Port open which is used to
connect to the internet and it has some
aggressive OS guesses as well for
example it thinks there's a 90 94 chance
that it's going to be a Microsoft
Windows XP Service Pack 3. that's partly
because a lot of the Windows XP update
packages are still prevalent on Windows
now that the OS detection is confirmed
there are multiple more details that we
can gather from nmap
let's go with the NF minus a command
which is supposed to capture as much
data as possible
there is also a speed setting you can
call it a speed setting or a control
setting of the minus t
minus t ranges from t 0 to T1 to T
through all the way up to D5
this basically determines how
aggressively the victim is being scanned
if you scan slowly it will take more
time to provide the results but it will
also give a less chance for the
intrusion detection system on the
vulnerable machine firewall to detect
that someone is trying to penetrate the
network for now if we want to go with
somewhat of a high speed we can go with
the T4 and provide the same IP address
of the local machine I am trying to
attack
it's going to take a little bit of time
since it's trying to capture a lot of
information
as you can see the results are now
here
it launched a scan and took a few top
ports that are most likely vulnerable
from a Windows XP perspective and it
showed
a few ports over here it has not shown
991 filtered ports which could not be
attacked anyway since they were closed
for outside access it shows a few
fingerprint settings like the connection
policies and the port details
it shows an HTTP options some other
intricate details that can be used when
you attacking its servers
it shows a VMware version that it's
running
and some few other ports over here
apart from that we also have the
aggressive OS gases over here just like
we did with the minus o and you can see
this time it is showing Windows 7 as 98
percent
no exact OS matches since uh if there
was any exact wise matches we could have
seen a hundred percent chances over here
this is a trace route a trace route will
be the time and the path a connection
request takes from the source to the
destination for example this request
went from 192
168.72.2 to a destination address since
this is a local machine it took only a
single step and multiple occasions so if
you're trying to access a remote system
it's going to be a number of free suits
when it jumps from firewall to firewall
and router to router
this is how we can use nmap to find
information about a system and find some
vulnerable ports we can access
moving on we have a tutorial on how to
use Wireshark to sniff Network traffic
to start using Wireshark we're going to
have to open the application first now
during installation of Wireshark there
is an option to enable if non-root users
can be able to capture traffic or not
in my installation I have disabled that
so I will be launching Wireshark when
using the root user itself
also to capture data we need an external
Wi-Fi adapter
you can see it over here in the VM tab
removable devices
re link 802.1 and WLAN
this is a external Wi-Fi adapter which
is inserted into my USB system
you can see it over here if I write
iwconfig
this is the one wlan0 this is absolutely
necessary because we need to have a
monitor mode required we won't need it
for sniffing data on Wireshark right now
but it's going to be necessary later on
in this tutorial as well as we will see
for now we can just start up Wireshark
by writing its name on the command line
and it should start the program
here we go
here it's going to check which of the
adapters we want to use for example
right now the eth0 which supposed to
stand for ethernet 0 Port you can see
data is being transmitted up and down
we're going to select eth0
and we have started capturing data you
can see this data requires from the
source so destination from the time and
the which protocol it is following
everything we can see and we can see the
ipv4 flags here as well
as you can see over here
capture internet traffic
we can try running Firefox
if we just write Wikipedia
.com
and you can see the number of requests
increasing
okay this is a spelling mistake
Wikipedia
yeah
you can see the application data of all
these requests going up
and they're connected to a destination
server of 1 0 through 102.166.224
now if you even if you check the
transmission control protocol Flags over
here and so many more things we cannot
find anything beneficial as you can see
the information over here is gibberish
which is supposed to be since it's
supposed to be encrypted
now
this is possible due to this being an
https website hence you can see the lock
symbol over here and connection is
supposed to be secure
now what about HTTP ports we have seen
many people recommend to not visit HTTP
ports
repeat
we have seen many people recommend to
not visit HTTP websites and even if we
have to visit to not provide any
critical information
for example let's go to a random
HTTP page over here
as you can see this is
saying connection is not secure and this
is an HTTP HTTP page and not https
now let's check for some of the
information that is passing through this
this is a login form let's say I have a
legitimate account over here
if I write my account name
and my password is supposed to be
password one two three four
I press login
and the password does not match because
I do not have an account over here but
let's say I did and I was logged in as
expected you can go to Wireshark we can
use filters over here now all the
requests that I am sending it's a TCP
request so I can write a filter
containing TCP
contains
whatever string if it is being passed
let's say for the end user name I write
my account name
so I can just write my account name over
here
and press enter
to find a request over here now as you
can see
there are many flags over here
if we go to the HTT HTML form URL
encoded and open up some of its Flags
as you can see I can see my account name
and simply learn password over here this
is the same
details that I input on the website
let's say I did have a legitimate
account on this website I would have
logged in with no problems but anyone
who will be using Wireshark to sniff on
the data can easily get my credentials
from here
this is why it's recommended to not
provide any information on HTTP Pages
the security is not up to the mark and
always look for the lock symbol when
visiting any website or making any
internet transactions or providing any
information
this is how we can use Wireshark to
detect transmission and sniff packet
data that is being transferred to the
network adapter
next we have to learn about what is
Metasploit
the Metasploit project is a computer
security project that provides
information about security
vulnerabilities and AIDS in penetration
testing and IDs development
we can open up the terminal here we're
going to allow root access
and to open up Metasploit the key word
is msf console
that's going to take a little bit of
time to start it up
now the Metasploit console has been
loaded
from here we can decide what type of
attack we want to launch and what kind
of exploits we can launch against
vulnerable targets
for example like we already discussed I
am running this virtual machine on a
Windows 10 host machine so if I open the
command prompt for my Windows 10 over
here
if I need to check the IP address once I
go with ipconfig
here you can see the IP address of this
local machine
moving on
if we have to attack that machine let's
say we want to see what kind of exploits
is going to work over there
now we already know that Windows has
some common vulnerabilities one of those
vulnerabilities is the HTA server
vulnerability HTA is supposed to be a
HTML application but when past the right
payload it can be used to open a back
door into a system
to start off with the Metasploit and
accessing such applications
we're going to use the command use
exploit and the name of the reverse HTA
server is this windows
for miscellaneous
HDA server
as you can see it already found this one
all right now there are some options
that we need to set for this exploit to
go through for example you can see some
of the options over here there is a
payload the payload is supposed to be
the malicious file that we are going to
send on the HTML application which
allows us to give the back door
for example right now the payload which
is the malicious file is a Windows meter
printer reverse TCP
completely understandable now let's set
the L host
L host and R host and SRV host should be
the one where we are going to launch the
attack from for example if we launched
another tab of this console
and we just press i f config
the IP address is 192 plus 168 72130
so we're going to set the L host as
192.168.72.130
and we're going to do the same thing
with SRV host
we're going to set up port
where we need to capture the back door
axis
next
the payload has already been set this
payload will launch a back door and give
us meter printer access to the system
metabritter is can be considered as an
upgrade of a normal command prompt shell
we will look into it once we get the
access in the first place
now that we have set the commands we can
press on exploit and press enter
now you can see we have a URL over here
we're going to copy this URL
once the URL is copied we take it into
the browser
and paste it
this will ask us to download this file
now as per browser security settings
this file should be blocked by default
we can decide to keep it and with the
correct formulation of this malicious
package even the website browser
antivirus softwares will not be able to
detect good payloads we're going to save
this file
and we're going to open it
publisher could not be verified if we
press run and we go back to our meter
beta access over here
you can see it has already captured the
URL of an HD server and it is writing
delivering payload
just have to wait for a few seconds so
the payload is delivered
it has sent this much amount of data
meter Peter session one is opened
and we should get the access soon
there we go now to understand where is
the session set
we can write sessions minus I
as you can see it has a meter beta over
here we're going to write sessions minus
I
recession ID is one so we're going to
write one and we have the meter beta
access now to get a fair idea of the
system so we're going to write Source
info and it's going to the computer name
the OS architecture all these things we
can write the help command to see what
are the things that we can get out of
the system we can take screenshots we
can control the webcam and start a video
chat
we can take a lot of things over here
there are other commands as well where
we can change the file directory like
the cad command CD command there are so
many things that work in the normal CMD
which we can run on the meter beta as
well now if you want to access this
command prompt of the system directly we
can go with this we have to write shell
and there we go we are in the downloads
folder right now to see if this is the
same computer or not we're going to
write ipconfig
as you can see it is our victim machine
with 192.168 or 29.171 we can just press
exit and we're back with the meter beta
access
this is how we can use metaprita and
Metasploit to gain access to a Windows
10 machine next let's take a look at how
we can get to root access from a Windows
10 system
we just learned how we can get a meter
beta access from a system
we can background this meter Builder
session by writing background and
pressing enter
we can still we can still see the shares
sessions minus I it's still present over
here
now
these kind of access are not
administrative access
these are the kind of back tools that
can be created for standard users but to
get a complete access of a system
including the program files the windows
documents we need to have root access or
administrative access
through that we're going to use another
exploit
reminder that the meter Peter session of
the standard access is already present
and we're not messing with it right now
we're going to set up another session
albeit with the same machine
that exploit name is
use exploit windows
local
bypass USC
Event Viewer
and there we go now if we check the
options that we can put in the system
we have to choose an exploit Target
we need to put a session as well
let's say we going to use the session
one this is the session that has the
meter beta access with the standard user
it doesn't have the system user
we're going to write
set Session One
and we're going to run export run a few
commands and it open a second meter
Peter session
as you can see it is the session 2.
if I write this info
you can still see I am not the
system user right now I'm still just a
normal user how can we check that
if you go to Shell
it's still CC users can be downloads all
these things
if I press exit go back to the meter
beta there is a command on meter beta
get system it attempts to elevate your
privilege to that of the local system
which basically means you get promoted
into root access so if we write get
system
and due to pipe impersonation we now
have the system root access
as you can see now it has become x64 and
we are the admin users now if I go to
Shell
I can easily go back
windows
and I can easily access these ones this
kind of control over the windows folders
and the program files folders these kind
of things are not possible if you are
not an admin access or the command
prompt has not been run with admin
permissions this is how we can use
privilege escalation to get into an
admin access system
we use the second exploit which was the
bypass us Event Viewer exploit
and essentially used to do the first
session as you can read here Windows
escalation USA protection bypass
it was first disclosed on 2016 but it
still works on some systems so let's
start out by learning what parrot
security is
parrot OS is a Debian based Linux
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom hard Linux kernel while
being founded in 2013.
parrot security contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and hobbies
it features a distant forensics mode
that does not Mount any of the system
hard disks or partitions and has no
influence on the host system making it
more stealthy than regular mode this
mode is used in the host system when
there is a need for executing forensic
procedures
in software development a rolling
release is a paradigm in which software
upgrades are rolled out constantly
rather than in batches of versions this
ensures that the software is constantly
up to date a rolling release
distribution such as parrot security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market
with a basic introduction to the
operating system out of the way let us
have a look at the bare minimum system
requirements necessary to be able to run
this operating system
first up we got a CPU requirement which
states that a one gigahertz dual core
CPU is the absolute minimum in order to
use parrot OS while multiple core
systems will provide more Optimum
performance a small beginner has been
included
a very distinct thing to be noted is
that the operating system can be
installed on all variants of chipsets
build 32-bit 64-bit and the newly
popular arm portfolio of devices
unlike Kali Linux which requires some
amount of graphical acceleration needed
to display the operating system
correctly paratoos has no such
requirements and can be used with the
leanest of machines
taking into account the ram issue a
minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free Ram
provides the optimum usage scenarios
even when the OS is installed on a hard
drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 GB
information which may extend up to 16 GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box
when it comes to booting options we have
the option of going with the Legacy BIOS
settings or with the more modern UEFI
settings
these are just some of the requirements
for the installation of parrot security
OS to understand this process more
vividly and to learn how visualization
can help install an OS in our existing
computer please follow the link to our
parrot security installation video
linked right above
let's understand what some of the things
that make parrot security unique among
all the other penetration testing
operating systems
along with all the giant catalog scripts
parent security has its own custom
hardened Linux kernel which has been
modified explicitly to provide as much
security and resistance to hackers as
possible as a first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as a second Gateway taking
care of malicious requests and dropping
them off
this is particularly beneficial since
should there be a scenario where the
latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the paratos development
team will most likely iron it out first
before passing it on as an update
if the custom hardened kernel wasn't
reasoning enough parrot security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the galley Linux
users
all the tools you found in Kali are
present in paratos and then a few extra
ones for good measure this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
size of the installation file between
both operating systems
however it's not all productivity points
for parrot OS they provide a choice
between two different desktop
environments the main desktop which
comes pre-installed by default and KDE
for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a Linux
system being highly modular in nature
one can use Kali Linux or parrot OS
while adding another desktop environment
which they find appealing
has only a single option paratos has
managed to provide two optimized bills
with made desktop and KDE desktop
ready-made on the website
one of the primary advantages of parrot
OS over Kali is at its relatively
lightweight
this implies that it takes frequently
less disk space and computing power to
function properly with as little as 320
MB of ram required
in reality parrot OS is also designed to
operate successfully of a USB stick but
Kali lilacs does not work well from a
USB stick and is generally installed in
a virtual machine
parrot OS can be seen as more of a niche
distribution if you're searching for
something lighter than color Linux there
are multiple ways to go about with this
installation
many people prefer to install it
directly onto a hard disk where the
parrot security OS will override
whichever data the hard disk already has
now this is beneficial if you want to
preserve your data for the long term but
this might pose some trouble to people
who do not have a spare hard disk or do
not want to lose their current
installation of Windows operating system
another way to use parrot security is by
using the live boot but whatever changes
you make to the live boot operating
system those changes are removed the
moment we restart or shut down the
system
a very good Common Ground between both
these installations is virtualization
using virtualization software like
VMware or virtualbox we can install
parrot Security on our systems while
simultaneously saving our data and
having the convenience of a host machine
such as a Windows operating system in
case things go wrong
to start the installation we first need
to get a ISO file for the parrot
security operating system
this can be found and the current
website
parrotsac.org
once you enter the website move into the
download section
and select the get security Edition over
here
parent security OS has multiple desktop
environments to you to choose from these
desktop environment serves as a
different user interface for the user
for example right now we have the made
desktop and the KDE desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to them
for our example let's go with the made
desktop
we have two options either we can go
with the direct download or we can get
the torrent file
for this example if we press on the
download button
and our download will start
I have already downloaded this file but
the ISO file provided over here will
serve as an installation it will have
around four and a half GB of space it
will be used to install this operating
system in VMware
once the file is downloaded we can close
this and open VMA Workstation
VMware can also be used as a player
version or the Workstation version if
you have much more familiarity with
using virtualbox or virtualization
application we can use that as well
once the VMware is open
we'll click on file and select a new
virtual machine
for the first time installation we're
going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine osis going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with a typical
option
moving on it will ask us for a source to
where to install the operating system
from since you're going to use a live
ISO first we're going to select the
third option which will be I will
install the operating system later and
press next
as we already know parent security is a
Debian derivative so When selecting the
guest operating system type we're going
to go with Linux
and the selection we're going to choose
whichever the highest version of Debian
is along with a 64-bit OS
we're going to click on next we're going
to name our virtual machine let's say
parrot security
OS
we're going to select the location where
we want to save the virtual machine this
will have all the hard disk of the
operating system installation
we're going to click on next
for the disk size we're going to specify
how much of the current memory are we
going to allocate this is the hardest
memory of the operating system
installation whatever changes you make
in the operating system whatever
applications we install on the virtual
instance will all be stored in this
amount of memory while it is recommended
to go with at least 15 GB of storage you
can go as high as possible and we're
going to select the recommended 20 GB as
written
when given the choice of storing the
virtual disk as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that helps
them stay portable people change systems
and sometimes they want to swap their
instances between the work and their
personal computer
if there is no portability in mind
storing the virtual disk as a single
file gives the best performance and
should be the recommended go to when
installing for the first time
we click on next here and it's going to
give us a summary of the settings we
have already settled till now
we're going to press on finish
and there we go we have our installation
First Step completed
here on out we're going to click on edit
virtual machine settings
here we're going to have a look at some
of the requirements that the parrot
security OS will need
it is known to be a memory lightweight
operating system but just to have the
almost Optimum performance we're going
to provide around 2GB of RAM from our
host system which is a Windows 10
machine
when it comes to the processors I'm
going to increase it to 2 and the number
of course to 2 as well so giving out a
total four processor cores to the
operating system now this depends on
what are your computer rig and how much
resources you can justify so these need
to be customized according to the system
at hand
size has already been set at 20 GB and
the rest of them are pretty standard and
we can go on
one thing that we need to make sure is
selecting the CD DVD IDE here we have to
use a ISO image file over here
previously it should be used physical
drive and at Auto detect we're going to
use a use ISO image file over here we're
going to click on browse
we're going to go to where we have
downloaded the ISO file which is over
here
and select it
press OK here
and we can now power on this virtual
machine
at this point of time there are two
options we can go with the try install
option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode
to get a better user experience we're
going to go with the try install mode
specifically press enter
and it's going to start the live boot
ISO meanwhile
VMware has an
prompt over here where it will try to
install some VMware tools on it while
this is not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with the
host system and many more things for now
we are going to close this prompt
foreign
security operating system
currently it's running the mate desktop
as we have downloaded in the website
the live boot ISO is necessary to get a
good feel of the operating system there
are many good Linux distros that have
this live boot option so that you can
give a try of the operating system
before installing it permanently
once you are into the live board we can
start up with the installation using the
shortcut as you can see install parrot
I'm going to double click it
and this is a calamaris installer
choose your language as American English
and press next
you can select your time zone according
to your location
character and we can go next
at this point of time you have to choose
the correct keyboard now what many
people go get confused is choosing their
own language keyboard but people must
keep in mind is what keyboard the laptop
provides
most of the systems that come pre-built
provide the English US keyboard so
whatever keyboard you choose make sure
to type here and test that all the
buttons including the superscript and
the subscript buttons are working
correctly before moving forward with
this step
once you've settled on the keyboard that
you need to install
you can go ahead
here it'll ask you to select storage
device and the only option you are going
to get is the amount of Hardware storage
you have given in the virtual machine
settings we have already provided 20 GB
of storage we're going to choose that
and we're going to erase this disk
manual partitioning can be useful when
you are going to install parrot Security
on an operating system or on a hard disk
where it is already including a Windows
OS for now we're going to select erase
disk and press next
we're going to give our full name Let It
Be simply learn
you can give the name of the computer
and if this is the username which you
will use to log in
this is your root password that we are
going to give over here the root
password of this Kali Linux will act as
the administrative access and it will be
necessary it will make changes to the
system or installing and updating
software
enter the password
and repeat it over here
you have the option to login
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this disabled
click on next
this is another summary of the
installation that we are going to move
forward with have a look at whatever
changes we have made is according to
your requirements and once everything is
checked we can press on install
click on install now
and we're going to let it complete the
work
as you can see the installation of
parrot security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart Now button over here disabled
I am going to click on done
we're going to shut down this live boot
ISO
I'm going to click on menu
turn of the device
and shut down
but not restarting straight away because
if you remember correctly in the virtual
machine instance settings we had given
it an ISO file
please remove the live medium and press
enter to continue we can just press
enter to continue
and it's going to shut down now to move
on we're going to click on edit virtual
machine settings
you go into CD DVD and we're going to
use physical drive now
we're going to remove it from the iso
image file because installation has
already been completed and we don't want
to use the same ISO file again and again
by using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20 GB hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it
I'm going to press ok
and we're going to power on this virtual
machine for testing
make sure this you clicky s over here
this is the grub menu
at this we get different choices for
example which NVIDIA drivers off or with
some other Advanced options
more often than not we're going to
choose the first option and press enter
if you remember clearly we did not get
the option of try install or a terminal
run just like we did in the live boot
ISO since this is running straight from
the 20 GB hard drive storage it's going
to start the OS directly
now with the login screen you can see
our username over here as we provided in
the installation
we're going to enter our root password
and press enter
and this is a currently working desktop
of the Paris security operating system
you can open the terminal over here
foreign
password and installation
to install any software we're going to
use the keyword sudo apt
install and Neo fetch
we're going to use the root password
that we use to log in
I'm going to press y for yes
this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of Hardware requirements
that we had provided
now that we have installed a Neo fetch
we can write the command Neo fetch
and this is going to give us some
information about our installation
you can see the OS name as parrot OS
4.11 is running on a VMware host it's
the kernel versions and some of the
other information like the number of
packages installed the current shell
version resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once
and some other things you can see the
memory is supposed to be 1951 megabytes
which is supposed to equal around 2GB of
RAM usage that we had provided
let us compare both these operating
systems directly with respect to their
Hardware specifications and usability
in the end we can decide on what
distribution is fit for each type of
user
for a first point of comparison let's
take a look at the ramp required
for Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature Prime usage is a very
important facet while College Linux
demands at least 1GB of ram parallel
security can operate optimally with a
minimum of 320 MB of RAM
for correctly displaying graphical
elements Kali Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parrot security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user side
once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos
they take up a minimum amount of hard
disk storage both of these operating
systems have a recommended disk storage
of minimum of 20 GB in Kali Linux and a
minimum of 15 GB in parrot security so
they can install all the tools necessary
in the ISO file
when it comes to the category and the
selection of tools Carl Linux has always
been the first in securing every single
tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry Security on
the other hand has managed to take it up
a notch
while specializing in Wireless pen
testing valid security makes it a point
that all the tools that Kali Linux
provides has been included in the iso
while simultaneously adding some extra
tools that many users will have to
install from third party sources in Kali
Linux
being a decade role penetration testing
distribution Kali Linux has formed up a
very big Community with strong support
signature parent Security on the other
hand is still growing and it is
garnering much more interest among
veteran penetration testers and ethical
hackers
a primary drawback of Kali Linux is the
extensive Hardware requirement
to perform optimally it requires higher
memory than parallel security it also
needs graphical acceleration while
demanding more virtual hard disk storage
parrot Security on the other hand was
initially designed to run off a USB
drive directly thereby requiring very
minimal requirements from a hardware
perspective like just 320 MB of RAM and
no graphical acceleration needed this
means parrot security is much more
feasible for people who are not able to
devote massive resources to either their
virtual machine or on their laptop hard
disk directly
with the comparison done between both of
these operating systems let's take a
look at the type of users both of these
are catered to
one can go with color Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years
if they have a powerful system which can
run Kali Linux optimally without having
to bottleneck performance
and if they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners
one can decide to go with parrot
security if they want to go with a very
lightweight and green distribution that
can run pretty much on all systems
it also has a lot of tools pre-installed
and some of them are not even present on
car Linux
it is much more suitable for
underpowered rigs where users do not
have a lot of Hardware resources to
provide to the operating system and
thereby it is much more feasible for
people with underpowered laptops or no
graphical acceleration
compared to Kali Linux parrot Securities
desktop environment is also relatively
easier to use for new beginners for
people who are just getting into ethical
hacking parrot security does a
relatively better job of introducing
them to the operating system and the
various tools without having to dump
them into the entire intricacies
in recent years the cost of data
breaches has steadily risen the
additional vulnerabilities that occur
due to the move to a remote Workforce
dramatically enhance the chances for
cyber attacks and introduce several weak
points for hackers to exploit
additionally automated hacking assaults
and the capacity to exchange Bitcoins
via ransomware have increased the cost
of cyber crime in general
companies workforces have transitioned
to full-time work from home models which
gives rise to new attack surfaces threat
actors target the people who are most
vulnerable by taking advantage of
current events and shifting situations
to better understand this growth in
digital crime let us go through a few
statistics
2020 brought with it a slew of new
problems for both businesses and
consumers in the midst of a worldwide
epidemic forest fires and political
instability it's easy to overlook a
serious albeit less physical threat it
set a record for data loss due to cyber
attacks as well as the sheer volume of
attacks 2020 is already outpacing its
predecessor the graph below denotes the
percentage of companies that fell victim
to at least one Cyber attack in the
respective year
with numbers growing steadily we are yet
to see the true Crux of this digital
Revolution
in situations like these penetration
testing has been a gift for
organizations worldwide while security
testing cannot guarantee a 100 solution
it can go a long way in securing those
critical data from falling into the
wrong hands
hey everyone this is Baba from Simply
learn
next we know about the benefits of
penetration testing and how the help
organizations save money in the long run
moving on WE familiarize ourselves with
the different types of penetration
testing or ethical hacking with each
serving a different category of
personnel
in the next section we read about the
five distinct phases in every ethical
hacking campaign and how they helped
clear up the extensive report at the end
of every penetration testing session
finally we have a live demonstration on
how we can check for vulnerabilities and
the ways hackers can break into devices
without adequate security measures in
place
let's start by learning about
penetration testing in general
organizations can Define penetration
testing based on the objectives of the
test
all networks applications devices and
physical security components are
included it imitates the behavior of
harmful individuals or the hackers
experience cyber security Specialists
use penetration testing to strengthen a
company's security posture and eliminate
any weaknesses that leave it vulnerable
to attacks penetration testing when done
correctly goes beyond simply preventing
thieves from Gaining unauthorized access
to a company systems it generates
realistic scenarios that demonstrate how
well our company's present defenses
might perform in the face of a full
skilled cyber assault the simulation
AIDS in the discovery of the sites of
exploitation and the testing of it
breach security
businesses May acquire professional and
biased third-party input on the security
procedures by conducting frequent
penetration testing
when testing while relatively time
consuming and costly can Aid in the
prevention of highly destructive and
expensive breaches
a white hat hacker employs hacking
talents to find security flaws in
Hardware software or networks on the
other hand white attack hackers follow
the rule of law when it comes to hacking
instead of black hat hackers
the assist firms in conducting
penetration tests to analyze the
security index and make the necessary
improvements
ethical hacking provides a full audit of
your security policies and in the case
of bug bounties can assist you in
identifying holes in existing
operational systems it takes a far
broader approach to cyber security than
penetration testing
whereas penetration testing focuses on
system flaws ethical hacking allows
actors to utilize any attack tactics
available to them
they can take advantage of system
misconfigurations send phishing emails
launch Brute Force password assaults
reach physical boundaries or do whatever
else they feel will get them access to
critical information
because thieves are progressively
changing up the approaches and launching
multi-layered complex attacks this is
incredibly useful for determining just
how exposed the organization is to cyber
threats
considering the vast domain that is
ethical hacking we have multiple
categories of penetration testing
methodologies let's cover them in the
next section
when configuring a security system
testing is critical to preventing
Hackers from penetrating the perimeter
there are three sort of tests Black Box
gray box and white box
in the Black Box testing the tester
receives no information during the
penetration test in this case the pen
tester takes the method of an
unprivileged attacker from initial
access and execution until exploitation
this scenario is the most realistic
showcasing how an attacker with no
inside knowledge May Target and
compromise an organization
however because of this it is also the
most expensive alternative
white box penetration testing which is
also known as Crystal Box testing
entails sharing all Network and system
information with the tester which
includes Network maps and passwords this
saves time and lowers the overall cost
of a project
a white box penetration test effectively
simulates a focused assault on a given
system using as many attack paths as
feasible
in a gray box penetration test also
known as a transparent box test very
restricted information is present with
the tester gray box testing is
beneficial for understanding the extent
of access a privileged person may get
and the possible damage they could wreck
Reebok tests achieve a mix between depth
and efficiency and may be used to mimic
either an Insider danger or an assault
that has infiltrated the network
perimeter
now that we covered the basics of
penetration testing and the relative
categories one must know how these
testing campaigns benefit the
organizations conducting them
let us go through a few perks of
penetration testing
regular penetration testing helps your
business assess the security of online
applications internal networks and
external networks it also assists you in
understanding what security measures are
required to achieve the degree of
protection your company needs to protect
its people and assets
prioritizing these risks offer firms an
advantage in anticipating hazards and
preventing harmful assaults
penetration testing is similar to a
real-life hacker rehearsing for a real
life hack regular penetration testing
helps you be proactive in your real
world approach to reviewing the security
of your it infrastructure the process
identifies gaps in your security
allowing you to correct any flaws before
an actual attack happens
it is undeniably expensive to recover
from the effects of a data breach legal
fees ID cleanup consumer protection
programs lost revenue and dissatisfied
customers may cause businesses Millions
penetration testing regularly is a
proactive strategy to remain on top of
your security and may assist in
preventing Financial damage from a
breach while safeguarding your brand and
image
penetration testing Aid in meeting the
compliance and security duties imposed
by industry standards and regulations
such as PCI HIPAA fisma and ISO 27001
having these tests done regularly help
demonstrate due care and a commitment to
information security all while avoiding
the significant fines associated with
the non-compliance
with the entire process seeming to be a
lengthy ordeal what are the multiple
phases in the process
theoretically we have to follow a five
stage process
reconnaissance is the first phase of the
penetration test in this phase the
security researcher collects information
about the target it can be done actively
meaning you are collecting information
by sending a request directly to the
Target and interpreting it passively
where you are collecting data without
contacting the Target or both
it helps security firms gather
information about the target system
Network components active machines Etc
this activity can be performed by using
information available in the public
domain and using different tools
the scanning phase is more tool oriented
rather than performed manually
the penetration tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the Target by using scanners such
as war dialers port scanners Network
mappers and vulnerability scanners the
penetration tester collects as many
vulnerabilities which help in turning to
attack a Target in a more sophisticated
way
the third phase is gaining access of the
system
in this phase the penetration tester
tries to connect with the Target and
exploit the vulnerabilities found in the
previous stage the exploitation will
buffer overflow attacks denial of
service dos attacks session hijacking
and many more
when tester extracts information and
sensitive data from the servers by
gaining access using different tools
in the fourth stage the hacker has to
maintain access the penetration tester
tries to create a backdoor for himself
it helps the penetration tester to
identify hidden vulnerabilities in the
system and can later access the machine
should the need arise
in the Final Phase of clearing and
covering tracks the penetration tester
removes all logs and Footprints which
help the administrator identify his
presence
this allows the penetration tester to
think like a hacker and perform
corrective actions to mitigate those
activities
with the cost of cyber security
platforms going up train penetration
testers receive an excellent level of
remuneration for the efforts as per
reports the average yearly salary for a
penetration tester is 6 lakh Indian
rupees of 110 000 in the American
counterpart
finally let's go over some of the ways
hackers can identify vulnerable
positions on a system to gather
information in a live demonstration
in this demo we will start by setting up
a VPN connection that will allow us to
access to a vulnerable Network by
creating a local virtual group over the
internet
we then try to scan the victim machine
for breachable entry points find the
username and password of the user in
question and eventually grab the root
password from the device
to start our demonstration we're going
to need a vulnerable machine to work on
now this vulnerable machine can be found
on the website known as try hack me
which is a service catered towards
penetration testers
before we connect to the machine we need
to
join the network where the machine is
located
we can do that using an ovpn file which
is short for openvpn protocol
to connect to this ovpn file we're going
to going to a new workspace on parrot
security
we're going to activate the root
access
and we're going to connect to it
practice Dot ovpn
once you see the message initialization
sequence completed
we can be sure that we have connected to
the network which has the vulnerable
machine
now to start the vulnerable machine
we're going to click this button and
wait for a few seconds
as you can see it gives a one minute
countdown before it shows you the IP
address
now remember whatever the IP address we
receive here it is a machine being
launched on the try Hackney servers but
we can access that machine because of
the ovpn connection that we have just
set up using this file this ovpn file
can be found on the try hack me servers
profile section which I downloaded
beforehand
as you can see we now have the IP
address of our victim machine
let's try if we can reach this machine
or not
we're going to copy the IP address
and we're going to try and ping to the
machine
if the connection is successful and we
have joined the network we should be
able to see some response over here
as you can see we're receiving request
pings from the victim machine which
means that we have already joined the
victim Network
now that we are confirmed we are able to
access the vulnerable machine
let's run the first step in a
penetration test which is reconnaissance
let's run up and map scan
we're going to use the flag of SV so
that we can know which version of the
service it is running
we're going to take up the IP address
and paste it here
this can only be possible if the openvpn
connection is up and running
as you can see it is still running
and we have our results over here
by running the scan so that we can find
the services running on the host machine
that we will run nmap against
we conclude that a web service is
running actually on Port 80 as we can
see over here which is using the Apache
server system
in addition to this there is a SMB Samba
Service as well
running on ports 139445
now that you know we have an Apache
server we can use this IP address
to open it on a browser
okay
since the current home page is not
accessible we can use some other URLs as
well
let's press Apache servers are concerned
there are a certain set of URLs that can
be used to open
however if we go to the URL which is IP
address slash
development
this opens up a new folder
if we try to check the contents of these
files this is for the dev.txt
you can see the version of the Apache
HTTP server that is being run
this is the dev.txt
if we go back and we check the second
file as well
it says the contentsy shadow has the
credentials
okay if we go back again
SMB has been configured
which we have already found at nmap that
it is running a Samba server
now with this version of the Apache
server we can find version specific
exploits that can be run on Metasploit
but there is sometimes no no need of
that we can use another technique as we
now know that there are multiple users
that is being run over here
we can use a tool known as enum for
Linux
what it does is acts and enumerates the
windows and a Samba systems
to run that command we're going to use
enum for Linux
minus a
and we're going to take IP address of
the machine
I'm going to paste it here
what this will essentially do is provide
us usernames that are being stored in
the victim machine
it's going to take some time to find out
the usernames once we find those out we
can run the necessary attacks
as we have already seen on the nrap it
is also happening in SSH port
so if you find the username and we find
a single hash that can be cracked we can
use the SSH to get inside the machine
right now you have to wait for the
results
of the enum for Linux command
as you can see
we have found two users of the machine
known as K and Jan
I think we can stop the enumeration
right now since we have the two users of
this machine
Next Step what we can do is we can try
to SSH into the machine
now to run the SSH command we're going
to need the password of one of the users
for this example let's say we go with
the user of Jan
to Brute Force we're going to use the
Hydra 2
this is like an example command this is
how we can use let me just copy this
and paste it over here
all right
Hydra minus L user as we have already
decided we're going to use the user Jan
and
we're going to use SSH
for the IP address we're going to copy
it from here
and paste it here
now for the password list we're going to
use a word list
which has a few passwords already
present in it for this example I am
going to use the raw queue.txt file
which has like millions of passwords
already stored in it what the Hydra will
do it will try to bypass the SSH console
on the machine using the passwords
present in the rocky.txt file
we will give the path of rock Q over
here
like this
and we're going to run it
as you can see it's mentioned that it's
attacking SSH at this IP address
now this attack is going to take a while
and after this attack is done we are
going to get the SSH password which is
basically the credentials of the Jan
user in the victim machine
for now I am going to stop this attack
what I would recommend is for you to run
this attack and write down the password
that you received in the comment section
below
the password that we receive from here
can be used to login into the machine
let's try that once
put SSH into the machine we're going to
write SSH user at the rate
IP address
we're going to write yes and press enter
now we're going to enter the password
that we have found after running the
Hydra command
I am going to type the password and
press enter
and we have logged in
as you can see
now if we try to look around
there are no directories over here okay
so let's go one step back
give a space over here okay
let's go to the second users folder
okay
these are the contents of the K folder
and you can see there's a DOT SSH folder
over here so we're going to enter that
let's have a look the files in this
folder
and we can file in RSC ID over here
which if I'm not wrong should be an RSA
private key
which can be used to SSH into the
machine here we go you can see it's a
big in RSA private key and it should end
here as well now what this private key
does this hash will be used to log SSH
into the machine when using the user k
once this hash is cracked using Hydra or
any other cracking software like John
the Ripper we can easily use the
passphrase to login into the machine
with the user of K
what I am going to do is copy this
private key
I'm going to launch a new terminal
we'll create a new file known as nanoid
paste the private key over here
and save it
as you can see you have saved the file
over here
now this hash can later be used to crack
into the machine using the user of K
this hash can be cracked using either
John the Ripper Hydra or there are other
Cloud mechanisms that can be used to
crack this machine
after it is cracked
we can use the passphrase derived from
it to SSH into the machine
to perform the SSH entry we're going to
use this command SSH minus I
are going to use the same file
which we received
we're going to write the username which
is K
10.10
you can just copy it from the
here
right
minimize this and paste the IP address
over here
or we can do one more thing we're going
to use a sudo command together as well
it's better
sudo SSH
enter the system password
this passphrase is the one that we
received after cracking the hash in this
ID file
whichever password you received after
cracking this using Hydra or John the
Ripper please write the password in the
comments section so that we can know
that we have successfully cracked the
password we're going to write the
passphrase over here press enter
and as you can see we have entered the
system of K
here we're going to press LS
and we find
the backup file of the password I'm
going to write
cat
password back and
here is the final root password
so as you can see we have now we have
now received the final root password of
the primary user and we have already
cracked the password of the other user
that is Jan
so this is the entire process of how you
can use nmap to find out the vulnerable
points you can see which are the
softwares that are running which
versions they are running and which of
those versions have a legitimate claim
as an NC class exploit
malware is a malicious software that is
programmed to cause damage to a computer
system Network and Hardware devices
many malicious programs like Trojan
viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive data
let's take a look at the introduction
for two different types of malware virus
androgen
firstly let's take a look what exactly
is a virus program
a computer virus is a type of malicious
program that on execution replicates
itself
they get attached to different files and
programs which are termed as host
programs by inserting their code if the
attachment succeeds the targeted program
is termed as infected with a computer
virus now let's take a look at the
trojanos
Trojan Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms a system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create bad doors into a
system to allow the Cyber criminal to
steal our information
let's take a look how they function
after getting installed into a system
firstly we have wireless programs the
computer virus must contain two parts to
infect the system
first is a search routine which locates
new files and data that is to be
infected by the virus program
and the second part is known as the copy
routine which is necessary for the
program to copy itself into the targeted
file which is located by the search
routine now let's take a look at the
Trojan Horse functioning
for Trojan horses entryway into a system
is through emails that may look
legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the closed
program gets installed and infects the
system
they also infect the system on the
execution of infected application or the
executable file and attacks a system
now that we understand what virus and
Trojans are let's understand different
types of virus androgens
let's take a look at different types of
viruses the first one is known as the
boot sector virus this type of virus
damages the booting section of the
system by infecting the masterbot record
which is also known as MBI
this damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the system
then we have the macro virus microvirus
is a type of virus that gets embedded
into the document related data and is
executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale
and lastly we have the direct action
virus
this type of virus gets attached to
executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system
once the infection of the file is
completed they exit the system which is
also the reason it is known as a
non-resident virus
let's take a look at different types of
Trojans
the first type of corrosion is the back
dot erosion they are designed to create
a back door in the system on execution
of an infected program
they provide remote access of a system
to the hacker this way the Cyber
criminal can steal our system data and
may use it for illegal activities next
we have
Crick Source program
they enter the system by clicking the
random pop-ups which we come across on
the internet
they tell the user to give their
personal details for different
transactions or schemes
which may provide remote access of a
system to the Cyber Criminal
and the last Trojan type is Ransom
Trojan this type of Trojan program after
entering the system blocks the user from
accessing its own system and also
affects the system functioning
the Cyber criminal Demands a ransom from
the targeted user for the removal of the
Trojan program from the device now that
we understand some details regarding
viruses and Trojan let's solve a
question
the question is J equals denies access
to his system and he wasn't able to
control the data and information in a
system
now the actual question is what could be
the reason behind a systems problem
option a macro virus option b Ransom
Trojan option C Backlot version
give your answers in the comment section
now let's understand how to detect the
activity of viruses and Trojan in our
system
to detect virus or Trojan activity in a
system we can refer to the following
points for viruses we have slowing down
of the system and frequent application
freeze shows that the infection of the
virus is present in the system
then we have the viruses can also steal
sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected logout from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have frequent system crashes
due to virus infection which damages the
operating system
for Trojan we have frequent system
crashes and system also faces slow
reaction time
then we have there are more random
pop-ups from the system which may
indicate Trojan activity and lastly we
have modification in the system
application and change of the desktop
appearance can be also due to the
infection of a Trojan program
next let's take a look at a famous Cyber
attack for virus and atrogenous
for virus we have the midoom virus which
was identified in the ER 2004 which
affected over 50 million systems by
creating a network of sending spam
emails
which was to gain backdoor access into
our systems
next for the Trojan Horse we have the
emotextrojan program
which is specifically designed for
financial theft and for stealing Bank
related information
next we have few points for how to
prevent virus entry or Trojan attack for
a system
the most basic way of virus protection
is to using antivirus and do regular
viruses can this will prevent virus
entry in the system and also having more
than one antivirus provides much better
protection
then avoid visiting uncertified websites
can also prevent virus entry into a
system
then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry
for corrosion we have using certified
softwares from legal sites to prevent
any Trojan activity in a system
and also avoid clicking random pop-ups
that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and firewalls
for protection against Trojan horses is
a good habit
now that we have reached the end of the
video Let's Take a look what we learned
for the first part we saw the main
objective of the virus is to harm the
data and information in a system whereas
for the Trojan we have stealing of the
data files and information
effect of viruses is more drastic in
comparison to the Trojan horses
then we have viruses which are
non-remote programs whereas Trojan
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
Trojan does not have the replication
ability let's take a look at some of the
famous potent attacks
the first one is Mirai botnut which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a network of bots that on
command perform basic and medium level
denial of service attacks
then we have the zoo spot specifically
designed for attacking the system for
Bank related information and data
now let's take a look at the agenda for
today's video
firstly we will understand what is a
botnet then we'll see how exactly a
botnet works
after that we'll learn some of the
architectures how our botnet works on
off in the end we learned how to protect
ourselves from botnet attacks
now let's see what exactly a botnet is
botnet refers to a network of hijacked
interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious quotes known as
malware
each of these infected devices are known
as Bots and a hijacked criminal known as
bot hoarder remotely controls them
the Bots are used to automate large
scale attacks including Data Theft
server failure malware propagation
and denial of service attacks
now that we know what exactly a button
it is let's dive deeper into learning
how botnet works
during the preparation of a bottleneck
Network the first step involves
preparing the botnet Army after that the
connection between the botnet Army and
the control server established and the
end the launching of the attack is done
by the bot hoarder
let's understand through our
illustration
firstly we have a bot order that
initiates the attack
according to the control server commands
the devices that are infected with the
malware programs and begins to attack
the infected system let's see some
details regarding the preparation of the
botnet army
the first step is known as the prepping
the botnet army the first step is
creating a botnet is to infect as many
as connected devices as possible this
ensures that there are enough Bots to
carry out the attack
this way it creates Bots either by
exploiting the security gaps in the
software or websites or using phishing
attacks they are often deployed through
Trojan horses
for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks a device as per previous step it
infects it with a specific malware that
connects the device back to the control
button server a bot header uses command
programming to drive the bot's actions
and the last step is known as launching
the attack
once infected a bot allows access to
admin level operation like Gathering and
stealing of data reading and rewriting
the system data monitoring user
activities performing denial of service
attacks including other cyber crimes
now let's take a look at the important
architecture
the first type is known as client server
model the client server model is a
traditional model that operates with the
help of a command and control center
server and communication protocols like
IRC
when the bot order issues a command to
the server it is then relayed to the
clients to perform malicious actions
then we have peer-to-peer model here
controlling the infected Bots involves a
peer-to-peer Network that relies on a
decentralized approach that is the ports
are topological interconnected and acts
as both CNC servers that is the server
and the client to the hackers adopt this
approach to avoid detection and single
point failure
in the end we will see some points on
some counter measure against botnet
attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates
after that we should avoid clicking
random pop-ups or links that we often
see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti-spyware software's and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack
Jane is relaxing at home when she
receives an email from a bank that asks
her to update her credit card pin in the
next 24 hours as a security measure
judging the severity of the message Jane
follows the link provided in the email
on delivering her current credit card
pin and the supposedly updated one the
website became unresponsive which
prompted her to try sometime later
however after a couple of hours she
noticed a significant purchase from a
random website on that same credit card
which she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with a malicious link that
Intel credit card fraud this is a
classic example of a phishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted source
basic purpose is to trick the victim
into revealing sensitive information
like passwords and payment information
it's based on the word phishing which
works on the concept of baits if a
supposed victim catches the bait the
attack can go ahead which in our case
makes Jane the fish in the phishing
emails the bait if Jane never opened the
malicious link or was cautious about the
email authenticity an attack of this
nature would have been relatively
ineffective
but how does the hacker gain access to
these credentials a phishing attack
starts with a fraudulent message which
can be transmitted via email or chat
applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of phishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns or an identical fishing
mail sent to thousands of users the rate
of success is relatively low but never
zero
between 2013 and 2015 corporate giants
like Facebook and Google were tricked
off of 100 million dollars due to an
extensive fishing campaign where a known
common associate was impersonated by the
hackers apart from credit access some of
these campaigns Target the victim device
and install malware when clicked on the
malicious links
which can later function as a botnet or
a target for ransomware attacks there is
no single formula for there are multiple
categories of phishing attacks the issue
with Jay or the hacker Stoler Bank
credentials falls under the umbrella of
deceptive fishing a general email is
sent out to thousands of users in this
category hoping some of them fall prey
to the scam
spear fishing on the other hand is a bit
customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
drawback of deceptive fishing techniques
on the other hand a simple screenshot of
a Spotify playlist being shared on
social media indicates a probable point
of entry the hacker can send counterfeit
messages to the Target user while
implying the source of such messages
being Spotify tricking them into sharing
private information
since the hacker already knows the
target uses Spotify the chances of
victims taking the bait increase
substantially
for more important targets like CEOs and
people with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10 full which can be
called a case of whaling the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their phishing attack often to
still industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price
apart from just emails farming focuses
on fake websites that resemble their
original counterparts as much as
possible a prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit webpage which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cache poisoning but
they are rarely carried out due to time
and resource constraints
now that we know how phishing attacks
work let's look at ways to prevent
ourselves from becoming victims while
the implications of a phishing attack
can be extreme protecting yourself
against these is relatively
straightforward
Jane could have saved herself from
credit card fraud had she checked the
link in the email for authenticity and
that it redirected to a secure website
that runs on the https protocol even
suspicious messages shouldn't be
entertained one must also refrain from
entering private information on random
websites or pop-up Windows irrespective
of how legitimate they seem it is also
recommended to use secure anti-phishing
browser extensions like cloudfish to
snip out malicious emails from
legitimate ones the best way to prevent
phishing is browsing the internet with
care and being on alert for malicious
attempts at all times
so here is a question for you if both me
and my friends received the same email
that instructs us to change our Spotify
password before the end of the day even
though one of us never use Spotify what
bracket does this phishing attack fall
under
one whaling two spear fishing three
deceptive fishing four farming
think about it and leave your answers
Below in the comments section and three
lucky winners will receive Amazon gift
vouchers
cyber attacks are becoming more
prevalent due to the pandemic where work
from home is the norm and people spend
possibly more than half their day with a
laptop but we cannot stop every attack
at the root we must be informed and
Vigilant to phishing attacks among
others to safeguard our data it's the
year 2015 and Richard has just finished
playing games on his computer
after a long gaming session Richard
tries to shut it down but find some
random text file on the desktop that
says Ransom note the text file mentioned
how a hacking group had encrypted
Richard's game files and private
documents and he had to pay a ransom of
500 worth of bitcoin in the specified
Bitcoin address
Richard quickly checked his files only
to see them being encrypted and
unreadable
the story of how the Tesla Crypt
ransomware spread in 2015 which affected
thousands of Gamers before releasing the
master key used for encrypting the files
so what is ransomware
for Richard to be targeted by such an
attack he must have installed
applications from untrusted sources or
clicked an unverified link both of them
can function as gateways for a
ransomware breach ransomware is a type
of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
a password a text files available to the
victim explaining how to make the ransom
payment and unlock the files for it
just like Richard found the ransom note
text file on his desktop
even after the money has been paid
there's no guarantee that the hackers
will send the decryption key or unlock
the files but in certain sensitive
situations victims make the payment
hoping for the best having never been
introduced to ransomware attacks before
this gave Richard an opportunity to
learn more about this and he began his
research on the topic
the spread of ransomware mostly starts
with phishing attacks to know more about
phishing attacks click the link in the
button above users tend to click on
unknown links received via emails and
chat applications promising rewards of
some nature once clicked the ransomware
files installed on the system that
encrypts all the files or blocks access
to computer functions they can also be
spread via malware transmitted via
untrusted application installation or
even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access
a computer can be accessed remotely
using this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware which is the type of malware
that blocks standard computer functions
from being accessed until the payment to
the hackers is complete it shows a lock
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers
once the files are encrypted finding the
decryption key is impossible unless the
ransomware variant is old and the keys
are already available on the internet
scareware is fake software that claims
to have detected a virus or other issue
on your computer and directs you to pay
to resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with pop-up
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security
one must always have backups of their
data cloud storage for backup is easy
but a physical backup in a hard drive is
always recommended
keeping the system updated with the
latest security patches is always a good
idea
apart from system updates one must
always have reputed antivirus software
installed many antivirus software like
Kaspersky and bitdefender have
anti-ransomware features that
periodically check for encryption of
private documents when browsing the
internet a user must always check for
the lock Sim on the address bar which
signifies the presence of https protocol
for additional security
if a system is infected with ransomware
already there is a website
nomoreransom.org it has a collection of
decryption tools for most well-known
ransomware packages it can also help
decrypt specific encrypted files if the
list of anti-ransomware tools didn't
help the victim
so here's a question for you what should
be the first course of action after a
ransomware attack
one contact the criminal authorities two
run antivirus scan for the entire system
3. recover from local or Cloud backups
4. isolate device from the parent
Network
think about it and leave your answers in
the comments section
three lucky winners will receive Amazon
gift vouchers ransomware attacks have
become increasingly common due to the
shift in corporate work culture from
in-office to work from home in March
2021 a chicago-based company called CNA
Financial was attacked by a ransomware
that affected nearly 75 000 users the
company was later forced to pay out 40
million dollars to get their system
access back ransomware costs businesses
more than 75 billion dollars per year
and we must take the necessary steps to
incur as minor damage as possible so
that was ransomware in a nutshell a
growing concern among Security
Professionals worldwide to understand
the key logging problem better let's
take a look at an example
this is June she works in a business
firm where she manages the company's
data regularly
this is Jacob from the information
Department who is here to inform her
about some of the security protocols
during the briefing she informed him
about some of the problems a system was
facing with which included slow reaction
speed and unusual internet activity
as Jacob heard about the problems with
the system he thinks of the possibility
what could be the reason behind these
problems a system was facing with
the conclusion that he came across was
the key logging issue
unknown to the problem her system was
facing with she asked him about some of
the details regarding it
for today's topic we learn what exactly
keyloggers are and how they affect our
system what are the harmful effects that
key logging can bring into the system
for today's agenda we learn what exactly
the key logging program is
then we will see how the system gets
infected what are different methods of
the key logging issue enter into the
system
then we'll take a look at different
types of methods how to detect the key
logging issue into the system
then we will take a look at different
types of keyloggers that are present and
how the effect differently into the
system
then we'll take a look how the hackers
use the recorded data that has been sent
by the key logging program
and then we'll take a look at a case
where the mobile devices get infected
with the key logging issue
and lastly we will take a look what are
different prevention methods available
to prevent the system from getting
infected by the key logging issue
to begin with we learn what exactly the
key logging program is
as the name suggests keylogger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record keystrokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a log file then the same program
secretly sends these log files to its
origin
where they can be used for malicious
acts by the hacker
now that we know what the key logging
program is let's take a look how they
enter into the system
searching for a suitable driver for a
system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into a system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind a key logging issue entering into
the system
and lastly there are often cases where
different pop-ups that we often see on
social sites or different media sites
can lead to the installation of key
logging program into a system
now that we know how the problem gets
into the system let's take a look how to
identify whether the system is infected
by the key logging issue
the key logging issue can be identified
if there are often cases when a keyboard
lags behind the system
the data that we enter sometimes is
stuck in between when we type through
the input
then there are cases when the system
freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system
and lastly there are different cases
when we often see suspicious internet
activity on the system that we don't
know about this could lead to the
identification of a problem into the
system
now we'll take a look at different types
of key loggers that are present on the
net which can harm our system
differently
the first problem that keyloggers arouse
is API based the most common key logging
case which uses apis to keep a log of
the type data and share it to its origin
for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and locks it
then we have form grabbing based
keyloggers as the name suggests they are
a best key loggers that store the form
data that is if we often use waveforms
or different kinds of forms to enter
different data they can be recorded into
the system by the program and send it to
its origin
then we have kernel based keyloggers
these key loggers are installed deeply
into the operating system where they can
hide from different antivirus if not
checked properly and they record the
data that we type on the keyboard and
send it to its origin
and lastly we have Hardware Key loggers
these key loggers are present directly
into the hardware that is they are
embedded into system where they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
now let's take a look how hackers
differentiate different type of recorded
data and exploit them
when hackers receive information about
the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related issues
then in case of company data that is
recorded by the key logging program can
also affect the economic value of the
company in the market which may lead to
the downfall of the company
also in some cases the key logging
program can also log data about military
Secrets which may include nuclear codes
or security protocols which are
necessary to maintain the security of a
country
now let's take a look whether mobile
devices get infected with the key
logging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
key loggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use on-screen
keyboard or virtual keyboard
but in some cases we often see different
kinds of malicious programs getting
installed into the hand device if we
often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites
and also the device that is infected
with the key login issue or different
kind of malicious program can often lead
to the exploitation of data that
includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the system
now to prevent a system from getting
infected by the key locking program
let's take a look at different points
the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering or
malicious program into the system
then keeping system security protocols
regularly updated is also a good habit
and lastly using virtual keyboard to
input are sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related different
websites
now that we have some understanding
about the topic of keyloggers let's take
a look at the demo to further increase
the knowledge about the topic
for the first step we have to download
some of the important libraries that are
required into the system
which is
this Library
now we'll run it
the system says the library is already
installed into the system
now let's take a look what exactly
modules are required from the particular
Library
from this Library we'll import
the keyboard module which will help us
to record the data that we type on the
keyboard
now from the same we'll also import
key module
and The Listener module
and also
the logging module which will help us to
record the data into a log file
for the next part
we'll write a piece of code that will
allow us to save the data that is
recorded by the program into our text
file that will be named as key
underscore log text file along with the
date and time stamp let's take a look
now we'll provide it with the file name
that will be given as
key log dot txt file
and also so the part where the format of
the data is recorded
put the brackets over here to contain
the file name now we'll write the format
in which the data will be recorded into
the log file which will be given as
the format would be
the message and the timestamp which
would be given as
a long way
the timestamp
even as percentage
and ending it with the bracket
now for the next step we will Design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a look
while press function
would be a function that will come into
play when the keyboard key has been
pressed
is
and
this would go for the
format that we designed
in the above line
and
logging
the Pressed key
info
a string file
to be recorded
into the log file
now
we'll design a function that is while
release
that will come into play
fin
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from running
and in the end
we require for the functioning of the
program to loot these functions that is
while press and while it leads to
continuous cycle
that will be going for
while
press
and
on
release will contain while release
function
as
listener
and now
this part
would join the different threads and
store them into the log file
now that we have completed the code for
the program let's run it
we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
no
to verify the program let's open Notepad
and on the notepad
we'll write
hello world
which will be the basic whether the
program is working or not let's take a
look
and we will go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page
go to the bottom
over here we see the key log text that
is a text file that we created
let's open it
and over here we have the data that is
created as we started with Note
then this is a Hello World part that we
created just now
which shows that the program we created
is working properly
let's take a look at some of the
detection methods for keylogger in a
system
first one is
the keystrokes that we make become
sluggish that is the reaction speed from
the hardware keyboard which is slower
than usual
then we have instances where our system
gets hanged or freezes in between the
work
there are also cases when there is
suspicious unusual activity in the
internet
and lastly there are some unknown
programs that are running in the
background of the system
these four are General cases where we
can observe whether the system is
infected with a keylogger program or not
to better understand key logging
activity in a system let's take a look
at the demo for the same
for the first step let's execute the key
logging program in a system
over here I am using
a python key login program
and if you want to know more about the
key logging program in Python you can
watch our previous video on what are key
loggers let's begin now
let's execute the program
and wait for a second or two for the
program to continue execution
okay let's take a look whether the
program is working properly
we can see that the key logging program
would create a text file named key
underscore log let's take a look
key underscore log seems like the
program is working fine let's try typing
something on the notepad
hello world
now let's see whether the recorded data
comes
seems like the program is working fine
the data is recorded hello world
with exclamation marks
along with the time
now let's try detecting the keylogger
program using different detection
methods
for the first step you can access your
settings
where you should go for Windows update
over here you would often see some of
the updates regarding security measures
that is the very basic step if you want
to detect key logging activity in your
system
let's take a look at the second
detection method for this you can use a
start option and type task manager
using the task manager app you can see
some of the programs that are displayed
these programs are the ones that are
currently working or executed in my
system right now if you see any unusual
program that has been executed without
your knowledge May refer to a keylogger
program
and if you find any unusual program that
has been executed on your system right
now you should
right click on the program and choose
option and task this will immediately
end the task that is being executed
which might protect your data from being
recorded
let's take a look at the third option
how we can detect the key loggers
in the task manager use the option
startup
in the startup option represents the
softwares or programs that get executed
when the system is turned on
if you see any unusual program or
software mentioned in any of these in
your system you might have to disable
that
this representation unusual program or a
malicious tool that is being executed
when you start up your system which may
relate to a key logger problem
and the last method to detect keylogger
activity is to type something
if you feel there is some restrictions
or there's a gap between when you type
the key on your keyboard and the
reaction speed becomes slow even by a
millisecond this might represent there
is a program that is interfering with
the keyboard
if you use the following detection
methods you might save yourselves from
being spied down or getting your data
recorded that you type on your system
Jude is waiting at the airport to hop on
her flight back home when she realizes
that she missed making an important Bank
payment
she connects her laptop to the public
Wi-Fi at the airport and goes ahead to
carry out the bank transaction
everything goes well and Jude completes
her transaction
after a couple of days she was wiped off
her feet when she learned that her bank
account was subjected to a Cyber attack
and a hefty amount was wiped from her
account
after getting in touch with the bank
Authority she learned that her account
was hacked at the airport
she didn't realize that the public Wi-Fi
she used might have caused her this
trouble Jude wishes that Hatter bank
transfer escaped the Hacker's eyes she
would not have been a victim of a Cyber
attack
Bank officials advise her to use a VPN
for future transactions especially when
connecting to an open or public network
like most of us Jude had come across the
term VPN several times but didn't know
much about it and little did she think
that the repercussions of not using a
VPN would be this bad
let's understand how the hacker would
have exploited jute's transaction in the
absence of a VPN
in this process Jude's computer first
connects to the internet service
provider ISP which provides access to
the internet
she sends her details to the bank's
server using her IP address
Internet Protocol address or IP address
is a unique address that recognizes a
particular device be it a laptop or
smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it this is a passive Cyber attack where
the hacker collects Jude's Bank details
without being detected
more often or not in such an attack
payment information is likely to be
stolen the targeted data here are the
victims username passwords and other
personal information
such an unsecured connection exposed
Jude's IP address and Bank details to
the hacker when it passed through the
public network
so would you have been able to secure
her transaction with the help of a VPN
well yes picture Jude's Bank transaction
to be happening in a tunnel that is
invisible to the hacker in such a case
the hacker will not be able to spot a
transaction and that is precisely what a
VPN does
a virtual private Network more often
known as VPN creates a secure tunnel
between your device and the internet
for using a VPN Jude's First Step would
be to install software-based technology
known as the VPN client on our laptop or
smartphone that would let her establish
a secure connection the VPN client
connects to the Wi-Fi and then to the
ISP
here the VPN client encrypts Jude's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure
next the VPN client establishes a VPN
tunnel within the public network that
connects to the VPN server the VPN
tunnel protects Jude's information from
being intercepted by the hacker
Jude's IP address and actual location
are changed at the VPN server to enable
a private and secure connection
finally the VPN server connects to
Jude's Bank server in the last step
where the encrypted message is decrypted
this way Jude's original IP address is
hidden by the VPN and the VPN tunnel
protects her data from being hacked this
explains how VPN makes your data
Anonymous and secure when it passes
through the public network and the
difference between a normal connection
and a VPN connection
after learning about this Jude was
certain that she should start using a
VPN to carry out her online transactions
in the future this is also applicable to
each one of us even if you work remotely
or connect to public Wi-Fi using a VPN
is the safest option
in addition to providing a secure
encrypted data transfer vpns are also
used to disguise your whereabouts and
give you access to Regional web content
VPN servers act as proxies on the
internet
this way your actual location cannot be
established VPN enables you to spoof
your location and switch to a server to
another country and thereby change your
location
for example by doing so you can watch
any content on Netflix that might be
unavailable for your region given the
current scenario cyber attacks are on
the rise now more than ever so we have
to stay alert and protect our digital
information
if you are interested in protecting
networks and computers from cyber
criminals a cyber security career is
what you should Venture into
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become a
cyber security expert let's move on to
learning about the Tor Network
Tor short for the onion router it's an
open source privacy Network that permits
users to browse the web anonymously the
thought was initially developed and
solely used by the U.S Navy to protect
sensitive government Communications
before the network was made publicly
available
the digital era has disrupted the
traditional way of doing things in every
sector of the economy the rapid rise in
development and innovation of digital
products has given way to frequent data
breaches and cyber thefts in response
consumers are increasingly operating for
products that offer data privacy and
cyber security
Tor is one such underground Network that
was implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the torn
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security concerns
the torn Network intercepts the traffic
from your browser and bounces a user's
request of a random number of other user
IP addresses then the data is passed to
the user requester Final Destination
these random users are volunteer devices
which are called as nodes or relays the
Tor Network disguises your identity by
encrypting the traffic and moving it
across different Tower relays within the
network
the Tor Network uses an onion routing
technique for transmitting data hence
the original name of onion router
to operate within the Tor Network a user
has to install the Tor Browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the
Tor Network it has its own feature set
which we will be covering over later in
this video
as we discussed already the data passing
through the Tor Network must follow a
unique protocol known as The Onion
routing protocol let us learn more about
its unique characteristics
in our normal Network usage the data is
transmitted directly
the sender has data package to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind
however since the data can easily be
captured while being transmitted the
security of this exchange is not very
reliable moreover it becomes very easy
to trace the origin of such requests on
many occasions websites with
questionable and controversial content
are blocked from the ISP this is
possible since the ISP is able to detect
and spy on user information passing
through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the internet
however in the onion routing protocol
things take a longer route we have a
sender with the top browser installed on
the client system the network sends the
information to node one's IP address
which encrypts the information and
passes it on to node 2's address which
performs another encryption and passes
it on to node 3 address
this is the last address which is also
known as the exit node this last node
decrypts the encrypted data and finally
relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user
the torn Network obfuscates user IP
addresses from unwanted surveillance by
keeping the user's requests untraceable
with multiple servers touching the data
it makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious attackers
now that we understand the way Tor works
let us learn more about the Tor Browser
the top browser was developed by a
non-profit organization as a part of the
Tor project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced
the Tor Browser is a browser forked from
the popular Firefox that anonymizes your
web traffic using the torn network if
you are investigating a competitor
researching and opposing litigant in a
legal dispute or just think it's creepy
for your ISP or the government to know
what websites you visit the top browser
might be the right solution
before the top browser were developed
using that Network to maintain anonymity
was a huge task for everyday consumers
starting from the setup to the usage the
entire process demanded a lot of
knowledge and practice the top browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers intor and
guarantee the privacy of the data
Exchange
a major feature of the Tor Browser is
the ability to delete all browser
history cookies and tracking data the
moment it is closed every new launch of
the browser opens an empty slate having
a usage habits from being tracked and
singled out
a major feature that is the highlight of
the Tor Network is the availability of
onion links
only a small portion of the World Wide
Web is available to the general public
we have the Deep Web that contains links
that are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
Tor Browser gives you access to these
dot onion websites which are only
available within the Tor Network
onion is a special used top level domain
which designates an anonymous onion
service which is also known as a hidden
service similar to The Links of the Deep
Web these onion links provide services
like online shopping cryptocurrency and
many other products not available in the
consumer Internet space
often being considered as a Haven for
illegal activities and sales on your
links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by authorities
browsing the web over Tor is slower than
the clear net due to the multiple layers
of encryption
some web services also blocked our users
door browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced store as a
Cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving towards
anonymity properties
let us take a look at some of the
advantages of using the Tor Browser of a
standard web browsers
the highlight of using the Tor Browser
is to maintain anonymity over the
Internet the cause for such requests can
differ from person to person but all of
these concerns are answered by the torn
Network
routing the information via multiple
nodes and relay servers make it entirely
difficult for the ISP to keep a track of
usage data
the entire top project is designed to be
completely free and open source allowing
the code for the browser to be inspected
and audited by Third parties helps in
the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile devices
a number of websites are blocked by
governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via tor usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the Tor Browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive circumstances
many people believe that a VPN offers
the same benefits as the top browser
let's put both of them to the test and
see the differences between them
coming to the first point of difference
Tor is completely free and open source
all of the code for the browser and the
network can be audited and has been
cleared for security concerns when it
comes to VPN there are many different
brands which have open source clients
but the same cannot be said for their
counterparts some have partly open
source while some have completely locked
up their code so that they cannot be
stored in further
moving on Tor has multiple relay points
in his data transfer protocol between
the server and the receiver there are
three different IP nodes that number can
increase but it will always be more than
two
once the data is passed from the sender
it goes through all of those delay
points while in the case of a VPN the
connection is made from the client
device to the VPN server and then to the
requested destination there is no other
IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a
one-to-one between the client and a VPN
as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes through
similarly the multi-layer encryption of
Tor is consistent if you use Tor Browser
every single request passes so the same
layer of encryption and follows the same
routing protocol when the case of a VPN
different companies offer different
levels of encryption some have multi-hop
some prefer a single one-to-one
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more variable
finally the nodes and relays being used
in the Tor Network are volunteer there
is no company holding over them so
jurisdiction becomes relatively
straightforward for instance in the case
of vpns many such vpns are hosted by
adware companies or are being monitored
by Central governments to note the usage
information
now that we have a better understanding
of the Tor Browser and its routing let
us take a look at how the Tor Browser
can anonymize and protect our internet
usage
on opening up the Tor Browser for the
first time this is the page that you are
going to be welcomed with you have the
option of connecting to the Tor Network
before we start our browsing
so let's press connect
and we can see that it is connected
coming to the anonymization
let's check my current location on
Google Chrome
currently is showing as Navi Mumbai in
Maharashtra
if we check the same link on the Tor
Browser we should get a different
address
now every link that we open in the Tor
Browser will be little delayed and the
speed will be hampered because of the
multiple layers of encryption like we
discussed now as you can see
it's showing a German IP and the state
of Bavaria
this is how the anonymization works
there is no VPN configured there is no
proxy attached it's straight up the out
of the box settings that come inbuilt
with the Tor Browser
similarly we have an option of cleaning
up the data let's say if you want to
refresh your location and you want to
use a different ID for the next browsing
session if we just restart it once
and you can have to check it again
we should be seeing a different country
this time
as you can see we have Netherlands right
now so this is how we can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that it
cannot be tracked when in browsing the
internet
like we discussed we have some onion
links that can only be used on the Tor
Network
as you can see these kind of links do
not open in the Google Chrome browser
but once we copy these over to the Tor
Browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the Tor
Network
this is kind of an alternative Wikipedia
website where we can find articles to
read and more information to learn
similarly we have another onion link
over here
which is once again available only for
the tall browser
now these kind of delays are expected
but they are a valid compromise because
they maintain the anonymity that many
people desire
similarly we have found a hidden wallet
which is a cryptocurrency wallet which
is specifically for dark web members
this operates over the Tor Network and
this is used by mostly journalists and
people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing money
all of the other torn Network are almost
impossible to track therefore these kind
of cryptocurrency wallets are very big
on the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available with every aspect of corporate
culture going online and embracing cloud
computing there is a plethora of
critical data circulating through the
internet all worth billions of dollars
to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack
a brute force or known as Brute Force
cracking is the Cyber attack equivalent
of trying every key on your keyring and
eventually finding the right one
Force attacks are simple and reliable
there is no prior knowledge needed about
the victim to start an attack most of
the systems falling prey to Brute Force
attacks are actually well secured
attackers let a computer do the work
that is trying different combinations of
usernames and passwords until the final
one that works
due to this repeated trial and error
format the strength of password matters
a great deal although with enough time
and resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is Baba from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
take a look at the topics we need to
cover today
we start by learning about what a brute
force attack is and its reliability as a
hacking technique
next we take a look at a step-by-step
approach to how the hackers can take
control of a system using Brute Force
techniques
moving on we learn about the harmful
effects of getting our personal devices
brute forced or compromised and how it
can affect not only our devices but our
friends and family as well
we also understand a few steps that we
can enforce to make a better security
system again brute first attack
specifically and finally we have a
demonstration that explains how The
Brute Force mechanism Works in a real
world situation
but before we begin make sure you are
subscribed to a simple learn Channel and
click the Bell icon to never miss an
update from us
let's begin with learning about Rufus
attacks in detail
a Brute Force attack also known as an
exhaustive search is a cryptographic
hack that relies on guessing possible
combinations of targeted password until
the current password is discovered
it can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
Network peripheral devices
the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be time
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data obfuscation are
used and at times downright impossible
however if the password is weak it could
merely take seconds with hardly any
effort
dictionary attacks are an alternative to
Brute Force attacks where the attacker
already has a list of usernames and
passwords that need to be stretched
against the target it doesn't need to
create any other combinations on its own
dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general population
there is a three-step process when it
comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in detail
in Step 1 we have to settle on a tool
that we are going to use for brute
forcing there are some popular names on
the market like hashcat
Hydra
and John the Ripper while each of them
has its own strength and weaknesses each
of them perform well with the right
configuration all of these tools come
pre-installed with certain Linux
distributions that cater to penetration
testers and cyber security analysts like
Kali Linux and parrot security
after deciding what tool to use we can
start generating combinations of
alphanumeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six digit password will create 900 000
passwords with only digits involved
add alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially
the popular tools allow customizing this
process
let's say the hacker is aware of the
password being a specific eight digit
word containing only letters and symbols
this will substantially increase the
chances of being able to guess the right
password since we remove the time taken
to generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time
in the final step we run these
combinations against the file or service
that is being broken
we can try and break into a specific
encrypted document a social media
account or even devices at home that
connect to the internet let's say there
is a Wi-Fi router
the generated passwords are then fed
into the connection one after the other
it is a long and arduous process but the
work is left to the computer other than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and The Brute Force
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely lead to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use passwords
now that we have a fair idea about how
Brute Force Works let's see if we can
answer this question
we learned about how complex passwords
are tougher to crack by Brute Force
among the ones listed on the screens
which one do you believe will take the
longest to be broken when using Brute
Force tools leave your answers in the
comments section and we will get back to
you with the correct option next week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
Brute Force attacks
a hacked laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections it has been reported on
multiple occasions where compromised
Facebook accounts are sending malicious
links and attachments to people on their
friends list
one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP Etc
personal information such as credit card
data usage habits private images and
videos are all stored in our systems be
it in plain format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other things
once a system is hacked it can also be
used as a mail server that distributes
spam across lists of victims since the
hack machines all have different IP
addresses and Mac addresses it becomes
challenging to trace the spam back to
the original hacker
with so many harmful implications
arising from a Brute Force attack it's
imperative that the general public must
be protected against such let's learn
about some of the ways we can prevent
ourselves from becoming a victim of
Brute Force attacks
using passwords consisting of alphabets
letters and numbers have a much higher
chance of withstanding Brute Force
attacks thanks to the sheer number of
combinations they can produce
the longer the password the less likely
it is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them
having alphanumeric passwords also
allows the user to keep different
passwords for different websites this is
to ensure that if a single account or a
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the incident
two-factor authentication involves
receiving a one-time password on a
trusted device before a new login is
allowed this OTB can be obtained either
via email SMS or specific 2fa
applications like authi and Aegis
email and SMS based otps are considered
relatively less secure nowadays due to
the ease with which SIM cards can be
duplicated and mailboxes can be hacked
applications that are specifically made
for 2fa Cores are much more reliable and
secure
captures are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
captcha for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of Brute Force
considerably
a definite rule that locks the account
being hacked for 30 minutes after a
specific number of attempts is a good
way to prevent Brute Force attempts many
websites lock account for 30 minutes
after three failed password attempts to
secure the account against any such
attack and an additional note some
websites also send an email instructing
the user that there have been three
insecure attempts to log into the
website
let's look at a demonstration of how
Brute Force attacks work in a real world
situation
the world has gone Wireless with Wi-Fi
taking the reins in every household it's
natural that the security will always be
up for debate to further test the
security index and understand Brute
Force attacks we will attempt to break
into the password of a Wi-Fi router for
that to happen we first need to capture
a handshake file which is a connection
file from the Wi-Fi router to a
connecting device like a mobile or a
laptop
the operating system used for this
process is parrot security a Linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
to start a demo we're going to use a
tool called air Garden which is made to
hack into wireless network specifically
at this point it's going to check for
all the necessary scripts that are
installed in the system
to crack into a Wi-Fi and to capture the
handshake file we're going to need an
external network card
the significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode
for now the wlx1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select
to be able to capture data over the air
we're going to need to put it in monitor
mode as you can see above it's written
it is in managed mode right now
so we're going to select option 2 which
is to put the interface in monitor mode
and its name is now wlan0 monitor
the monitor mode is necessary to capture
data over the air
that is the necessary Json why we need
an external card since a lot of inbuilt
cards that come with the laptops and the
systems they cannot have a monitor mode
installed
once we select the mode we can go into
the fifth which is the handshake tools
menu
in the first step we have to explore for
targets and it is written that monitor
mode is necessary to select a Target
so let's explore for targets
and press enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network jio 24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi's this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices
this channels features on one or two or
there are some many channels that the
networks can focus on
this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example
the station that you can see 5626 this
is supposed to be the macro address of
the device that is connected to a router
this PC side is supposed to be which
wi-fi it is connected to for example 58
95 d8
is this one which is the jio 24 router
so we already know which router has a
device connected to it and we can use
our attack to capture this handshake
now that we it has already ran for one
minute now that we press Ctrl C
we will be asked to select a Target see
it has already selected the number five
which is the jio 24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake for
select Network 5
and we run a capture handshake
it says we have a valid WPA WPA2 Network
Target selected and that the script can
continue
now to capture the handshake we have a
couple of attacks a Dior air replay
attack what this attack does is kick the
clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the handshake
for our demo let's go with the second
option that is the diorc air replay
attack
select a timeout value let's say we give
it 60 Seconds
and restart the script
we can see it capturing data from the
jio 24 Network and here we go
we have the WPA handshake files
once the handshake file is captured you
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a p MK ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored
the dot cap file for the path we can
let's say we can keep it in a desktop
okay we give the path
and the handshape file is generated
we can already see
a Target over here same Geo 24 router
with the BSS ID
now if we return to its main menu
we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key
so let's go to the offline WPA WP to
decrypt menu
since you'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option one
now to run the Brute Force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
air crack or we can go the hashcad
let's go with lcac plus crunch which is
a Brute Force attack against a handshake
file we can go with option two
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated
so we select yes
the bssid is the one which denotes the
jio 24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA to psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10. and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as 20.
the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password
will affect the time taken to Brute
Force for example if we already know
that or we have seen a user use the
password while connecting to the router
as something that has only numbers and
symbols then we can choose accordingly
let's say if we go with only uppercase
characters and numeric characters
go with option seven
and it's going to start decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this passphrase over here
the first five or six digits are a it
starts working its way from the end from
the last character it keeps trying every
single combination you can see the last
the fourth character from the right side
the D it will eventually turn to E
because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end
this will keep going on until all the
single characters are tested and every
single combination is tried out since
the handshake file is encrypted using
the security key that is the WPA Tookie
of the router whichever passphrase is
able to decrypt the handshake key
completely will be the key of the Wi-Fi
router this is the way we can Brute
Force into Wi-Fi routers anywhere in the
world apart from individuals
organizations worldwide that host data
and conduct business over the internet
are always at the risk of a DDOS attack
these DDOS attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to botnet farms and compromise devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest DDOS attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020. lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DDOS attacks active
involvement with hacked machines and
botners allow further penetration into
the consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems
GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DDOS
attack in 2018. widely suspected to be
conducted by Chinese authorities this
attack went on for about 20 minutes
after which the systems were brought
into a stable condition it was the
strongest leaders attack to date at the
time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
combat such attacks even after years of
experimentation DDOS attacks are still
at large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space
hey everyone this is Baba from Simply
learn and welcome to this video on what
is a DDOS attack
let's take a look at the topics we will
be covering today
we start by learning what is a DDOS
attack and how it works on a phase by
phase level
we learn about the distinct categories
in DDOS attacks and the potential aim of
hackers when the launch Adidas attack
campaign
we also look at some preventive measures
that can be taken to protect oneself
from these DDOS attacks finally we have
a demonstration of how such attacks can
hamper the working of a server system
using VMware and parrot security
operating system
but before moving forward make sure you
are subscribed to the simple learn
YouTube channel don't forget to hit the
Bell icon to receive updates about more
informative videos from our channel so
let's learn more about what is a DDOS
attack
a distributed denial of service attack
or DDOS is when an attacker or attackers
attempt to make it impossible for a
service to be delivered
this can be achieved by thwarting access
to virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications
in a Dos attack it's one system that is
sending the malicious data or requests a
detos attack comes from multiple systems
generally these attacks work by Drowning
a system with requests for data this
could be sending a web server so many
requests to server page that it crashes
under the demand or it could be a
database being hit with a high volume of
queries the result is available internet
bandwidth CPU and RAM capacity become
overwhelmed
the impact could range from a minor
annoyance from disrupted services to
experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center
the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the DDOS
campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how DDOS attack work
Adidas attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
botnet of devices
simply put a vast network of computers
are hacked via malware ransomware or
just simple social engineering
these devices become a part of the
botnet which can be triggered anytime to
start bombarding a system or a server on
the instruction of the hacker that
created the botnet
the devices in this networks are called
Bots or zombies
in the second phase a particular Target
is selected for the attack
when the hacker finds the right time to
attack all the zombies in the botnet
network send these requests the target
thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth
these can be simple ping requests or
complex attacks like SYM flooding and
UDP flooding the aim is to overwhelm
them with more traffic than the server
or the network can accommodate the goal
is to render the website or service
inoperable
there is a lot of wiggle room when it
comes to the type of DDOS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DDOS
attacks
volume based attacks use massive amounts
of bogus traffic to overwhelm a resource
it can be a website or a server
they include icmp UDF and spoofed packet
flood attacks
the size of volume based attack is
measured in bits per second
these attacks focus on clogging all the
available bandwidth for the server
thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warranty reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate users
next we have the protocol level attacks
these attacks are meant to consume
essential resources of the target server
they exhaust the load balances and
firewalls which are meant to protect the
system against the DDOS attacks
these protocol attacks include syn
floods and Smurf DDOS among others and
the size is measured in packets per
second
for example in an SSL handshake server
replies to the Hello message sent by the
hacker which will be the client in this
case but since the IP is poofed and
leads nowhere the server gets stuck in
an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgment without any end in sight
finally we have the application Level
attacks application layer attacks are
conducted by flooding applications with
maliciously crafted requests the size of
application layer attacks is measured in
request per second
these are relatively sophisticated
attacks that Target the application and
operating system level vulnerabilities
they prevent the specific applications
from delivering necessary information to
users and Hawk the network bandwidth up
to the point of a system crash
examples of such an attack are HTTP
flooding and bgp hijacking a single
device can request data from a server
using HTTP post or get without any
issues
however when the requisite botnet is
instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and unusable
but what about the reasons for such an
attack there are multiple lines of
thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a DDOS attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them
the first option is to gain a
competitive advantage
many DDOS attacks are conducted by
hacking communities against rival groups
some organizations hire such communities
to stagger their Rivals resources at a
network level to gain an advantage in
the playing field
since being a victim of a detours attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some ground
secondly some hackers launch these DDOS
attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom
the resources are jammed and the only
way to clear the way is if the target
company agrees to pay a designated
amount of money to the hackers even a
few minutes of inactivity is detrimental
to a company's reputation in the global
market and it can cause a spiral effect
both in terms of market value and
product security index most of the time
a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a while
tdos attacks have also found use in the
political segment certain activists tend
to use DDOS attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
forum primarily political these attacks
also focus on online communities ethical
dilemmas or even protests against
corporations
let's take a look at a few ways that
companies and individuals can protect
themselves against DDOS attacks
the company can employ load balances and
firewalls to help protect the data from
such attacks load balances reroute the
traffic from one server to another in a
DDOS attack this reduces the single
point of failure and adds resiliency to
the server data
a firewall blocks unwanted traffic into
a system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect adidos attack in action
early detection of Adidas attack goes a
long way in recovering the data lost in
such an event
once you've detected the attack you will
have to find a way to respond for
example you will have to work on
dropping the malicious DDOS traffic
before it teaches your server so that it
doesn't throttle and exhaust your
bandwidth here's where you will filter
the traffic so that only legitimate
traffic reaches the server
by intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by a cluster
resources
the most important stage in DDOS
mitigation is where you will look for
patterns of readers attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first step
Cloud providers like Amazon web services
and Microsoft Azure who offer high
levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and
networks from DDOS criminals the cloud
also has greater bandwidth than most
private networks so it is likely to fail
if under the pressure of increased tdos
attacks
additionally reputable Cloud providers
are for Network redundancy duplicating
copies of your data systems and
equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DDOS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a Beat
one can also increase the amount of
bandwidth available to a host server
being targeted since Cheetos attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection
this solution can prove expensive as a
lot of that bandwidth is going to go
unused most of the time
a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates DDOS attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular cdns include
Akamai CDN cloudflare AWS cloudfront Etc
let's start with a demo regarding the
effects of DDOS attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a dose
attack of sorts
once a botnet is ready multiple devices
can do the same and eventually emulate a
DDOS attack
to do so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parrot security operating system
running
for a Target machine we will be running
another VMware instance of a standard
Linux distribution known as Linux light
in a Target device we can use Wireshark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly
this is Linux like which is a target
machine and this is parrot security
which is used by the hacker when trying
to launch a DDOS attack this is just one
of the distros that can be used
to launch the attack we must first find
the IP address of our Target
so to find the IP address we open the
terminal
we use the command ifconfig
and here we can find the IP address now
remember we're launching this attack in
VMware now the both the instances of
parrot security and Linux light are
being run on my local network so the
address that you can see here is
192.168.72.129 which is a private
address this IP cannot be accessed from
outside the network basically anyone who
is not connected to my Wi-Fi
when launching attacks with public
servers or public addresses it will have
a public IP address that does not belong
to the 192.168 subnet
once we have the IP address
we can use a tool called
hp3
hping 3 is an open source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol
to check what are the effects of an
attack we will be using Wireshark
Wireshark is a network traffic analyzer
we can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the Linux light distro
is being displayed over here with the IP
address the source IP and the
destination IP as to where the request
is being transferred to
once we have the Dos attack launched you
can see the results coming over here
from The Source IP which will be parrot
security Now to launch the hping 3
command we need to give sudo access to
the console which is the root access
now we have the root access for the
console
the hp3 command will have a few
arguments to go with it which are as you
can see on the screen
minus s and a flood
a hyphen V
hyphen p18 and the IP address of the
target which is 192.168.72.129
in this command we have a few arguments
this such as the minus s which specifies
syn packets like in an SSL handshake we
have the syn request that the client
sends to the server to initiate a
connection
The Hyphen flood aims to ignore the
replies that the server will send back
to the client in response to the syn
packets here the parent security OS is
the client and Linux slide being the
server
minus v stands for verbosity as in where
we will see some output when the
requests are being sent
The Hyphen p80 stands for Port 80 which
we can replace the port number if we
want to attack a different port
and finally we have the IP address of
our Target
as of right now if we check Wireshark it
is relatively clear and there is no
indication of a DDOS attack incoming now
once we launch the attack over here
we can see the requests coming in from
this IP which is
192.168 72.128
till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux light
the requests keep on coming and we can
see the http
flooding has started in flood mode
after a few seconds of this attack
continuing
the server will start shutting down
now remember Linux light is a distro
that can focus on that serves as a
backend
now remember Linux light is a distro and
such Linux distros are served as backend
to many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack
now the system has become completely
irresponsive this has happened due to
the huge number of requests that came
from Pilot security
you can see whatever I press nothing is
responded even the Wireshark has stopped
capturing new requests because the CPU
usage right now is completely 100 and at
this point of time anyone who is trying
to request some information from this
Linux distro or where this Linux this
row is being used as a backend for a
server or a database cannot access
anything else the system has completely
stopped responding and any request any
legitimate request from legitimate users
will be dropped
once you stop the attack over here it
takes a bit of time to settle down now
remember it's still out of control but
eventually the traffic dies down and the
system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into
that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
Adidas attack comes into play what we
did right now is a Dos attack as in a
single system is being used to penetrate
a Target server using a single request
now in a DDOS attack multiple systems
such as multiple pirate security
instances or multiple zombies or bots in
a botnet network can attack a Target
server to completely shut down the
machine and drop any legitimate request
thereby rendering the service and the
target completely unusable and
inoperable
as a final note we would like to remind
that this is for educational purposes
only and we do not endorse any attacks
on any proven domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on the important
question is how to become a certified
ethical hacker in order to become a
certified ethical hacker you need to
pass the certified ethical hacker or the
ceh exam from EC Council which tests the
broad knowledge of subject matter that
is required for someone to Be an
Effective ethical hacker well since its
Inception in 2003 the certified ethical
hacker has been the absolute choice of
the industry globally it is recognized
worldwide and has been endorsed by
governmental agencies like the NSA the
CH exam is also is accredited by NC
which adds credibility and value to the
credential members the Cs exam is
computerized proctored exam you will
have four hours to complete 125
questions there are some sources of
information that mentions that in order
to pass you need to score about 60 to 80
percent the actual percentage of
questions that you must answer correctly
varies from exempt exam and depends on
the difficulty of the exams delivered
when you take the exam the harder the
questions that are asked the fewer
questions you need to get right to pass
the exam if you get easier questions
then you will need to get more of the
questions right to pass the exam however
keep in mind that when you take the
actual exam at the testing center the
passing grade may vary the CH
certification exam costs 500 plus an
additional eligibility fee of hundred
dollars the exam duration is for four
hours the questions are all multiple
choice the exam is only available in
English as of today candidates can take
the CES exam online using a remotely
proctored service from anywhere in the
world 24 7 as long as they have a
computer equipped with a webcam and a
microphone let's just discuss the exam
outline the exam is broken into seven
domains networking and information
background covers about 32 percent
analysis assessment covers 12 percent
security covers 23 percent tools system
programs 29 procedures methodology nine
percent regulation policy two percent
and ethics three percent let's discuss
these domains a little more in detail
networking and information background
this first domain of the ceh exam is
designed to test your knowledge of
everything that you need to know to
practice ethical hacking which isn't
specific to any information security
domain the objectives of this domain
include Network and communication
Technologies next is information
security threats and attack Vector such
as malware's OAS top 10 Etc the final
object active covers information
security Technologies such as mobile
technologies telecommunication
Technologies backups archiving
Etc analysis assessment this domain of
the certified ethical hacker exam is
designed to test your knowledge of what
goes into performing a penetration test
or ethical hacking the objectives of
this domain are information security
assessment and Analysis and information
security assessment process combination
of ethics and regulation policy domains
covers five percent of the total exam
weightage the objectives of this domains
are ethics of information security which
covers what is considered ethical and
unethical from the perspective of the
ceh certification not only you will be
expected to behave ethically you will be
expected to adhere to a code of ethics
next objective is information security
policies laws X which covers some of the
major information security regulations
and the evaluation of organizational
security policies this is an important
procedures methodology this is an
important domain and carries a weightage
of nine percent there are two objectives
the first objective covers information
security procedures which is the
step-by-step methods that is used to
identify prevent and enforce security
controls against unwanted Behavior the
next objective is information security
assessment methodologies which covers
security assessments to determine
security gaps that may pose a risk to
the organization tools systems programs
this domain carries the maximum
weightage of 29 and so you should expect
the maximum number of questions from
here this domain is heavily focused on
knowledge of the specific systems
programs and tools you use in ethical
hacking there are three objectives first
objective covers information security
systems such as firewalls intrusion
detection and prevention systems Siem
Solutions
Etc next objective covers information
security programs that are used to
secure a host system against malicious
attackers these programs include
antivirus anti-spyware anti-riskware ad
blockers anti-root kit Etc the final
objective covers information security
tools used for performing footprinting
and reconnaissance performing
enumeration conducting Network scanning
performing web application hacking Etc
this security domain is the second
largest domain on the exam with 23
percent weightage this domain is divided
into three objectives the first
objective covers information security
controls such as administrative controls
Tech technical controls and physical
controls the second objective
information security attack detection
covers various methods to detect attacks
against an organization's information
security the final objective information
security attack prevention covers
proactive methods that organizations can
use to protect themselves from malicious
attackers from malicious attacks let us
understand the importance of the C8
certification before getting to know
about its content
so why should you take up the CH version
11 the certified ethical hacker is the
most trusted ethical hacking
certification and a recommended one by
employers around the globe
since the introduction of the C8
certification in 2003 it is globally
recognized as a standard within the
information security field the CH
version 11 by EC Council continues to
keep up to the standard and it
familiarizes the latest hacking
techniques and teaches you Advanced
hacking tools and exploits used the CH
version 11 aligns with the current cyber
security Market requirements and adds
the latest advancements in the cyber
security field
the CH certification helps and trains
you to think like a hacker and this in
turn helps you beat a hacker and defend
your network after obtaining the Cs
certification you'll be a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a skilled professional working
in a red team environment who safeguards
networks and understands attack
strategies and mimics the skills of
malicious hackers certified ethical
hackers discover vulnerabilities in a
system and operate with permission from
the system owners only
so who can become a certified ethical
hacker and who can take up the ca
certification let us have a look at that
now
in the first case to be eligible for the
CH certification exam you need to attend
the official training from authorized
easy Council training Partners it can be
an online training or tutor-led training
from EC Council learning Partners only
then are you eligible to take up the CH
certification exam
so a candidate who has completed an
official easy Council training is
eligible to take up the exam without
going through the application process
or in the second case in order to be
considered for this credential you need
to have at least two years of work
experience in the information security
domain and you must pay a non-refundable
application fee and submit an
eligibility application form once it is
approved you can take up the CH exam
after the application is approved you
can purchase the test voucher
in the latest version of the CH we will
see the addition of various Core
Concepts moving on to our next topic let
us see how different the CH version 11
is and few of its objectives
firstly it outlines ethical hacking
Concepts cyber kill chain Concepts and
overview of information security and
various laws and regulations related to
information security the certification
briefs you about the faces of system
hacking attacking techniques and how you
can maintain access
it also briefs you about footprinting
Concepts and ways of utilizing
footprinting tools along with necessary
countermeasures
the next objective is to familiarize
with vulnerability assessment along with
a hands-on experience of various
scanning tools
next we have cyber security threats like
malware threats analysis of various
worms viruses and Trojans various
malware Concepts package sniffing
Concepts and techniques have been
introduced into this domain it also
highlights the concepts related to
social engineering denial of service
attacks SQL injection and Aviation
techniques it also speaks about Wireless
hacking Concepts and mobile device
management the concept of operational
technology is a new addition this time
next is getting acquainted with Security
Solutions like firewalls honey ports IPS
derivation and protection
our fifth point is knowing various
topics in cryptography like encryption
algorithms public key infrastructure and
cryptanalysis
moving on the next objective is to
incorporate parrot security OS as it
offers better performance on Lower
powered laptops and machines when
compared to Kali Linux
next is to learn to recognize and deal
with iot based vulnerabilities and
attacks with the CH version 11 course
that covers the latest iot hacking tools
you would be required to ensure the
safety of iot devices
our next point is with respect to the
evolving Cloud industry you would need
to learn how to identify and defend
cloud-based threats and attacks
the latest version of CH includes new
operating systems and Windows 10
configured with domain controller and
vulnerable web applications for
improving hacking skills
finally what is different is that more
than 50 percent of the CH version 11
course is dedicated to practical skills
in live ranges via EC Council Labs easy
Council leads in this aspect of the
industry now that we saw the CH exam
objectives let us look into the CH exam
topics weightage
as you see on your screens this is a pie
chart with nine domains in ch along with
their weightages you can prepare for
your exam accordingly
let us move on and take a closer look at
each of these domains their respective
subdomains and their descriptions
our first domain is information security
and ethical hacking overview
this domain consists of questions from
information security cyber kill chain
Concepts ethical hacking Concepts
various hacking Concepts and information
security laws and standards
you can expect a total number of eight
questions from this domain the weightage
of this section is six percent
the second domain is reconnaissance
techniques under the subdomains we have
footprinting and reconnaissance at first
this covers various topics like
footprinting Concepts footprinting
methodology email footprinting
footprinting through web services DNS
footprinting footprinting through social
engineering Etc
the next subdomain in this section is
scanning networks scanning networks
covers various Concepts like scanning
tools host Discovery port and service
Discovery OS Discovery draw Network
diagrams scanning Beyond IDs firewall
Etc
and our third subdomain under
reconnaissance techniques is enumeration
various topics like SNMP enumeration ntp
and NFS enumeration SMTP and DNS
enumeration and enumeration
countermeasures are covered under this
subdomain a total of 26 questions will
be asked from this domain under
footprinting and reconnaissance you will
have 10 questions and under scanning
networks and other 10 and finally under
enumeration you'll have six questions a
total weightage of 21 is given to this
particular topic
our third domain is system hacking faces
and attack techniques under a third
domain our first sub-domain is about
vulnerability analysis this subdomain
covers topics on vulnerability
assessment vulnerability classification
vulnerability assessment Solutions and
tools and various vulnerability
assessment reports our next subdomain is
about system hacking you have Concepts
like gaining access cracking passwords
vulnerability exploitation escalating
privileges maintaining access covered
under this subdomain and finally we have
malware threads under this domain
malware threads incorporate Concepts
like apt Concepts Trojan Concepts virus
and worm Concepts malware analysis and
so on a total of 21 Questions will be
asked from this domain under
vulnerability analysis there will be
nine questions asked system hacking and
other six questions and finally under
malware threats you will have six other
questions asked
that sums up to a total 21 with a
weightage of 17 for this domain
our fourth domain is about Network and
perimeter hacking
here you have various subdomains and one
of it is social engineering under social
engineering you will be asked questions
based on social engineering techniques
Insider threats impersonation on social
networking sites identity theft and so
on it you'll also have various question
on the sniffing Concepts as it is
another subdomain
you can also expect questions from the
denial of service subdomain here
questions related to botnets and DDOS
attacks will be asked various session
hijacking concepts are another crucial
part of this domain
the final subdomain is about evading IDs
firewalls and honey pots
here various Concepts on IDs IPS
firewall and honeypots are covered you
will need to understand how to evade
ideas and firewalls and how to detect
honeypots
a total number of 18 questions will be
asked from the fourth domain that is
network and perimeter hacking and the
weightage for this domain is 14 percent
our fifth domain is about web
application hacking and a first
sub-domain in it is hacking web servers
this incorporates concepts related to
web server attacks web server attack
tools patch management and so on
the next subdomain is about hacking web
applications here you have various
concepts related to bypass client-side
controls analyze web applications
footprint web infrastructure attack
access controls and how to perform
injection attacks and so on
finally under the SQL injection
subdomain you'll have questions based on
SQL injection the types of SQL injection
the SQL injection methodology SQL
injection tools evasion techniques and
SQL injection countermeasures
cure a total of 20 questions will be
asked from this domain and that is a
weightage of 16 will be given to the web
application hacking domain our sixth
domain is solely devoted to wireless
network hacking this domain focuses on
hacking wireless networks various
Wireless Concepts wireless encryption
Wireless threats Wireless hacking tools
various hacking methodologies Bluetooth
hacking and wireless countermeasures are
covered a total of eight questions will
be asked from this domain with a
weightage of six percent our seventh
domain is all about mobile platform iot
and OT hacking our first subdomain here
is hacking mobile platforms here the
concepts that are touched upon our
mobile platform attack vectors hacking
Android OS hacking iOS mobile device
management and mobile security
guidelines and tools
our next subdomain here is about iot and
OT hacking which covers Concepts on iot
hacking tools its methodologies
countermeasures and it also speaks about
OT Concepts OT attacks OT hacking tools
and OT countermeasures you have a total
of 10 questions asked from this domain
with a weightage of eight percent the
next domain is very interesting and it
is all related to Cloud the cloud
computing domain covers Concepts based
on cloud computing serverless Computing
cloud computing threats Cloud hacking
and Cloud security the weightage given
to this domain is six percent with the
total number of questions of seven and
finally we have cryptography as our
ninth domain
as the name suggests this domain covers
topics based on cryptography Concepts
encryption algorithms cryptography tools
public key infrastructure Email
encryption disk encryption cryptanalysis
and countermeasures and seven questions
will be asked from this domain with a
weightage of six percent now that you
saw the CH exam topics weightage let us
have a closer look at the CH exam
details let us first have a look at the
CH exam based on mcqs
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker with the exam code of
312-50 this example have 125 questions
with a time limit of 4 hours the test
format is multiple choice questions the
pass percentage varies ideally between
60 to 85 percent now let's have a look
at the CH practical exam details in
order to gain the CH Master recognition
it is mandatory that you take up the CH
practical exam as well the exam title is
certified ethical hacker practical and
this practical exam will have 20
questions with a duration of 6 hours
the exam format will be iLab cyber range
and finally the passing score for the CH
practical exam is at 70 percent after
clearing both the McQ based exam and the
Practical exam you can get the CH Master
recognition now that we had a look at
the CH exam details let us have a look
at the career prospects for a
professional with this certification
let's look at the critical skills you
need to become a certified ethical
hacker
first is coding
ethical hackers should have an excellent
grasp of the various programming
languages and understand the coding
techniques to gain access to any
software it will help you understand the
tools hackers develop to infiltrate a
security system
some of the popular coding languages
ethical hackers need to know are python
JavaScript PHP and SQL
coming to the second skill
so ethical hackers should know the
basics of different operating systems
specifically Linux as it is more secure
than any other operating system
most web servers run on Linux operating
system gaining access to This Server to
check for false is another must-have
skill for ethical hackers
now they also need to understand how
firewalls work as well
coming to the third skill so to become
an ethical hacker you must understand
both wired and wireless networks they
must know networks like DHCP n80 and
subnetting to investigate the different
interconnected machines in a network and
the possible security threats that this
may create now moving on to the fourth
skill
having good knowledge of Wireless
Technologies like wired equivalent
privacy or WEP Wi-Fi protected access or
WPA and Wi-Fi protected setup or WPS
will help ethical hackers regard systems
against sending information via hidden
streams ethical hackers need to grasp
how to write SQL statements for in-band
out of band and blind SQL attacks which
can swiftly compromise a database
operation and the detail tools
cryptography deals with transforming a
normal text message to a non-readable
form during the transmission to make it
incomprehensible for hackers
an ethical hacker ensures that
conversation between different people
within the organization does not leak
now coming to the final skill ethical
hackers additionally require analytical
thinking and problem solving skills to
succeed at this job
they should be able to reverse engineer
security Frameworks come up with
uncommon ways to break into a network
this also requires thinking outside the
box
now companies across various Industries
hire ethical hackers for several job
roles so once you become a certified
ethical hacker you can get into multiple
job roles let's look at a few of them
first we have security analyst
the security analysts execute security
systems to safeguard the organization's
networks data and also help to maintain
security standards
they document the security breaches and
measure the damage cost security
analysts also analyze the security
issues thoroughly to identify the root
cause
the second job role we have is
penetration tester
so penetration testers conduct tests and
purposefully try to exploit existing
computer systems and software to
identify and correct system weaknesses
they Implement solutions to enhance data
security and provide recommendations
based on an assessment of hardware and
software systems
the third job role we have for a
certified ethical hacker is security
engineer
so security Engineers understand
complicated technical issues and manage
them with a fast-paced business
environment
they also conduct proactive research to
investigate security vulnerabilities and
recommend suitable strategies
and finally we have the job role of a
security consultant cyber Security
Consultants are highly in demand today
and are amongst the heavily paid
professionals a cyber security
consultant is responsible for protecting
sensitive data that come from various
aspects of the digital world the evade
security risk and prevents cyber attacks
Security Consultants study security
criteria or cyber security criteria
security systems and validation
procedures
now before we go further I have another
question for you people
so which role do you think is the most
exciting do let us know your responses
in the comments section of the video we
would be glad to hear from you now
moving ahead
with the increasing number of cyber
attacks across the globe ethical hackers
are in demand like never before
very recently a United Nation official
warned that cyber crime went up by 600
percent during the covid-19 pandemic
as per the government data presented in
Parliament India alone reported 1.16
million cyber attacks in 2020.
that's almost 3x times more than 2019.
and according to cyber security Ventures
cyber threats will cost nearly 6
trillion US dollars in 2021. cyber
security Ventures also expects Global
cyber crime costs will grow up by 15
percent per year over the next five
years and reach 10.5 trillion US dollars
annually by 2025.
now there is a huge shortage of ethical
hacking professionals globally according
to the Bureau of Labor Statistics the
information security industry is
expected to grow 32 percent in the next
decade
another report by cyber security
Ventures tells that the world will have
3.5 million unfilled cyber security jobs
by the end of 2021.
according to a report by the data
security Council of India the Indian
cyber security services industry is
expected to grow to about 7.6 billion
dollars in 2022 and would be worth 13.6
billion dollars by 2025. so companies
are looking for trained ethical hackers
who can protect their networks and
Safeguard them from potential threats a
few of the industries that heavily rely
on ethical hackers are healthcare
companies financial institutions energy
companies and government agencies
with ample opportunities lying ahead
what's stopping you from starting a
career in cyber security
with the world churning virtual cyber
attacks are constantly flooding new
headlines covid-19 accelerated the
current digital transformation in the
year 2020 witnessed several data
breaches since technology has become
more intertwined with our daily lives it
is no surprise that the need for skilled
cyber Security Professionals is
increasing on that note hey everyone
welcome yet to another exciting video by
simply learn which will take you through
the top cyber security career options
available today but before we begin if
you're new here and haven't subscribed
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and that Bell icon for
interesting Tech videos every day
there is a significant lack of skilled
cyber security professionals who can
tackle the cyber security challenges
faced daily hence a career in cyber
security is demanding and equally
rewarding finding the right career path
in the cyber security industry isn't
always easy here we are here to help you
with that there are a few prerequisites
for a career in cyber security the basic
one being a bachelor's degree in a
subject relating to cyber security
however if you don't have a relevant
degree you can always take up relevant
cyber security certifications and
Kickstart your cyber security Journey
a few other skills like networking
knowledge of operating systems and Cloud
security are required to start and grow
your cyber security career you can check
out our video on the top 5 cyber
security skills to know more
cyber security jobs vary from entry
level to Executive management and
everything in between there are several
cyber security paths available today it
is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience here let us have a look at
the top 5 cyber security job rules today
the first job role is that of a network
engineer Network Engineers construct and
administer a company's computer networks
they are responsible for installing
configuring and supporting Network
equipment they also configure and
maintain firewalls switches and routers
this entry-level cyber security job can
help you start your journey to become an
ethical hacker the annual average salary
of a network engineer in the US is 85
000 and 98 dollars and in India it is
around 510 000 rupees
second on our list is information
security analyst as an information
security analyst your primary duty is to
protect sensitive information
information security analysts create and
Implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks they monitor data access and
ensure compliance with policies
depending on the Cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the US an
information security analyst earns eight
to nine thousand and one hundred forty
dollars annually and in India they earn
6 lakh 42 and 756 rupees
third on our list is ethical hacker they
are also known as penetration testers
they are Network Security Consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do they probe and test and network
using various penetration tools and
software they also design new
penetration tools and document the test
results in the US a certified ethical
hacker earns around ninety three
thousand dollars on an annual average
basis and in India they make around five
lakh rupees the fourth job role that we
are going to talk about is security
architect
security Architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks a security
architect approves the installation of
routers VPN and firewalls their duties
go beyond just architecture building and
including formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides security
architects in the US make a handsome sum
of 124 thousand dollars a year on an
average and in India they make nearly 21
lakh 80 000 rupees
finally fifth on our list is Chief
Information Security Officer ciso they
are senior level officers in an
organization they ensure the safety of
the information they develop Implement
and maintain information security and
risk management programs they also
interact with stakeholders and regularly
brief them with information security
concerns the average annual salary of a
chief information security officer in
the states is a whopping 165 thousand
dollars annually and in India it is 22
lakh 22 and 845 rupees several companies
are looking for skilled cyber Security
Professionals Philips Siemens Google
Microsoft and GE to name a few with
passion the right amount of experience
and relevant certifications you can grow
your cyber security career you can check
out Simply learned cyber security expert
Masters program to equip you with the
necessary skills needed to become an
expert in this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 Plus
hours of video content for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
the books we are going to talk about in
this live session will familiarize you
with hacking on the whole
to solve problems reading in general is
great as it helps with your thought
process and keeps you mentally alert it
is important that you use the
information in the upcoming books only
for lawful purposes
so let's get started and see the best
books which can help you with hacking
the first book we have is the basics of
hacking and penetration testing
this book is written by Patrick
ingridson for all your beginners out
there if you're clueless about how to go
about hacking then this is a good read
for you all having said that this book
is not just for beginners but even for
those individuals who are only exposed
to superficial penetration testing logic
this book Dives deep into the tools and
processes that are used by penetration
testers to gain access to the systems
the basics of hacking and penetration
testing book will help you achieve a
better understanding of offensive
security as well you'll be acquainted
with various faces of ethical hacking
here
the book contains seven chapters and it
focuses on hacking tools such as
backtrack Linux Google reconnaissance
nmap nessus Metasploit and hacker
Defender rootkit to name a few the fun
part is that each chapter consists of
Hands-On exercises that help you
interpret and Implement results in each
phase this book is apt for students
beginning in First Act professionals and
Security Consultants
the second book we have is hacking a
beginner's guide to computer hacking
basic security and penetration testing
it is written by John slavio
this is yet another go-to book for
beginners this book can be your first
step to a career in ethical hacking it
will cover all the basics with respect
to hacking security and Pen testing
the tools covered in this book are
history of hacking types of hackers
various types of hacking attacks basic
hacking tools and software and hiding IP
address it also speaks about mobile
hacking hacking an email address
penetration testing and spoofing attacks
up next we have hacking the art of
exploitation
it is written by John Erickson this book
has two editions one which is published
in 2003 and the other in 2008. this book
is famous for the hacking approach it
teaches it focuses on network security
and computer security it helps you
understand how to develop exploits
rather than just using them if you want
to up your ethical hacking game then
this book definitely requires a read
hacking the art of exploitation in its
second edition introduces ugc
programming from a hacker's perspective
out of the plethora of Concepts that you
will learn in this book few crucial ones
are that you will learn to program
computers using C and shell scripts you
will also be able to outplay security
measures like intrusion detection
systems having said that you will also
learn to hijack TCP connections track
encrypted Wireless traffic and speed up
Brute Force attacks
let's now have a look at the next
ethical hacking book on our list and
that is Kali Linux an ethical hackers
cookbook
this book revolving around Kali Linux is
written by himanshu Sharma
Kali Linux is primarily used for
advanced penetration testing and also
for security auditing it contains
numerous tools that are geared towards
various security tasks such as security
research penetration testing and so on
this book will help you get started with
installation and configuration of Kali
Linux which will enable you to perform
your tests
in addition to that you will learn to
perform web application exploitation
using tools such as burp you will also
be acquainted with performing Network
exploitation using Metasploit and
Wireshark lastly you will know how to
conduct Advanced penetration testing
these were few of the concepts you will
be learning besides a lot more others in
the book
at number 5 we have met hisploit the
penetration testers guide
this book is written by four authors
David Kennedy jimo godman Devon Kearns
and Marty yaharoni the magisbride
framework is a powerful tool for hackers
to exploit IP addresses and ports in it
this framework makes discovering and
exploiting vulnerabilities easy but for
first-time users it can be a little
tricky hence this book will teach you
all about Metasploit
you will learn the Frameworks interfaces
module system and more as you launch
simulated attacks after which you will
move on to Advanced penetration testing
techniques which include Network
reconnaissance client-side attacks
Wireless attacks and targeted social
engineering attacks you will also learn
to integrate next posts and map and
nesses with metasploy to alternate
discovery
up next we have penetration testing a
Hands-On introduction to hacking
this book is written by Georgia wheatman
hassanim suggests this book shows an
insight into penetration testing a
penetration tester discovers security
weaknesses in operating systems networks
and applications penetration techniques
are used to gauge Enterprise defenses
this book focuses on the core skills and
techniques of penetration tester
requires here you'll go through the
prime stages of an actual assessment
which includes gathering information
unravel vulnerabilities gaining access
to networks and so on
in addition to the above you will learn
to track passwords with the techniques
of brute forcing and word lists bypass
antivirus software automate attacks and
you will also learn to use Metasploit
framework for launching exploits and for
writing your own Metasploit modules out
of the many other learnings
moving on to our next book we have the
hacker Playbook 3. the hacker Playbook 3
practical guide to penetration testing
is written by Peter Kim
this is the third iteration of the
hacker Playbook series it brings with
itself new strategies attacks exploits
tips and tricks
besides all the new Concepts it also
highlights a few techniques from the
previous versions many schools have this
book Incorporated in their teaching
the hacker Playbook 3 red team Edition
acquaints you with the red team red team
simulate real world Advanced attacks to
test your organization's defensive teams
a red teamer will accurately test and
validate the overall security program
reading the hacker Playbook 3 will help
you advance your offensive hacking
skills and attack Parts in addition to
that it also focuses on real world
attacks exploitation custom malware
persistence and more this heavily
lattice book will incorporate several
virtual machines and custom the hacker
Playbook tools
at number 8 we have black hat python
python programming for hackers and Pen
testers
Justin Fields is the author of this book
as you know python is a very strong
programming language and it comes to
Great use when creating powerful and
effective hacking tools python is the
chosen Language by many Security
Professionals across the world and many
exploit Frameworks are written in Python
in this book you will go through the
darker side of Python's capabilities
like infecting virtual machines writing
Network sniffers creating Trojans Etc
this book covers some networking
fundamentals interesting Network tooling
web applications Windows privilege
escalation tricks and more this book as
the author says is a fun read
moving on at number nine we have the web
application hackers handbook finding and
exploiting security flaw
it is written by TAF it started and
Marcus Pinto
this new edition focuses on updated web
applications exposing them to attacks
and executing fraudulent transactions
this web application hackers handbook is
updated to speak about the latest
step-by-step methods for attacking and
defending the large range of
ever-evolving web applications
it also discusses new remoting
Frameworks HTML5 UI redress and hybrid
file attacks to name a few it looks into
attacking authentication attacking the
application server finding
vulnerabilities in source code Etc if
you have already mastered the first
edition you can focus on New Concepts in
this one
now let's head to our last book on our
list at 10 we have web security testing
cookbook systematic techniques to find
problems first
the author of this book is Parker hope
and Ben Walther
security testing is quite often a
neglected one when it comes to the tests
performed on web applications but it is
a very crucial one this book teaches you
how to check for the most common web
security issues it also acquaints you
with installing and configuring free and
good security testing tools
you will also understand how your
application communicates with users and
this book will help you build tests
pinpointed at Ajax functions and help
you automate the tests with the
knowledge of this book and the free
tools used here you can defend your site
so those were the top 10 books for
ethical hacking
now that you had a look at the books
let's move on and see how simply learn
can help you become an ethical hacker
simply learn provides a certified
ethical hacker CH version 10 course this
CS certification training course
provides you Hands-On training that will
help you master the techniques used to
penetrate Network systems and defend
your system against it simply learns
ethical hacking courses aligned with the
latest CH version 10 by EC Council here
you will learn about Trojans back doors
and countermeasures IDs firewalls and
honey pots Advanced hacking Concepts
Network packet analysis mobile and web
Technologies and advanced log management
this course content includes an
introduction to ethical hacking
penetration testing and Technical
hacking Concepts
it also speaks about SQL injection iot
hacking and cryptography to name a few
there are no prerequisites to take up
this certification training course in
this video we will run you through the
top 20 ethical hacking interview
questions based on Concepts like
networking software and programming
operating system and applications cyber
attacks and cryptography so let's get
started but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn let's start off with
question one what is a firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that I've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of a firewall
that is what how you can install a
firewall but there are different types
of firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for right so firewall is either
a hardware or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer they
secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or this allow a connection to
happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the configurations that
you have done based on the rules that
you have created on the firewall it will
then based on those rules identify
whether some traffic is allowed in that
Network or some traffic is to be blocked
from entering that Network so as the
screen shows
the firewall rules will analyze whether
the traffic is good if yes it will allow
if the traffic is bad it will block the
traffic and not allow that connection
from happening in the first place now
there are few common types of firewalls
that also need to be included in the
answer to this question and the first
one is a packet filtering firewall these
are the most common types that you will
come across which analyze packets and
lets them pass through only if they
match an establish security rule set now
here people do get confused when we say
that we analyze packets people think
that these firewalls will analyze the
contents of that packet which is not
correct
weather definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets these firewalls do not
have the capability of deep packet
inspection or a DPI as it is known if
that capability comes into the picture
you're basically looking at an intrusion
detection system or intrusion prevention
system in today's world called as a
next-gen firewall okay so packet
filtering firewall essentially will only
analyze data package for its source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocol that is being utilized
it will then map that information to the
rules that are there on the firewall and
based on those rules it will either
allow that a collection to happen or
disallow that connection from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter Network traffic
at the application Level So when you say
application Level they work at the layer
7 of The OSI model package filtering
firewalls since we have mentioned that
they've worked on IP addressing and port
numbers will work on the network layer
of the OSI model also on the transporter
because we also look at protocols proxy
firewalls will work at layer 7 which is
this application layer of the OSI model
and we'll deal with application Level
protocols such as HTTP https FTP SMTP
and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer app inspection firewall
these filter packets are the network
transport and application layers so they
basically do the job of the first and
the second type of firewalls
the packets are compared to known
trusted packets but now the first
question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type 1 and type 2 firewalls like
packet filtering and proxy firewalls
that is because that is how the
firewalls have evolved we started off
with a packet filtering then we added
functionality to it and so on so forth
so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall is to allow
good traffic and disallow bad traffic
based on the rules that have been
configured on the firewall and then
you've got basically three types of
firewalls packet filtering proxy and
stateful multi layer and just include a
brief description of each of these
firewalls so that's question one moving
on to the question two
what is a VPN
VPN is also called a virtual private
Network it is a connection between a VPN
server and a VPN client
so it basically creates a encrypted
tunnel between the client and the VPN
server which is then utilized to secure
the connections that you are making with
the internet so as you can see in the
diagram
the user has a VPN client installed on
their machine the VPN client then
creates an encrypted tunnel to the VPN
server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the VPN server uh sent to
the internet information can received
can be received backed by the VPN server
the VPN server will encrypt the data
back and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to
eavesdrop on the communication mechanism
they will not be able to do so because
of the encrypted tunnel it is very
difficult to decrypt this or hack
through this encrypted tunnel it is
possible but it is very difficult to
achieve that then question number three
how do you keep a computer secure now
this is going to be a very generic
question so you want to put your best
foot forward and you want to identify
the most common methodologies on how we
can keep a computer secure
so when we talk about computers the
first thing that you want to talk about
is authentication mechanisms where you
want multi-factor authentication or
two-way authentication to ensure that
your accounts are secured now if you
look at using passwords depending on how
passwords are being stored by the
application uh password attacks can be
possible either a Brute Force attack or
a dictionary based attack
or even password guessing attacks are
possible to mitigate those kind of
attacks you will need multi-factor
Authentication
to ensure that accounts are kept secure
now even if we are using multi-factor
authentication we also want to look at
secure passwords which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a Brute Force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible so we want
to randomize our passwords we want to
create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as meat has at
least one lowercase one uppercase
character has numerics and
special characters and is randomized is
not based on a dictionary word doesn't
contain usernames email addresses phone
numbers or anything that is personal to
that particular user third keep regular
updates which means that there will be
patches that will be released for the
application for the software that you
are utilizing download the patches
install them on a regular basis to
ensure that you are secured against the
most recent attacks that have been
identified
install a good antivirus
could be a Internet Security Suite which
will have an anti-virus intuition
detection system a firewall and will
help you protect yourself against
ransomware's malware and any script
based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system could be a host based firewall or
a network based firewall to ensure that
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices
have anti-fishing softwares installed as
well to ensure that you are not getting
any spam mails even if you do you're
able to identify that and not fall prey
or victim to those spam mails phishing
attacks are generic where they are
directed towards individuals
and they prey on the gullibility of that
particular individual so our Nigerian
frauds or the lotteries that we win on a
regular basis of hundreds of million
dollars uh those messages the emails
that we receive they are all phishing
emails where uh they're basically
prone to victimize the user and then Rob
them of money or install some malware
or do some other malicious activity if
you want to enhance encryption about
data that you have stored on your
devices or on your or that is accessed
by your software or being transmitted by
your software use encryption encrypt
your data whether it is at rest whether
it is in motion or whether it is at use
thus reducing data leakage and data loss
possibilities and finally in the
foremost secure your DNS DNS is the
domain name server which is utilized by
computers to resolve domain names to IP
addresses
if a DNS poisoning attack is possible
where your DNS settings have been
modified by an attacker and you are
redirected to a malicious DNS server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload also you don't want people
to know your DNS servers and the queries
that you are making so you want to use
secure DNS or DNS over https to encrypt
your TNS queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps
your devices your computers your
applications are going to be as secure
as possible moving on to question number
four what are the different sources of
malware now malware stands for malicious
software right malware is basically a
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload of attrition
virus spyware keylogger or sub manager
software that is going to have a
negative impact on security of your
particular device
so the question here is what are the
different sources of malware we want to
identify the most common sources through
which malware's in fact end user devices
in today's world and you can start with
pop-up ads so most of the websites if
you're visiting untrusted sites if
you're being redirected to sites that
you don't know about there will be a lot
of pop-ups coming your way where it says
you're the one millionth visitor to this
site please click here to download your
gift
or it will say uh congratulations on
winning a particular product for
visiting this page and so on so forth
there are some instances where you can
see a banner which is flashing at you on
top of the page and says that there are
eight uh infections that have been
identified on your computer click here
to download an antivirus to clean the
infections so all of these pop-ups
are there as a social engineering attack
as a phishing attack to make gullible
people click on those links and download
those malwares now the software that is
posing as a security software itself can
be a malicious software which is going
to install a Trojan or a virus or a bot
on your machine compromising the
security of that machine
the second is removable media USBS and
humans have a fascination with USB so if
you find a USB lying around it's a free
USB you get excited about it and you
want to take it home you want to plug it
into a machine and see what's on the USB
worst case scenario you format it and
you've got a free USB to utilize higher
the capacity the better but that is one
of the most easiest way people
use malware to uh to be deployed on
unsuspecting users if there is a USB
lying around
why would why would somebody want to
forget a USB it's most likely planted
over there as a social engineering
attack so that a gullible person is
going to pick it up plug it into their
device if the device is not secured
enough
it is going to install the malware right
uh then documents and executable files
this is where your viruses and all those
Creeps in so let's say you're surfing on
the internet you're looking for a
software uh and you find the software on
a particular website you do not verify
the trustworthiness of that site and you
just download and install that software
now that software could be malware as
well thus if you're surfing on the
internet you're downloading files from
different locations you have to research
the website you have to research the
source to ensure that it is trustworthy
and only then are you going to download
and execute those files does internet
downloads as well and when we say
internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrents we
go to uh the dark web or the Deep Web
and we are searching for other softwares
especially those who are researching
security right we always want we are
always on the lookout of new softwares
and we're always on those forums which
may not be so much trustworthy and we
just download those files can start
installing them that is a very bad
scenario right so you have to be very
careful what you are downloading from
the internet your antiviruses your uh
anti-fishing mechanisms you have hit
intelligence mechanisms uh have those uh
mechanisms installed and you want to
verify where your downloads are coming
from then your network connections if it
is a P2P connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify whom
which devices are connected to your
machines and you have to validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices and before you connect to
them
if you're on a public Wi-Fi you probably
don't want to connect to a public Wi-Fi
in the first place
then comes email attachments
there are so many attachments that come
across in today's world most of them in
a zip format or a RAR format uh
some of them come as document files
where there are macros hidden within
them macros are scripts that are
recognized by Microsoft Office files
right and then finally there are these
vanishes equities wins that we find
online right uh Let It Be Facebook let
it be WhatsApp let it be uh
any social media platform that you go or
even your search engines their job is to
display ads their job is not to verify
whether the ad is legit or not it is for
us as consumers to be careful and
validate that ad and verify whether it
is a genuine ad or not so just don't
start clicking on any of the ad trusting
uh the platform that you're on be be
sure that you are investigating that ad
so these are the most common
sources of malware and the end user
will always get infected by one of these
mechanisms then moving on to question
number five
how does email work now this is a very
uh
can be a complex question but we have to
keep it as simple as possible and we
have to identify that there are two
servers where both of them either using
SMTP where which is the simple message
transfer protocol where in this scenario
John
wants to send an email thus they've got
an email client installed on their
machine which is connected to the mail
Exchange Server which has a DNS server
which Maps the routing and which maps
The Exchange Server and inboxes so when
John composes that message and clicks on
send John should be connected to a Mail
Exchange Server where the email is sent
through that particular person's inbox
so so John's inbox will then uh be
validated and that email will then be
sent through the DNS server uh through
the internet and will be received by the
recipient mail server so at this point
in time John also requires the
recipient's email address so in this
case this is Jack so Jack at
something.com would be uh the email
address so while John is composing the
two field will have jax email address
the from field will have John's email
address the subject field will have
whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself and then when John clicks
on send it will go to their Exchange
Server the extension server will then
validate the Inbox and identify where
that inbox is located for Jack and then
to the internet it will be sent to the
email to the mail server of Jack the
mail server will then identify the
proper
that that email is to be sent to and it
will store that email in that particular
inbox when Jack opens their computer and
accesses their inbox this email from
John will be already waiting for them
and they can respond to it the same way
John had sent that email
moving on to question number six what is
black box and white box testing so when
you are testing a software or you are
testing your infrastructure there are
two different tests that you can conduct
the first one is a black box the second
one is a white box in a black box test
there is no knowledge that is shared
with the tester so let's say your
ethical hacker
and you have been avoided a contract by
an organization to test their current
application that they have developed now
they are not going to give you any
information they are not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an IP address and a
port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to find in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identify both abilities and see
if any of those vulnerabilities can lead
to a security incident so without any
knowledge zero knowledge of the ID
infrastructure or the source code that's
a black box attack or a black box test a
white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the IIT
infrastructure or the source code is
shared so the ethical hacker has
complete knowledge and based on the
knowledge they are then going to test
out the system to see if there are any
flaws that they can identify right so
why would these two audits be important
because the first one a black box audit
emulates the attack of a Outsider a
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an Insider so a
disgruntled employee within that
organization misusing their access
controls or the access rights to make uh
unvalidated profits right so somebody's
corrupt who has been bribed who wants to
sell out company Secrets based so
they're going to try to find out whole
Liberties try to steal data and try to
sell it on the uh gray market right so a
white box would emulate uh internal
attack a black box would emulate an
external attack the next question is
what are the steps involved in hacking a
server or a network so this is more of
an ethical hacking question you're
looking at devices and for uh and the
interviewer asks you uh what kind of
steps are involved what are the
activities that you would do in hacking
a server or a network now there are no
specific steps that you would Define
because every hack is going to be unique
but it has a hack can be classified in
five different steps
which are quite generic right so the
first step will always always be the
recognizance step also known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting uh
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase
the attacker gathers all the evidence
all the information that is possible
about the targets that they want to
attack so here you are trying to get to
know the victim so you can launch
specific attacks towards them you want
to identify what operating system they
are utilizing what IP addresses Mac
addresses the versions of the operating
systems and applications the patch
levels find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible find
out the information about the a person
who's using those computers so you can
launch social engineering attacks and so
on so forth so the first step is all
about gathering enough information based
on which you can launch further attacks
once you have that information comes the
second phase which is known as the
scanning phase this is more of a
technical phase so yeah in the first
step you've got your IP addresses domain
names maybe even Network maps and you
have identified which devices are
available now in the scanning phase
you're going to identify live devices
and then you're going to scan them for
open ports processors protocols Services
you're going to identify vulnerabilities
you're going to enumerate them to
identify more information from them
thus at this point in time you will have
identified a certain set of
vulnerabilities or a certain set of
security loopholes that you can misuse
once you have identified those
you are going to The Next Step which is
the gaining access tape in this you're
actually going to execute your attacks
based on the viabilities that you have
found and you are either going to gain
access to that particular system by
installing a Trojan or a destroyer
system by installing a virus or install
a spyware or a key logger whatever you
wanted to achieve so in the gaming
access phase you would have based on the
knowledge that you have had in the first
and the second phase you're going to
launch your attacks and you're going to
try to gain access to that particular
device
then the next step is where you're going
to maintain that access now that you
have hacked into that device it is not
necessary that you will always be able
to get access to that device suppose you
have cracked the password of that
particular user and the user changes
that password after a few days your
attack is worthless so what you're going
to do here is you're going to maintain
your access
so this is where it is assumed that you
want repeated access to that device and
thus you're going to install a keylogger
or a Trojan or sub mechanism which will
still allow you to get access to that
device without the knowledge or the
authorization of that particular user
and finally the last step is where you
are going to cover Your Tracks so
whatever activity that we have done so
far will have created logs and will have
created information based on which the
victim will come to know that they have
been compromise and may be able to trace
that activity back to you so to prevent
the user or the victim from realizing
that they have been hacked and to
prevent them to discover who has hacked
them you want to cover your tracks by
deleting logs and any references that
point to that particular activity you're
going to hide the files that you have
created so you've installed a tourism or
a key logger these will create files and
directories you're going to hide them so
that they are not discovered you're
going to hide processes that have been
created you're going to try to hide all
the activity that you have done so that
to conceal the actual attack and
preventing the user from realizing that
they have been compromised so these are
the five steps that will be involved in
hacking a server Network application or
any Computing device you will come
across the next question refers to what
are the various sniffing tools now this
is a network based attack where you're
trying to capture a data package that
that have been transmitted over the
network and then you're going to analyze
them to see if you can capture any
sensitive information like usernames
passwords Bank details or any anything
of that sort now these tools will also
depend on which operating system you're
utilizing for example MSN sniffer would
work on Microsoft operating systems
would be based on Linux and so on so
forth so on the screen you'll see six
different sniffing tools that work on
different operating systems Wireshark is
uh something that is common both on
Windows and Linux
it is used to analyze Network in detail
it is the de facto tool that you will
come across in most of your ethical
hacking trainings in most of your
organizations when they want to do data
captures
now data capturing or packet capturing
is not only done by hackers to gather
more information but it is also a known
troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so wow the first tool you see on
the screen is Wireshark like we stated
is available for Windows Linux as well
then there is TCP dump which again has
the same capability of Wireshark but is
a command line version whereas Wireshark
also has a GUI a graphical user
interface TCP dumped is available on
Linux
Amazon sniffer it's a very old tool uh
when we had MSN Messengers MSN Messenger
is no longer there but Microsoft does or
did have a Microsoft message analyzer
Tool uh which they have stopped
development since 2015 but that's
another tool that is specific for
Microsoft operating systems from
Microsoft you are can be installed to
gather more information then you've got
ETA cap which is a tool to launch man in
the middle attacks data capturing and is
is essentially a Linux command line
based tool then D Smith is another
password and network capturing tool
which can help you capture data packets
prominently a Linux 2.
same with heat array
this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to capture data data traffics
and map protocols and identify which IP
addresses have been communicating with
what essentially all of the tools have
similar functionality except that some
have addition functionality like logic
man in the middle attacks or capturing
or having specific filters that will
help you identify and troubleshoot some
network issues that you may be facing
question 9 what is SQL injection SQL
stands for structured query language
which is a language that is used by most
of your databases or your relational
databases the variations of your
database would be MySQL Microsoft SQL
Oracle SQL
you'll have IBM databases all of these
databases utilize the structured query
languages to interact with the
applications now all of these databases
have their own syntax so you'll have to
study most of these databases based on
which applications and which databases
you want to provide security for
but as the name suggests SQL injection
vulnerability or a structured query
language injection vulnerability is
where a user can maliciously inject a
SQL input
or a SQL statement in a query and
send it to the database and evoke a
response response out of it
so this vulnerability is not
specifically to the database it uh the
vulnerability lies more in the
application and the coding of that
application so when the application
receives a query which it needs to be
forwarded to the SQL database we need to
configure at the application Level of
what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various aspects
of how to manage a SQL injection
vulnerability but the basic flaw lies in
the application where uh invalidated
input is accepted and sent forward to
the database where the database might
confuse it into an executable statement
and thus create a response that was not
warranted there are various types of SQL
injections as shown on the screen in
band circuit injection where you can
look at an error based or a union based
rejection a blind SQL injection where it
is either Boolean based or a time-based
attack and then an out of bound SQL
injection essentially you're looking at
databases and you're looking at
application security however you want to
encourage secure coding practices so in
unvalidated input is mitigated the next
question is what is spoofing
now in spoofing you're basically
assuming the identity of another person
so here the attacker pretends to be some
other person or an organization and
sends you an email that appears to be a
legitimate email it looks almost genuine
it has been constructed to replicate
what a genuine email would have been
and it is very difficult to spot a fake
one there are different ways to identify
whether an email is genuine or not if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
moving on to the next question what is a
distributed denial of service attack or
a DDOS attack now generally a denial of
service attack is an attack where
legitimate users are prevented access to
the resources that they legitimately can
access right so for example if it is a
bandwidth-based attack the attacker
consumes the bandwidth of the network in
such a way that there is no more
bandwidth left for legitimate users to
access the network
now a single device may not be able to
generate that much amount of traffic to
consume the bandwidth of a huge server
thus the attacker will construct a
botnet and through that botnet they will
launch a distributed denial of service
attack
to the Target victim right so a botnet
there are two terms that you want to
look at over here the first term is a
bot and the second one being the botnet
itself bot is a software that once
installed on a victims machine allows
the hacker to send remote commands to
that machine that will make it to
generate some activity
once we have enough machines on which
such Bots have been implemented the
collection of these machines would be
known as a botnet so an attacker would
then instruct this entire botnet to
start generating data traffic to be to
be sent to the targeted Network or to
the targeted server which will then bog
down the server thus crashing it and
preventing users from accessing that
particular Source the next question is
how to avoid ARP poisoning or ARP now
first let's understand what ARP is ARP
stands for address resolution protocol
which is a protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network once you
compute a bootstrap
it starts a discovery process of
identifying its neighbors so if I'm in a
particular subnet my machine will
proactively send out ARP request an
address resolution protocol to find out
which other machines are within the same
network and which are live once it sends
out a query a live machine will respond
to that query along with its Mac address
this information is then stored in what
is known as a ARP table or an ARP table
on the machines cache
so whenever my machine now wants to send
out a packet to this particular machine
it will go to the ARP table it will
identify the IP address and the
associated Mac address it will print
that onto the data packet as a
destination uh IP and destination Mac
and Center packet across the switch the
switch will then identify the MAC
address and send the packet to the
relevant machine that is connected to
that particular switch
now to confuse this switch into sending
it to a different machine so our
poisoning attack is created this attack
is generally launched to
create a man in the middle attack now to
prevent this R poisoning from happening
in the first place there are three
different aspects that we can utilize
first we can use packet filtering which
will filter filter out and block packets
that are the same Source address data so
you have identified some malicious IP
addresses and you want to block out some
IP addresses so you're using a packet
filter firewall where you have
constructed the firewall to filter out
certain package
originating from particular range of IP
addresses this firewall and this
technique will then block those kind of
packets coming in
second keeping away from trust
relationships organizations will develop
protocols that do not depend on trust
relationships and thus you want to keep
this protocol away from there once you
have created a trust relationship
these machines should not be sending out
ARP requests to other machines in the
first place since the trust relationship
has been defined and these machines know
whom to communicate with such kind of
protocols should then be disabled or you
can use Erp spoofing software so there
are some there are softwares out there
that will look for ARP spoofing and
prevent that from happening in the first
place so if somebody has sent out a
spoofed ARP packet that package will be
picked up by this software and it will
be mitigated of network visualizers like
glass wire antiviruses like so force uh
they have inbuilt capabilities of
identifying uh our apps moving attacks
and mitigate them in the first place in
the next question we are going to
discuss what is ransomware now
ransomware is a type of malware that
blocks victims to access personal files
and demands Ransom to regain access
there are three categories before we go
into the categories let's just revisit
water and software is let's start with
the word malware malware is a malicious
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload that will
have a security impact on your machine
so in this instance viruses Trojans all
of these can be classified under
Maldives so can Ransom which a Trojan is
a software that will give you backdoor
access to a to a particular device a
virus will do some destructive activity
on that device a ransomware will
basically encrypt the data of that
particular user from on that particular
machine thus rendering that that data
inaccessible to the users themselves
and in turn will demand The Ransom to
provide access to that particular data
so the three types of ransomware is the
first one is square wear which uses
social engineering to cause anxiety or
the perception of a threat to manipulate
users into buying unwanted software so
this sprays on the gullibility of humans
where you can see a pop-up appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a particular software to
mitigate that particular virus now
the malware will be in this software
that you will be downloading and then a
ransomware will be installed and your
data will be encrypted
screen lockers uh were locking uses
computers by preventing them from
logging in and displaying an official
looking message you will see a screen
saver once you boot up which prevents
you from accessing the login page so it
will not allow you to log into your own
machine but it will give you a warning
that your data has been encrypted and
you need to connect to a particular
email address and send bit to send
Bitcoins over there to get a decryption
key to access your own data and then the
encrypting ransomware displays a message
demanding payment in the return for the
private asymmetry key which is needed to
decrypt the symmetric keys for encrypted
file so once your files have been
encrypted you might just have a blank
screen in front of you where you'll
receive a warning message where it
instructs you to pay up a ransom in
Bitcoins or in some cryptocurrency to
some particular digital e-wallet which
is not traceable and once you make that
payment they will send you the
decryption key and then you can access
your data then talking about the next
question what is the difference between
an active and a passive Cyber attack now
when we talk about cyber attacks Cyber
attack is a activity that is caused by a
malicious user who wants to try to get
access or do some security incidents
on the victim's devices so there are two
ways that can happen it's either in an
active manner or a passive manner in an
active manner the inputer attempts to
disrupt a Network's normalcy modifies
data and tries to alter the system's
resources so this is more active where
the attacker will proactively try to
destroy the network so that
Communications fail or they might try to
modify the data where uh we're using a
ransomware they can encrypt it or they
might delete that data using a virus or
steal that data using a Trojan or they
might even alter the data so that it is
no longer trustworthy whereas in a
passive attack the Intruder intercepts
data traveling through a network here
the into the eavesdrop but does not
modify the message so they're just
listening in they're just observing what
is going on they are not manipulating
the data they are not stealing anything
it's just that they are monitoring the
activity that's going on then the next
question what is a social engineering
attack now social engineering attack is
a people-based attack the victim here is
the Human by itself the vulnerability
also lies in the human it may be
executed through a computer but end of
the day recalibilities of the human so
it is the art of manipulating people so
that they end up giving up confidential
information
now we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out right because they said
the OTP with someone or they shared up
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will fall
prey to this attack and share this kind
of personal information to unknown
people that is where the social
engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information now there are
three categories in this attack the
first one is a phishing attack second is
a spear phishing attack and a third is a
railing attack now phishing attack is
basically a generic attack
it is targeted To The World At Large
whoever Falls prey to that attack will
be a victim
whereas a spearfishing attack is a
targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into
spearfishing where you analyze the
victim you try to figure out what their
vermilities are and your tailor make or
you customize the attack
do that particular vulnerability once
you have that attack you launch it
against those people those people
will then fall prey to this attack and a
wailing attack is where you're attacking
uh top level Executives so the c-level
executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people uh so any of these
people when they're attacked it will be
known as a wailing attack
next question what is man in the middle
attack now this is something that we are
touched based when we talked about ARP
where the ARP poisoning attack needs to
be executed to leverage a man in the
middle attack now in the man in the
middle attack
the attacker attacking computer takes
the IP address of the client unaware of
this the server continues to communicate
with the attacker now if you remember in
a previous question we have also talked
about spoofing so in this scenario uh
attacker has spoofed their IP address to
replicate themselves as a genuine client
and now with that spoofing in mind they
might either throw our poisoning attack
or just because of the spoofed IP
address become a man in the middle that
means that they are now eavesdropping on
the conversation between the actual
client and the server by posing
themselves as a server in this scenario
the attacker is now a go between between
the client and the server and can
eavesdrop and can copy the data if they
want they can modify the data as well so
as you can see on the screen the
attacker becomes a man in the middle
which means that they are now
eavesdropping on the conversation that
is happening between the client and the
server the next question
who are black ad hackers and Whitehead
hackers the main thing is the
differentiation between a black hat
hacker and a wildcat hacker now a
blackhead hackers are skilled
individuals
who illegally hack into a system the
motive behind such an attack is mostly
for monetary game these individuals are
known also known as security crackers
now if you look at your criminal hackers
those who have malicious intent those
who do hacking for the intent of
personal gain or for the matter of
disruption the main thing that blackhead
hackers lack
is authorization they are not authorized
to do the activity that they are about
to do and they are going to get
unauthorized access to devices or to
data which is going to cause losses to
the organization involved
whereas on the other side a whitehead
hiker are also known as ethical hackers
these are the individuals who discover
vulnerabilities in a computer network
and they help the organizations mitigate
these vulnerabilities they help the
organizations defend themselves from
black hat hackers so the main difference
between these two types of hackers a
blackhead and a white hat is the intent
and the authorization so black hat
hackers will have malicious intent they
will try to personally gain from that
attack
from by finding your vulnerabilities
they also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side Whitehead
hackers will be hired by organizations
they will provide authorization for
certain activity that the Whitehead
hacker can do to find out those
vulnerabilities once those
vulnerabilities have been found found
out by the Whitehead hacker they will
reported to the management and guide
them in implementing security controls
to mitigate those vulnerabilities the
main difference between a blackhead and
a white hat is the authorization and the
intent the next question what are
honeypots
now honeypots are a very interesting
device that can be introduced in a
network uh these basically are decoy
servers that are implemented in a
network to attract the attention of our
attacker
it is there to lure an attacker uh into
uh attacking that particular device thus
creating a security blanket blanket for
the rest of the devices
so if an attacker has been able to
bypass a firewall and is now trying to
scan a particular Network when they Scan
they will come across various devices
that are there in the network they will
then proceed to do a vulnerability scan
on these devices the Honeypot at that
point in time will provide us and
approve as an attraction to these
attackers because it will
demonstrate some vulnerabilities to the
hacker which will divert their attention
so these vulnerabilities are simulated
on these devices these actually do not
exist but the moment the attacker then
starts interacting with the Honeypot the
Honeypot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will warm the warn
the administrator about a possible
attack that is going on the
administrator will then investigate
through the Honeypot of what activity is
going on and then reconfigure the
security controls to block the attacker
or mitigate the attack itself right so
it is more of a decoy server that will
showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities to an attacker thus to
lure them and Safeguard the rest of the
network when we go to the next question
Define cryptography encryption and
decryption now cryptography is used by
Security Professionals to scramble data
into non-readable format which is used
in securing that information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format and then reversing it back to
readable format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like an
unreadable format now if you look at
this word that it has been scrambled
into it would be very difficult
for a human to figure out what the
actual world was now in this scenario we
have taken an algorithm where we have
made a shift of the alphabet where we
have added two alphabets the current one
so C plus 2 becomes e
o plus 2 becomes q m plus 2 becomes o so
we have done a shift of 2 and thus the
key over here for this algorithm is the
alphabet plus two so any person who
figures that out will be able to
unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text the fact of
scrambling a readable text Data into
something that is unreadable by using a
particular key is What cryptography is
all about
now as we discussed the decryption again
is replacing the alphabet and taking it
further back by two characters so e
minus two becomes c q minus 2 becomes o
o minus 2 becomes M and so on so forth
so anybody who knows this key uh the
shift key
anybody will able to decrypt this
particular character so this depends on
the user if I want to utilize alphabet
plus five then the spacing the shifting
of that character will be the fifth
character from that particular character
and so on so forth and now the last
question what is the difference between
ciphertext and clear text
ciphertext refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible so the word computer is
clear text that means that it has not
been treated to any cryptographic
measures it does what it is intended to
be however if the moment we encrypt it
that means we scramble it into
unreadable text by using any of the
algorithms that we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text
and without the key this becomes
unreadable
the clear text as discussed is the plain
word that we have utilized we are using
the English language in this instance so
the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
hope you all enjoyed learning about
ethical hackers and the lucrative
profession if there are any queries
based on this topic feel free to let us
know in the comment section below and we
will get back to you as soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more
informative videos like this and thank
you for watching
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here